what's going on guys this is Rob and per
your request we are remastering
spider-verse at least 70 of you guys
said you wanted me to remaster
spider-verse more like 75 because
Spider-Man no way home is a giant
multiversal story so I guess it makes
sense and so in order to make things
easier for you guys I'm gonna put the
reading order down in the description so
you guys can basically keep up as you
guys buy the comics and and read them
and so on and so forth uh but this picks
up with superior Spider-Man now for
those of you guys who don't know what
that is superior Spider-Man was the
story arc where Dr Octopus took over the
body of Peter Parker and so he basically
became the new Spider-Man it was an
amazing Story the entirety of the
spider-verse event actually happens
between two issues with superior
Spider-Man so you don't really see the
event play out per se and The Superior
Spider-Man comic as it was initially
written instead what you get are
superior Spider-Man tie-in stories to
the events of spider-verse and so the
way this would happen is that there was
basically this giant explosion that took
place uh that was a result of a temporal
meltdown at Horizon Labs now those are
guys you may be familiar with it if you
guys saw the movie obvious trailer you
saw Horizon one of the buildings in the
background it was literally the only
building with red Lighting on it right
red wording so of course we seem to know
that Mobius takes place in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe or at least that
seems to be the case Horizon Labs is
really a think tank when it comes to the
Marvel Comics Universe right just where
a bunch of smart people hang out and
just think of cool stuff and so with
that explosion taking place superior
Spider-Man was thrown into the time
stream now this happening was actually
pretty cool because if you look at this
scene where he's thrown into the time
stream and the very top left-hand Corner
that's the Earth X Captain America
that's actually the universe of the
eternals film is based off of next to
him is what looks like the Incredible
Hulk because it is he's actually called
Maestro and it's basically a future
version of The Incredible Hulk where the
world hits succumbed to like nuclear war
and he basically LED this city called
dystopia over on geek culture explained
I still stand by the fact and I'm making
the argument over there that what Bruce
Banner saw in Avengers Age of Ultron was
actually himself becoming the Maestro
but you just see these kind of alternate
realities right Old Man Logan different
things along those lines but he's just
kind of thrown into the time stream
until ultimately he arrives in the 2099
Universe now the 2099 Universe of Marvel
Comics is actually a really really cool
Universe it was created by Peter David
and it's been around since the 90s in
fact it was one of the more popular
lines of Comics Marvel had in the 90s
like most of those alternate realities
like the Ultimate Universe stuff like
that it started with Spider-Man and then
over time just became less interesting
you got stuff like the 2099 Incredible
Hulk and like 2099 Punisher and Dr Doom
and different things along those lines
but it's basically the the future right
now instead of having like New York what
you have is Nueva York just kind of like
this Future Super technologically
advanced place but by and large the
whole area is ran by alcamax and this is
important because one superior
Spider-Man gets into this place because
he's somewhat familiar with 2099 then of
course he's able to make his way through
there to a degree and he's basically set
upon by what's referred to as the public
eye now the public eye in the 2099
Universe they're basically private
police that are actually hired and
worked for alcamax the company that
seemingly runs everything or at least
basically all of New York but when this
happens of course he's able to get past
these guys quite readily and then he's
met by Gabriel O'Hara now Gabriel O'Hara
is the brother of miguela O'Hara also
known as Spider-Man 2099 at the moment
he's not here he's missing he's actually
out doing his own thing and we'll follow
up with him relatively soon but the idea
of Dr Octopus a really superior
Spider-Man being in this place of course
he's greeted by Gabriel and then he's
like I don't need you anymore right like
all I want to do is find my way back
home back to my native universe and
we're going to call it a day now here's
the funny thing about this when it comes
to Dr Octopus historically in the movies
his intelligence has been downplayed
despite how smart you've seen him come
off in the movies he's just not nearly
as intelligent in the movies as he is in
the comics in the comics he's light
years ahead of everybody he's like Tony
Stark right he's a futurist he's always
thinking to the Future always looking to
the Horizon and so he's basically given
this kind of sentient AI computer system
which is partially self-aware but still
has to follow the programming that's
assigned to it and asks it the best way
to achieve interdimensional travel or
time travel now as you would expect time
travels highly regulated in any one
particular universe and a lot of This
falls in line with the nature of
organizations like the time various
Authority itself as well as the
organizational structures of that
particular universe and what I mean by
that is the TVA as most of you guys
probably know from the Loki series
albeit that series was a little bit
different from the comics that it is by
and large charge governed by the
timekeepers and the goal of the
timekeepers is to basically ensure their
existence right that they come into
existence at the end of time and they
want to make sure that like nothing
happens across the Multiverse that
prevents them from existing and so they
closely monitor individuals who travel
back and forth through time making sure
they don't disrupt the time stream too
much so there's that kind of Regulation
that goes into it at the same time if
you're a massive company like alcamax
and you have all this power you don't
want anybody going back in time and
preventing your company from existing
and so that's the kind of Regulation you
end up seeing people who aren't meddling
with time and like disrupting existing
status quoes or possibly even sending
the Universe on a collision course to a
far worse future than the one that
currently exists so there's all kinds of
things you can screw up with time and
that's why it's monitored so closely
fortunately for us superior Spider-Man
doesn't care
it doesn't matter to him and in fact he
actually ends up breaking into all these
different facilities and stealing all
these different things he needs in order
to attain the ability to travel through
time or to move from one dimension or
one Universe to the next now with Dr
Octopus he can get away with that right
it's like giving Tony Stark the ability
to achieve time travel just part and
parcel of his intelligence is knowing
there's some things you just can't do
right you can't disrupt time too much
you've got to be very very careful
another part of this is that as he's
been working with this AI then this is a
particularly important Point going
forward he actually tells it to start
modifying its physical appearance so it
looks like Anna Maria Marconi now the
reason why that matters is Anna Maria
Marconi was a diminutive woman who was
also incredibly intelligent and actually
challenged Otto Octavius in a lot of
different ways she believed he was Peter
Parker she didn't really know the truth
she found out later on but she was one
of the few people out there that kept
pushing him to be better and so because
of the fact that she was not content
with mediocrity she would call him out
when he was wrong she would say like
you're better than what you currently
are right now it wasn't just I like you
as you are and that's fine right she
wanted to see him become better to live
up to his full potential that he
actually developed a huge amount of
respect for and then started falling in
love with her and so he basically misses
her and that all ties into the nature of
superior Spider-Man right Dr Octopus
basically reforming becoming a hero
instead of a villain forming Parker
Industries which actually became like
this worldwide multi-billion dollar
philanthropy-based organization he
created all these little pieces of
technology that made Peter Parker's life
better as Spider-Man it was really
really cool in terms of how all that
stuff worked but once the actual system
is set up and he's ready to travel one
of the things that he had done is
created a snapback protocol so that if
he ends up jumping into an alternate
universe and like it's in the middle of
a meteor crashing into it and everyone's
dying he can snap back
because wouldn't it suck if you travel
to a new universe and a meteor was about
to crash into it he had like 10 seconds
to live and that was that right like it
would it would really blow balls and so
once he ends up passing through because
of the nature of traveling through the
Multiverse is not as simple as simply
just jumping back to a period in time
trying to travel through space and time
the fact of the Multiverse actually
moves the way the Earth orbits around
the Sun that is a very very precise
system and so he ultimately ends up
missing where it is that he's supposed
to be instead he shows up in an
alternate reality where Spider-Man had
joined the Fantastic Four and this
version of Spider-Man's been killed not
only that he snaps back and ends up in
an alternate reality the House of M
Universe most of you guys have heard of
that the Universe with a Scarlet Witch
had basically rewrote reality to give
everybody everything they subconsciously
desired Spider-Man in that universe is
killed then he snaps back and ends up in
a civil war Universe where basically the
Civil War never ended and that version
of Spider-Man is killed that every
single Universe he goes to the
Spider-Man in these different universes
have all been killed they've been
executed but the more crazy thing about
this is they've all been killed in the
exact same way the two same puncture
marks right so seemingly someone or
something is traveling around the
Multiverse and killing all these
different versions of Spider-Man and so
what it does is it switches over towards
probably one of the cooler versions of
Spider-Man one superior Spider-Man jumps
back to 2099 and then jumps into the
time stream again you actually ended up
in an alternate reality where you get
Spider-Man India which is cool and then
you find the guy who's basically killing
everybody now this thing here this guy
he's what's called an inheritor and
we'll learn more about the inheritors as
time goes on the important thing and
really what Dan slot gives us here is
that this guy Spider-Man India seemingly
has all the same powers that you would
expect from a Spider-Man right like the
powers of Peter Parker so like the
proportional strength of a spider the
ability to climb on walls shoot webbing
different things like that a lot of that
stuff just kind of universal from one
Universe to the next but this guy this
Spider-Man India is getting totally
wrecked by by this inheritor right I
mean literally he's just fleeing for his
life nothing's working absolutely
nothing is working here and so what you
end up getting is this this kind of cat
and mouse game this incredible maneuver
that's made by this inheritor where he
actually ends up forcing a building to
crumble which draws the attention of
Spider-Man because as you guys know
Spider-Man would never let innocent
people die and then in turn because he's
distracted it's basically game over
there's no way for this guy to win and
then enter superior Spider-Man who saves
this dude's life right just saves this
guy's life by an instant I mean this
dude was like moments away from being
killed and so once this guy is basically
defeated of course he's you know we
really have superhero Spider-Man telling
us this guy's being held at Bay he
starts talking to Spider-Man India and
what he says is that as he's been
traveling through the Multiverse
presumably trying to find his way home
his mission to get back to the main
Marvel Universe shifted because every
Universe he came across Spider-Man were
being killed and Dr Octopus being as
intelligent as he is deduced someone or
something is hunting Spider-Man from
across the Multiverse and so it's only a
matter of time before they come for him
and so what do you he actually has been
doing is assembling a team of different
Spider-Man from across the Multiverse
all of whom intend to face off against
this guy this person this basically
taking him all out and so once
Spider-Man India is brought back to the
Marvel 2099 Universe you end up seeing
like five other Spider-Man including
Spider-Man Noir but one of them is also
assassin Spider-Man who's one of the
coolest versions of the character okay
so here's here's the origin of assassin
Spider-Man right we're going to switch
over to this it's actually kind of a
backup feature in Superior Spider-Man
number 32. that what you end up finding
out here is that somewhere along the
line the Green Goblin had actually
murdered Gwen Stacy and unlike the main
Marvel Universe were the death of Gwen
Stacy top Peter Parker that he couldn't
be Reckless and this alternate reality
the death of Gwen Stacy taught
Spider-Man to take no prisoners and so
every single villain that he had that he
came across he killed he just executed
him right like Craven the Hunter he just
killed him as he should have been doing
and of course one of the things that
also goes on here is that because there
are some threats out there that
Spider-Man is going to have to contend
with and his skills aren't quite up to
Snuff he actually ends up training with
Wolverine now this may seem kind of like
weird to have him train with Wolverine
but it actually makes perfect sense and
the reason why is because Wolverines
trained a lot of people in Marvel Comics
Black Widow learned how to fight from
Wolverine when she was in the Red Room
he had all kinds of people who who have
trained with this guy right and it's one
of these things in Marvel Comics it's a
hodgepodge somewhere along the line
seemingly everybody's trained with
everybody else the only real exception
to that insofar as the one person that
like everybody's trained with is
actually two people and they're really
more teachers than anything else the
first one is Taskmaster right like Tony
Masters that guy I mean he's he's the
guy you want to train with he usually
trains villains but heroes are trained
with him as well but the other person
and probably the more significant
trainer of heroes in Marvel Comics is
Shang Chi he's trained really almost
everyone in some form or fashion even if
there's someone like Wolverine that
already had a formidable set of skills
all change he did was hone them and make
them better so again it's one of these
things where Tony Masters and Shane Chi
are kind of like the one-two punch of
people that train with but this guy this
version of Spider-Man training with
Wolverine made him far more ruthless and
far more brutal because it's just the
nature of Wolverine's training and so of
course when this inheritor showed up in
that universe and immediately started
going after that version of Spider-Man
the Assassin Spider-Man that Wolverine
stepped in the way and Wolverine was
totally incinerated right of course all
that's really left is his adamantium
skeleton now this is one of those things
where Marvel plays it fast and loose if
you read Days of Future Past Marvel's
like yeah man Wolverine's entire
skeleton was incinerated and he died but
then you go and you read a story like
Civil War where Nitro blows up in front
of Wolverine and reduces them down to
his skeleton and he regrows right so
it's one of those things where it just
kind of goes either way Wolverine's
ability to heal from an injury is more
of a plot device than anything else
especially when it's an injury this
extreme but what it does is it allows
assassin Spider-Man to basically
temporarily gain the upper hand on this
inheritor even if only for a moment now
during this process he's actually met by
Alex now we're not given a whole lot of
information about Alex all we really
know is that she's basically the girl
that this version of Spider-Man ended up
with that liked the main Marvel Universe
the following the death of Gwen Stacy
Peter Parker at least in this reality
ended up with Mary Jane Watson but then
along the way he met Alex he broke up
with Mary Jane Watson and got with Alex
instead most likely it seems to be
because the mentality Alex had is more
in line with the mentality of assassin
Spider-Man but at the end of the day you
actually get this really really cool
moment where assassin Spider-Man's
fighting the inheritor and he realizes
his staff basically relies on energy and
so his response is then we'll just
overload it right so he actually leads
him to this location which is just a
giant power battery more or less and as
the two of them are fighting the staff
is temporarily overloaded but at the end
of the day the inheritor pulls it back
out and the fight's on again it's one of
these things where he's just kind of
like I'm entertained right like your
death will be quicker than most because
you know you kind of gave me a good
fight right I respect you so I'm not
going to kill you slowly and so
ultimately this guy kind of just seems
to be unstoppable there's no real way
for anyone to overcome it but then what
actually ends up happening is that while
this fight's taking place superior
Spider-Man shows up he ends up ripping a
tree out of the ground and throwing into
this dude and sending him flying and so
that's the explanation of how it is that
as these two meet up superior Spider-Man
had assassin Spider-Man in his ranks
because he saved yet another Spider-Man
from being killed by one of the
inheritors now at this point we switch
over to What's called the edge of
spider-verse so the way the spiderverse
was told it was told in a couple
different forms the first is that you
followed superior Spider-Man then you go
into edge of spider-verse which is
basically these stories that give you
like either Origins on different
versions of Spider-Man or stories
involving existing Spider-Man from
across the Multiverse in terms of how it
all ties together and how they ended up
as part of the spider-verse event and so
in this instance we actually ended up
picking up with Spider-Man Noir who's
actually been around since 2009 so he
was he appeared about five years before
this story was written and one of the
things to know the way Peter Parker
gained his powers in this particular
story because the Marvel Noir series was
designed to be a lot more grounded than
what you saw in terms of just the
traditional Marvel Comics lines so like
radioactive Style Fighters biting people
and instead of them succumbing to
radiation poisoning they get powers the
way you actually saw here was basically
a kind of spider Idol which really
seemed to be imbued with magical energy
so I mean I guess you know kind of
grounded I don't know but regardless
Peter Parker in this universe was bitten
by one of those spiders and then he woke
up with the with Spider-Man Powers as
you would expect what you also have here
is somebody called uh the magical
Mysterio or like the amazing Mysterio
what's really going on here and kind of
an important thing to understand these
aren't really significant moments we're
really covering this because of the way
that it ends but basically Mysterio is a
guy the Magnificent Mysterio he's a guy
vying for power right Wilson fist
Kingpin is running New York he's the guy
that wants to take his places like the
new Crime Boss is really all it is and
that's one of the things that kind of
happens is you have this bit of a
discussion where like Wilson Fisk walks
in on Mysterio talking about how he's
going to basically steal the powers of
Spider-Man and then in turn he's going
to be the one to run New York right so
when you're Wilson Fisk that stuff
doesn't really bother you because you
know that people are just going to come
gunning for you at some point along the
line and so one of the things that goes
on here is you actually have will Fisk
trying to gain information on the
identity of Spider-Man and that's been
an ongoing theme in the Spider-Man Noir
series for quite some time they actually
end up visiting Felicia Hardy now
Felicia Hardy was at one point in a
relationship with a villain called the
crime Master but was in love with
Spider-Man Noir and when the crime
Master learned this he ended up slashing
her face and that's why she wears a
white mask because her face is scarred
all the hell and so because of that it's
basically like her saying like I don't
know the identity of Spider-Man I'm in
love with him but I don't know him
personally but while all this is
happening right all these little plot
threads and things like that are going
on Peter Parker in this universe is
experiencing this kind of dull headache
that just kind of seems to be sitting
back there there really doesn't seem to
be any indication in terms of the fact
there's like an immediate threat that's
kind of how his Spider Sense manifest
it's sort of a dull pain but it just
kind of kicks in whenever any like
massive event takes place so very very
similar to the spider's sense of Peter
Parker from The main Marvel Universe but
what his sense is basically telling him
is there's a threat out there somewhere
and it's a kind of a kind of a bit of an
annoyance here because if it's like if
there's a a threat out there somewhere
like why doesn't the threat manifest
itself right I mean keep in mind Peter
Parker's fighter since doesn't tell him
where the threat is coming from it just
says there is a threat there kind of
like a sixth sense and even refers to it
as like an ESP to a degree but during
this whole thing because of the fact
that Mysterio is trying to get his hands
on on the blood of Spider-Man Noir for
the purpose of finding a way to
basically make himself someone that has
powers akin to Spider-Man that he
actually ends up challenging Spider-Man
Noir publicly in the newspapers by
saying like there is going to be a girl
you're going to have to rescue right can
you live up to the challenge that kind
of a thing now behind the scenes the
indication is he's actually going to
kill her like Mysterio really will kill
this girl if Spider-Man Noir doesn't
show up and because he's a quote-unquote
magician the audience will believe is a
trick when it's actually real right in
Spider-Man Noir will kind of have to
live with that so of course he ends up
showing up here and when that happens
he's overcome pretty quickly by a kind
of uh gaseous substance which basically
knocks him out temporarily and then of
course he's hoisted up and in response
to that the entire you know old casket
basically that he's in is filled with
water keep in mind this is all real it's
designed to look like a trick to the
audience because they're like oh man
this is crazy Mysterio couldn't kill
Spider-Man in front of everybody right
it's only you can March them out on
stage put a gun to the back of his head
and shoot him right because they would
all be like my God you killed a man but
like if you make it look like a trick
then it's like wow that was so
impressive we watched a man die but
we're too foolish to know what actually
happened right that kind of a thing now
at this point you get this kind of plot
device where basically Spider-Man Noir
shoots webbing on his face which like
traps a bit of oxygen and then he's like
the oxygen saved me from drowning right
and it's that kind of a thing now
honestly it would kill him because he's
he's exhaling CO2 right so basically
he's breathing in a poisonous substance
the oxygen would run out but it's comic
book logic roll with it don't ask too
many questions guys if you try to take
comic books too seriously you're gonna
make yourself go crazy and so of course
he ends up basically making his Escape
he fights Mysterio you know kind of
Beats him up a little bit and the day's
more or less saved and he frees Felicia
Hardy and all that kind of stuff and
that's it and then the inheritor pops up
and that's kind of how this happens
right these guys teleport into universes
right teleport into these spaces and so
when this guy arrives superior
Spider-Man shows up it's one of these
things where literally superior
Spider-Man teleports in grabs Spider-Man
war and teleports out and that's it
because by this point in time as this
kind of conversation begins to progress
and we start to get into the next part
of our little story here that what you
have is basically the realization by
superior Spider-Man they can't beat this
guy as a small number hence the reason
why the entire team was formed and so
what you get is a is a different reality
where you basically have cyborg
Spider-Man he's pretty cool but he looks
pretty amazing this inheritor shows up
and then you actually end up finding out
that at some point along the line
superior Spider-Man visited cyborg
Spider-Man and informed him of what was
going on that seemingly the inheritor
would come after him somewhere along the
line and that ultimately when that
happens he actually ends up calling in
all these different Spider-Man right so
like Spider-Man India Spider-Man Noir
The Superior Spider-Man Spider Girl
rights like Ashley Barton from The Old
Man Logan Universe She was amazing oh my
God I loved her character so much an Old
Man Logan did you guys remember that she
was all like helpless and she needed to
be saved and then like once she was
saved she was like I'm ruling everything
now she like turned out to be a villain
it was awesome by the way if you guys
want to see like the origins or
explanations on any of the characters
that we cover here that you're not like
familiar with let me know and like I'll
make you know we'll kind of like pause
the series for a second and make videos
about some of these characters because I
feel like some of you guys are going to
want to know like the origins of these
guys and things along those lines but
ultimately they all end up teaming up
against against this inheritor and they
actually draw this really cool
conclusion superior Spider-Man realized
that while this guy is going around
killing Spider-Man then what he's doing
is absorbing their energy and so finding
a way to reverse engineer that process
he could actually use that energy
against him right they could basically
siphon that energy off of him and
basically make him weak the nature of
Ashley Barton right like the daughter of
Hawkeye the nature of her is she's kind
of like okay we gotta kill this guy
right like we got to take this guy out
and it's one of the things where the
other Spider-Man are like really like
you want to kill like I mean are you
sure about that and then like Assassin
Spider-Man's like yeah man he's been
killing us right like we just gotta
eliminate this guy be done with it call
it a day why would we let this guy live
he's gonna find somebody to escape what
do you think's gonna happen he's gonna
be in prison and then realize his heart
was three sizes too small and he's gonna
become a good guy and help us is that
really what you think is going to happen
no he's a villain kill him
and so there's this kind of big debate
that goes on there but superior
Spider-Man steps in and says before we
kill this guy at all we need information
right and so he asked him like what's
your mission and the response to the
inheritor is like there is no mission
right this is what my kind does we kill
spiders it's our way as for others like
me pray you never meet the rest of my
family and that's when it takes superior
Spider-Man by surprise like wait a
minute wait a minute there's more than
one of you and his response is like oh
yeah there's there's more than one of us
and so the question superior Spider-Man
asks here is will my weapon function as
well against these others I warn you I
will know if you lie and the response to
this guy is I mean sure like it'll
function as well against the others as
it does against me which is completely
and totally ineffective and then just
like breaks out right and it's just like
I was just wanting to hear what you guys
were saying I just wanted to hear what
your plan was understand what you guys
were doing and this massive fight breaks
out now all these Spider-Man are facing
one inheritor they're doing what they
can but at the end of the day even for
just one inheritor they're all being
painfully overpowered right I mean like
they're attacking as best they can can
but they can't kill this guy right like
all they can do is kind of throw him
around Pummel him a little bit they set
him on fire and it doesn't work and then
it's just like okay this could not
possibly get any worse and they're
suddenly met by the arrival of two other
inheritors now of course you learn this
guy we've been following the whole time
his name is Karn but basically he's kind
of seen as like a shameful member of the
family not as powerful as just kind of
uh kind of shame that he carries and
we'll talk more about that later but
like these other two showing up if there
was ever a fight to be had here it's
long since gone they overpower these
guys with a quickness right these
inheritors they overpower these
Spider-Mans so fast and like Superior
Spider-Man's like we have to go we can't
stay here if we stay here we're all
gonna die I'm sounding a retreat and
some of them don't want to but it's like
no like like you guys remember that
scene from Aliens when when uh when
Hicks was like Marines we are leaving
it's that right I mean it's it's just
it's a massacre this them just like
trying to live and so ultimately they
actually the inheritors end up fighting
amongst themselves and that's just what
superior Spider-Man and those guys need
it's to basically have a distraction to
make their escape they open their
portals and they bail they immediately
take off and so following that you have
this kind of discussion that goes on
where One Superior Spider-Man ends up
creating an arm for one of the
Spider-Man to basically upgrade his uh
cybernetic devices so he can you know
hack into the systems from alcamax
without being detected and he's like
your job is to hunt for the names of the
inheritors throughout the entire history
that Alco Max has at their disposal if
they're moving through universes it also
means they're moving through time so
they could appear at any point in time
across the entirety of the Multiverse if
they're hunting Spider-Man there's a
good chance they've appeared in the past
find their names and that assignment
actually ends up going out to the six
armed Spider-Man as well right to kind
of hunt throughout the entirety of the
time stream space and time itself and
find some reference for these guys
anywhere the next thing is it actually
ends up going to Spider-Man India and
well he really calls him turtleneck but
it's basically Spider-Man Noir where
he's like you're going to find out where
their home universe is if they are
hunting Spider-Man throughout the
Multiverse then it means they're
retreating somewhere they're going
somewhere they live somewhere find their
home whether it's an entire universe or
some pocket Dimension somewhere find out
where they live and so what he actually
ends up doing is pulling aside Ashley
Barton and pulling aside assassin
Spider-Man and this is one of the cool
things because these were the two who
immediately said we have to kill this
inheritor guy and so one of the things
superior Spider-Man picked up on is that
the other Spider-Man who were here are
all very closely modeled after Peter
Parker right they're just alternate
reality versions of Peter in the sense
that they almost exactly mirror his
mannerisms but also his moral compass
they're not willing to kill and so it's
one of the things that kind of goes on
because he says I wanted to speak to the
two of you privately I feel we share a
certain perspective that eludes our
allies and that's when assassin
Spider-Man's like don't dance around it
we're killers and Superior Spider-Man
says yes he's like I wasn't really
dancing around it it's more than that
the others may have killed in dire
circumstances I don't really know but
it's clear to me that we three have seen
things that they have not brutality
Devastation Darkness the others think
they've seen the worst that life has to
offer because they've lost a loved one
or two but we have seen the face of true
evil and we understand what is required
to stop it this is incredibly important
because he goes on to say these beings
we fight belong to the same family to
end their threat we may have to commit a
genocide and by way of that we may find
our allies standing in our way I.E if it
comes down to it I need to know you're
willing to kill other Spider-Man in
order to ensure we can end this threat
it's pretty extreme right it's just that
severe of a conflict in the eyes of
superior Spider-Man
what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are back with spider-verse and you guys
really seem to enjoy the last video that
we did so we're gonna do more uh this
one in particular is very very
interesting so here's one thing that I
want to preface before we we get into
this there are a few things going on
within the Marvel Universe and
Multiverse at the same time this is
happening and that actually lead up to
it specifically the events of infinity
so basically Thanos fighting the
Inhumans and the terrigen bomb as well
as the incursions we'll explain that
once we get to it but the other thing is
that following this we're gonna jump
into edge of spider-verse an edge of
spider-verse is where you get a lot of
the origins you guys have been asking
for right so like the origin of
spider-gwen different things like that
so we'll kind of bring all that stuff
together and then once edge of
spider-verse finishes we'll get into the
actual Main spider-verse Event because
this is all Prelude stuff this is all
the stuff leading up to quote unquote
the main spider-verse event and so what
this does is this actually focuses at
least in this video we're going to be
focusing on Amazing Spider-Man Volume 3.
now the reason why that matters is
because technically the events of
superior Spider-Man man concluded
they're done and when superior
Spider-Man ended you went into Amazing
Spider-Man 3 which was basically Peter
Parker getting his body back the reason
why you still see superior Spider-Man is
because prior to the ending of his story
spider-verse took place so he was thrown
into the Multiverse he's currently
outside of time so it's like Dr Octopus
taking over the body of Peter Parker on
a Monday the entire spiderverse event
happens on a Tuesday and then on a
Wednesday Peter gets his body back so
it's just one of those one of those
weird things right it's just something
to wrap your head around I know it seems
a little strange but what this also does
is it brings in a character named Cindy
moon now Cindy moon was a really really
cool concept that Marvel wasted
and it really kind of sucked so if you
guys recall our discussion about the
idea of spider totems again that was
Marvel basically moving away from the
idea that Peter Parker was just a kid
who was bitten by a radioactive spider
and instead him being bitten by that
spider basically tied him in to this
kind of mystical uh connection that he
had with all these other people who had
been bitten by spiders and become spider
people now one of the things that
marvelous did is they had an event
called Original Sin and all original sin
did is it basically revealed all these
things that we never knew about it was a
way for Marvel to kind of jump start
stories they'd been looking to tell and
you learned some really really cool
stuff right Captain America being part
of the Illuminati and then having his
mind wiped and kicked out different
things along those lines Sydney Moon was
actually a girl who was bitten by the
exact same spider that bit Peter Parker
and in fact they happen within like
minutes of each other this fighter bit
Peter it fell off and then it bit Cindy
on her ankle the kicker to this is that
if you recall our discussions about like
Ezekiel Sims and all those guys
basically Ezekiel Sims realizing that
like the inheritors were going around
and killing people who were basically
Spider-Man fighter women from across the
Multiverse that when he encountered
Cindy Moon and her power started
manifesting he realized that the
inheritors were after her and so what he
did is he locked her away and what was
basically a bunker that had years worth
of food now she wasn't a prisoner she
could have left at any point in time she
had the access code to leave but Ezekiel
Sims basically said if you do that
there's a good chance they'll find you
and they will kill you if they do right
there's no way you can fight them off on
your own so she was more of a prisoner
by choice than anything else following
the events of original sin and Peter
Parker learning of Cindy Moon's
existence he basically rescued her and
then there was like a whole series of
events where she was pissed off but
because of the fact that she's part of
the spider totems and she has the name
the bride essentially her and Peter
Parker just can't stop banging that's
really what it means like if they are in
a vicinity of each other like literally
it happens here we're like they're
talking he's showing her the internet
and he was like okay when you were
locked away yeah it was AOL and Netscape
for those of you guys who were that old
to remember that kind of stuff I do I
remember AOL
but he says like nowadays it's all
Facebook and all that kind of stuff
they're literally within a foot of each
other the pheromones start kicking in
and they want to start banging and it
happened for a while when they first met
they couldn't stop banging it was crazy
it was hilarious but it was crazy and so
again with Anna Maria Marconi being here
of course again her she initially met Dr
Octopus believing he was Peter Parker
all that stuff took place during
superior Spider-Man now she's like okay
nope we're not having you guys doing
this this is not gonna happen uh she
starts literally starts spraying him
with water in order to make him stop and
so Cindy Moon finally gives up and she
ends up basically taking off to find her
own place now following that what you
actually end up getting is this great
big huge kind of Calamity where you
basically have Minerva the reason why
this matters is like Minerva fighting
the cops and things like that it's not
overall important to the spider-verse
event but it is cool and and the weird
thing is that Minerva is one of those
characters Marvel just never really
updated her so to get a guy's
perspective Minerva was a character who
was basically a member of the cree race
and she traveled to Earth to meet the
original Captain Marvel of the cree the
guy and then wanted to bang him in order
to basically jump start the cree's
evolution the reason why is because at
one point in their history the cree had
gotten their hands on something called
the crystal of ultimate Vision but
because they wanted to use it for
nefarious purposes it basically froze
their evolutionary state so they never
aged Marvel fixed that with a story
called operation Galactic storm where
basically the cree race was almost
totally obliterated and because of that
their evolution was forced and so there
really isn't a need for Minerva to exist
anymore that's why you see her here and
there occasionally but she never matters
because Marvel never changed the
motivation it's like she never knew that
operation Galactic storm happened right
I don't know how she didn't know she was
there when it did but nonetheless it's
one of those one of those weird little
things this matters because the whole
situation with this going on with
Minerva actually gets the attention of
basically Kamala Khan of Miss Marvel and
she's a great character I love the
character of Miss Marvel her basically
stepping in and intervening actually
leads to her and Spider-Man teaming up
which is cool but Kamala Khan is one of
these characters where she had basically
come about as a result of the terrigen
bomb detonating so prior to the events
of what was going on here with
spider-verse what you had it was a story
called Infinity which was part of a
larger story that dealt with the
incursions and we'll talk about that
here in a little bit but Infinity was
really its own self-contained story so
you can read that of its own accord and
actually not read anything else
involving Hickman's Avengers and New
Avengers and for the most part be fine
you'll probably have to do a little bit
of Internet researching to kind of get
caught up on some things that don't make
sense but the overall gist here is that
Thanos had formed the coal obsidian and
was basically traveling around the
Multiverse trying to find his offspring
and kill him that eventually led him to
Earth where he learned his child existed
among the Inhumans he ended up getting
in a fight with black bull and in the
conflict one of the most amazing moments
in the story dude there's this amazing
moment in Infinity dude I love this
moment it's like one of the best moments
ever where like Thanos is fighting black
Bolton he was like tell me where my son
is and black Bolt's like no right like
anytime he talks it's a quasi-sonic
scream so like he basically you know
just emanates this massive amount of
energy like this huge concussive blast
and like he's like screaming at Thanos
and it's not working at Thanos is like
fine keep your secrets carry them with
you to the grave and like smashes his
head in the ground it's just a
ridiculously amazing moment but in any
event uh basically Black Bolt detonated
the terrigen bomb which spreads
herogenesis across the world and then
all these people who carry the inhuman
genes and didn't know it suddenly went
into a state of Terror Genesis quite
literally they were just like kind of
encased in these ugly looking cocoons
and then they would just manifest in
whatever form it happened to take right
very similar to how mutants suddenly
just developed Powers based on their X
Gene usually during like puberty or high
levels of stress but Kamala Khan is one
of those now what made Kamala Khan so
cool in her early stories why G Willow
Wilson is one the family Dynamic right
the fact that she came from a very
traditional family but she actually
wanted to do like very American things
which were considered to be very much
against what her family stood for but
she was also like really new to the
superhero scene so like meeting Heroes
for the first time and then basically
just fan and growing it was hilarious
I love the original run of of uh Kamala
Khan and so that's why when like
Spider-Man shows up she's like you're
Spider-Man holy cow I'm gonna I'm gonna
team up with Spider-Man this is amazing
and then she starts asking him stuff
like did you really go on a date with
Miss Marvel with like Harold Danvers
like what was she like what kind of
music does she dig she's like the
ultimate Carol Danvers fangirl but it
was a it was a cool little thing of
course she really became you know kind
of stepped into her own and became a
more solidified character but one of the
things that Minerva's doing is that
because she's trying to like jump start
Cree physiology she basically ends up
taking this kind of inhuman and then
seemingly bonding them with Cree DNA for
the purpose of like allowing them to
manifest and kind of go forward
accordingly what follows after this
isn't really interesting at all um they
fight the thing and then they basically
win and like the day save and you got
some cool moments where some stuff
happens in all honesty it's basically
filler to justify the existence of the
comic uh to basically fill it up with
space one of the things that does happen
here is you actually end up seeing Cindy
moon fashioning like an official costume
for herself having one of the more
popular costumes that exists in the
spider universe but basically
everything's is kind of cool and
everything's copacetic and you know the
day's saved and that's basically it the
meat and potatoes of this and the real
takeaway from this comes by way of
spider UK and again these are the kind
of backup features that you saw during
these events of of Spider-Man that
largely dealt with uh basically the
spider-verse event kind of leading into
the whole thing and so what ends up
happening here is that you basically
have a kind of situation where spider UK
almost has this kind of experience like
something's wrong in the Multiverse
involving the various Spider-Man and in
fact he's actually using the ability to
scan the Multiverse to essentially
figure all this stuff out now there's a
few things we have to explain in terms
of why this happens so spider UK is part
of What's called the Captain Britain
Corps and his name is Billy Braddock so
the Captain Britain Corps is a
multiversal team for those of you guys
who are unfamiliar with this if you guys
know about it bear with me here for a
second I feel like we're gonna get a lot
of new viewers who have never heard of
this before the Captain Britain core is
a multiversal superhero team they're not
pretty particularly powerful but take
the Green Lanterns from like the DC
Comics universe and make it a
multiversal team and that's basically
the Captain Britain core there's
officially one Captain Britain for each
universe and what they have is something
called The Lighthouse which is like
their base of operations but it's also
an interdimensional teleportation device
and it allows them to enter into what's
called The Starlight Citadel that's
basically the base of operations for a
woman named saturnee who's called the
omniversal magistrix her job is to like
monitor the Multiverse and make sure
things don't pop off a lot of people do
that the Living Tribunal does that
altezza the custodian of a Multiverse
does that and saturnin does that and
there's even more people who do that as
well but because of what's going on
because of the nature of the Starlight
Citadel and even the nature of the
lighthouse itself there is technology
there that allows members of the Captain
Britain Corps to scan the Multiverse and
to see what's going on because of what
use would they be as a team if they
weren't able to like communicate with
each other different things like that
and so what ends up happening is Billy
Braddock actually looks into an
alternate reality which is Earth 1983 in
New York City and basically see season
in that universe that more Lund is there
and is actually killing one of the
Spider-Man and absorbing their power
right taking this guy out the crazy
thing about this is this is seemingly a
universe where things were basically
just cool no one really thought it was
pretty light-hearted so this guy's
overcome pretty easily because evil
doesn't really seem to be something that
exists so quite literally he's
encountering something he's never
encountered before and so literally like
all these folks are killed at the hands
of Mulan and then that's it following
that he actually starts looking through
all these different realities that
you've got two of the other inheritors
that we saw in the last video the
brother and sister bricks and Borah who
are actually killing one of the spider
totems as a cat and this alternate
universe that you actually end up
switching over to Deimos in Earth 7831
that guy is consuming actually an entire
world full of anthropomorphic Heroes
largely consisting of the Knights of
Wonder Gore which are basically uh
individuals who were created by the high
evolutionary by basically modifying
animal DNA and they kind of spread out
into the world and seemingly populated
this world with anthropomorphic animals
partly and then also Baseline humans
while the the inheritors themselves are
only supposed to feed on spiders if a
being has super powers and they are
animal in nature they're part of that
animal totem system so that's the reason
why I like more Lund fought black
panther as an example uh they can feed
on those but by by way of the
instruction given to them by their
father they're not supposed to they're
only supposed to feed on spider totems
the other thing about this is you
actually have genics who's kind of like
the scientific arm of the inheritors who
actually realizes that that Billy
Braddock is spying on them that this
Spider-Man UK is watching them from some
other place in the Multiverse and so of
course you know spider you know Billy
Braddock is told like we're gonna get
you you know that kind of a thing but
following that he basically takes off
and he goes to meet with Roma and
saturnin now Roma is the daughter of
Merlin like the Merlin from Arthurian
Legend right like he's literally the one
who founded the Captain Britain Corps
The Starlight Citadel all that kind of
stuff he's the one that basically
spearheaded all those things now while
all this is going on with spider-verse
you also have the incursions universes
crashing into each other basically the
collapse of the Multiverse that's the
first and foremost pressing threat
that's the most important thing keeping
the Multiverse from collapsing but where
you end up having like like literally
Billy Braddock who shows up here Intel
saturnine all the different Spider-Man
and spider-women across the Multiverse
are being killed by the inheritors she
doesn't care she's like Ah that's the
least of my concerns entire universes
are being destroyed Cosmic entities are
Vanishing right the Multiverse is
collapsing the least of my concerns are
a bunch of Spider-Man and Spider-Woman
being killed by a crazy family that I
have I have no concern about that now
that's kind of the nature of saturnin
she's just kind of a dick right that's
just kind of the nature of her she's
pretty crass pretty rude there's very
much like my way or the highway that
kind of thing Roma was a far more
nurturing hand and that's why she's the
one that listens to the appeal of Billy
Braddock when he says like we have to do
something about these and her response
is look we can't divert the efforts of
the entire Captain Britain Corps to
basically help you deal with with you
know the spider totems I can help you
out by giving you a device that'll let
you basically travel through the
Multiverse but that's the extent of it
kind of the irony of all this all these
guys in the Captain Britain Corps they
get annihilated when they meet the
beyonders oh dude the beyonder is just
eradicate these guys and I think it's
really more the map makers and the
beyonders themselves but it doesn't
matter right like the the forces of the
beyonders these guys get crushed the
only member of the Captain Britain Corps
who lives is Brian Braddock from the
main Marvel Universe the Captain Britain
Corps never had a chance and in like a
last-ditch effort saturnin opens a
portal she throws Brian Braddock through
it gives them all the information and
then the portal shuts and that's the end
of the Captain Britain core right they
they never stood a chance but ultimately
spider UK is given this ability to
basically travel through the Multiverse
and this is a huge asset because while
he doesn't necessarily have all the
resources of the Captain Britain core at
his disposal right now he has a lot of
experience with understanding the
Multiverse and that in and of itself is
a pretty big thing because that will go
a long way and basically helping the
forces of of uh Spider-Man 2099 and
Superior Spider-Man and all those guys
in dealing with the inheritors now at
this point we switch over to our last
little tidbit here which is kind of
leads into the official edge of spite of
her story but we basically end up
picking up with Mayday Parker which is
essentially Earth 982. now Mayday Parker
is a fan favorite people absolutely love
her character she originally appeared in
a what-if story back in 1997 the what-if
story centered around the idea of like
Peter Parker and Mary Jane Watson having
a kid and actually being able to raise
that kid there was a point where Peter
Parker in that altered Universe
basically lost his leg and he ended up
retiring and then once his daughter made
a started developing Powers he started
training her to become a superhero which
is pretty cool and that's basically what
goes on here right It's the Return of
Mayday Parker after a pretty lengthy
absence in Marvel Comics but the whole
thing about this is you've basically got
one of the inheritors which is actually
Deimos literally attacking Peter Parker
of this reality and then attacking
Mayday as well as Mary Jane Parker and
that's kind of the crazy thing is
because none of these guys really have a
chance here right the power of the
inheritors they overcome them all now
Mayday was one of those characters where
like she was one part fun but she also
had had it work counted she was the girl
you wanted in your corner when things
started popping off she would always try
to find a way right this girl had like
just non-stop optimism and so despite
the fact that it's basically a losing
battle this version of Peter Parker
fights demos as best he can but in the
end he knows it's basically just a
distraction his goal is to not actually
defeat damos I mean if he does he'll
certainly be like yeah great I mean he
wants to defeat the guy but he also
knows it's probably not gonna happen
Deimos is just too strong too powerful
too fast he's just he's far beyond the
powers of just a normal spider- person
right Spiderman Spider Woman what have
you and so the the instruction here is
actually for Mayday to basically grab
Mary Jane and her younger brother and
herself and to get out of there as fast
as she possibly can right to leave is
Peter sacrificing his life to save his
family and so ultimately what ends up
happening is Mary Jane hands the baby
the the younger brother of Mayday over
to MayDay herself and says get out of
here right I'm right behind you
everything's gonna be cool and then Mary
Jane seemingly tries to stay to fight
now that was always a testament to the
nature Mary Jane Watson in the early
days of Marvel Comics and when I say the
early days I mean like Mary Jane as a
character when it was Peter Parker and
Gwen Stacy Mary Jane was always kind of
there but she seemed really shallow she
seemed like there wasn't a whole lot of
depth to her she seemed very
self-absorbed and the idea is that when
Gwen Stacy died there was a moment there
in the comics it was beautifully written
there was a moment there in the comics
when Peter lashes out at Mary Jane and
then Mary Jane chooses to stay and that
formed the relationship there that the
two of them falling in love and then it
was really like Jerry Conway and those
guys that followed suit reworking and
crafting Mary Jane Watson into a person
that became a lot more responsible a lot
more concerned a person that genuinely
cared about Peter Parker which she
always kind of did but she was far less
self-absorbed this is kind of like the
the fruition of that right the totality
of that what would that version of Mary
Jane Watson look like if her and Peter
Parker had got married they had a kid
all that kind of stuff and so that's why
the family Dynamic of these characters
is so cool of course Mayday basically
takes off with half of her mind knowing
her mom's gonna stay behind and that's
exactly what happens right both her mom
and her dad are basically killed there
is a bit of hope for her that like Peter
Parker survives but what you end up
having is the arrival of the forces of
like superior Spider-Man and those guys
to rescue Mayday Parker and when she's
like well I mean it's like it's like we
can go save my dad their response is no
your dad's gone like we arrived here too
late Peter Parker's dead that's when
damos comes out it's like yeah I absorb
the powers of Peter Parker he's totally
killed like there's no one here to save
you now either you can stay here and die
or you can flee as fast as you can but
understand there's nowhere you can go we
will find you no matter where you go in
this Multiverse and so that kind of sets
in stone this notion or this idea of
Mayday Parker to take out the inheritors
no matter what it takes no matter what
happens she wants to come out on top of
this that's a huge motivation for a
character going into the future of the
story
what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are back with spider-verse specifically
as promised we are covering edge of
spider-verse now for those of you guys
who don't know what that is Edge of
spider-verse and we technically already
covered part one but edge of
spider-verse was a five-part mini-series
that basically covered the origins of
like different spider-esque characters
from across the Multiverse some of whom
ended up joining the various you know
the great big huge Spider-Man team is
part of spider-verse and others who
actually were killed by the inheritors
so it's a really really cool concept
this one in particular is the origin of
spider-gwen and this one's nuts because
here's a crazy thing when this story
came out it's one of those rare
instances in this day and age when a
character is introduced in comics and
immediately explodes in popularity it
was actually the costume that made
fighter Gwen so popular when she first
came out because the costume design was
fantastic but like literally that year
it like comic-cons everywhere like you
just saw girls running around as like
spider Gwen it was it was nuts how
popular she was but what this does is it
initially opens up basically a Midtown
High School right Midtown being the
school that Peter Parker went to so a
lot of similarities that we know of
between this alternate reality uh
Spider-Man story and and the main Marvel
Universe story but basically Gwen Stacy
plays in a band called The Mary Janes
which my initial idea was like man how
arrogant could you be that you named a
band after yourself but Van Halen did
the same thing and their band was
amazing uh the thing about this is that
we get this kind of flashback right now
this is her first appearance in comics
and so Jason LaTour plays it fast and
quick with their origin in the sense
that all we really know is that
basically she was bitten by a
radioactive spider and that in turn she
went on to become a superhero but unlike
the main Marvel Universe where Captain
Stacy the father of Gwen was someone
that became a Ally of Spider-Man in this
instance he's actually an enemy of
spider Gwen all the while totally
unaware of the fact that his daughter is
spider-gwen so that added a really cool
Dynamic on top of that Peter Parker
never became Spider-Man instead he's
just basically an introverted kid in a
school that gets picked on all the time
and so Gwen's Stacy is the one saving
him and in a pursuit to become something
comparable to her he actually ended up
becoming the lizard instead and during
some kind of a conflict which was never
explored here in the story he basically
ends up dying and so following that what
you get is Jay Jonah Jameson that puts
forward this idea that basically Peter
Parker died at the hands of uh of
spider-gwen and that he has to be
Avenged right the superheroes are
basically being viewed as vigilante and
they can't be allowed to go around and
operate in that capacity right so the
cool thing about this is that with that
little bit out of a way she kind of gets
lost in herself as she's she's playing
in this band right just kind of getting
lost and sort of you know getting
carried away and of course you know
she's told by the band hey let's just
take a break right remember we have our
concert coming up and so you get
basically this kind of big uh struggle
that that spiderwing goes through and
this is one of the things that really
brought a lot of people on board
spider-gwen was hugely popular among
girls which if I'm being honest with you
guys Marvel needed that at the time
right Marvel didn't have a whole lot of
Heroes that resonated with the female
audience and so you know by and large
there weren't a whole lot of people that
that women could have a camaraderie with
and so one of the things that a lot of
just young people in general struggle
with is like the coming of age thing
right a lot of you guys who are in your
teenage years and those of you guys who
remember your teenage years you remember
what it was like right you're trying to
fit in you're trying to understand your
place in the bigger picture you're
trying to figure out who you are so
you're making friendships but you're not
even sure of the friends you have are
going into your friends for the rest of
your life you want to make sure you
maintain those relationships but you
also know you're changing it's a very
very confusing and difficult time that I
think is exacerbated by the nature of
social media but the thing about this is
that she's basically struggling with
this idea that one part of her feels
guilt over the death of Peter Parker but
there's another part of her that's like
I'm not the one who's responsible for
this so while the world is telling her
it's your fault Peter died she knows
it's not but she can never really share
her identity with seemingly anybody
around her let alone her father her
father's a cop and her father's hunting
spider Gwen and so there's no real
knowing what would happen if she dumped
her identity to her father now there
does come a moment when she almost does
when she almost tells her dad who she is
what's going on you know and it kind of
makes sense right given the relationship
between her and her father and really
between most girls and their father that
as time progresses girls become closer
to their dads and then they become
closer to their moms and so in this
instance her father is the only real
parental figure she has is the only real
person she feels like she can go and
talk to anything about and so if there
were any person she could have this
conversation with it would be him but
before she gets the chance she's
actually basically Tracked Down by a cop
who of course doesn't necessarily shoot
around the spot but actually tries to
and that's kind of the extent of of how
she's viewed here that in some ways it
was pretty dark right he tells her like
freeze put her hands up you know all
that kind of stuff you know the things
you normally expect to hear when a cop
is like you know trying to arrest you
essentially and of course she's she's
dodging and moving out of the way and so
on and so forth but he fires a few shots
at her and tries to kill her and she
actually you know ends up in you know
basically webbing him up so he can't do
anything and then puts in a call saying
shots fired and you know a bunch of Cops
show up and she actually makes her
escape and these cops continue tracking
her down what this does is it says
there's basically no safe place for
spider-gwen and this is starkly
different from the Spider-Man Mythos
that we're used to and that was one of
the best things about edges fightiverse
because this is the tip of the iceberg
right wait till we get to the story
about the Spider-Man who bites Mary Jane
Watson that gets nuts right that story
gets crazy it's like a horror story more
so than anything else what you actually
also end up getting here is basically
Matt Murdock who's actually a villain
right which is kinda crazy right it's
one of the cool things about this and so
you basically have him talking to Alexi
who is really this alternate reality's
version of Rhino from Marvel Comics is
really all he is but as the two of them
are talking basically he's being set
upon Captain Stacy right just a desire
to take this guy up because Captain
Stacy's not necessarily a bad cop right
like I mean he's trying to track down
spider Gwen because in his mind she's a
criminal of vigilante as far as he's
aware he's doing what he's instructed to
do as a member of law enforcement but
more so than that he takes down big
criminals different things along those
lines so he's just much an issue for
spider-gwen as he is for like Matt
Murdock and any of those guys and so
following this of course as you expect
much like if you're familiar with
Spider-Man from the movie Marvel
Universe this girl can't be on time
anyway that's kind of the thing about
Spider-Man right Peter Parker this guy
couldn't be on time if he had like a
giant purple clock sitting in front of
his face telling him what time it was
right like he still couldn't be on time
and so ultimately she's actually late
for her own concert with the Mary Janes
now there is a little bit of a Saving
Grace here in the sense that like with
no drummer there people are kind of like
I mean this is a little weird seeing a
band with no drummer but then like Alexi
busts in with the intention of going
after Captain Stacy right spider-gwen
shows up just at that moment and of
course throws on her suit and then
immediately goes through to try to save
her dad but it's kind of a little bit of
a Saving Grace right before anybody
could realize hey this girl's missing
you know outside of the band like this
this band sucks right if it went on for
like 15 minutes people would be like
yeah this band sucks they don't have a
drummer this is weird let's let's go
next door and get some drinks
that's basically what it would turn into
but you get this thing where Rhino
actually gets the upper hand honor and a
lot of this seems to be because she's
still fairly new to this right she's
still fairly new to being a spider
character and understanding everything
that goes along with it the various
villains that are out there and even
with Peter Parker and Main Marvel
Universe it was much the same way Peter
Parker didn't know how to cope with
someone like Electro until he fought
someone like Electro but it's just one
of those things you don't know how to do
it until you do and then you learn how
to go forward from there and so she's
able to get the upper hand just by
virtue of her enhanced strength and
actually overcomes this guy quite
readily I mean just absolutely pummels
this dude and then webs him up knocks
him unconscious and goes to walk away
only to be met by her father right for
like Captain Stacy to turn around just
be like you're under arrest and that's
kind of the crazy theme because you get
this really really cool exchange here
right it's almost this thing where like
she approaches it from a pretty
interesting philosophical level right he
says don't move an inch and she's like
really you know she's like what's the
girl gotta do to impress a guy right so
obviously maintaining that kind of
joking thing you know she's like I just
want to be Longs you know and so on and
so forth and then what what happens is
things get serious right you know you
get that kind of Peter parker-esque
joking which is sort of necessary for
any kind of you know alternate reality
or any main Marvel Universe Spider-Man
story but when Captain Stacy goes to a
wrestler he's like I'm placing you under
arrest for the murder of Peter Parker
you have the right to remain silent and
that's when she chimes in she's like
Peter's death it was not my fault at
least not in the way that you think but
Captain Stacy doesn't care right you
know he's like it's not my job to decide
that she's like sure you'll just leave
it to Jameson's angry mob right some
crazy guy who ramped up a bunch of crazy
people and they all want to take me out
you know she's like or you could leave
it to the cop that tried to shoot me in
a crowded Subway but whatever the case
is and he's like whatever it takes right
however long it takes to to do it like
you'll see Justice I will like you will
you will stand before a judge for the
crime that you committed and that's when
Xi'an masks right she's like I'm spider
Gwen she's like here's the thing dad
like you're a good cop you put on the
badge because you knew that if you
didn't somebody who doesn't need to wear
a badge would right somebody who would
abuse their power would do it and so you
are are in effect not necessarily
overpowered but you're a person who does
the right thing and that's what I'm
doing right I'm putting on this mask I
tried to do the right thing Peter Parker
got himself killed he became a villain
right he became a bad guy you know
whatever the case was it unfolded in his
situation she's like I didn't kill Peter
Parker and if I'm going to be like you
and I'm going to be somebody who stands
up for small people like I'm gonna be
somebody who makes the world a better
place I can't do it from a jail cell
right I can't do it there so you have to
let me go right she's like this mask is
my badge now right if I don't Define
what it means monsters like that will
and that's true right that's one of
those things where if you have a cause
that you're standing up for you have to
have a face of that cause otherwise
you'll become a kind of walking talking
case study where your opposition defines
your cause better than you do that's why
I always Advocate every movement has to
have a leader otherwise you end up
having people who do things awry and
there's no one there to say they don't
stand for what we believe in and so
that's why she has to be out there in
doing this kind of thing because it's
not necessarily about her solidifying
what it means to be a hero to a degree
it is it's her solidifying the idea that
not everyone out there with powers is a
bad guy some of us are good guys and
some of us are trying to do good things
and so as a result of that I have to go
out and be one of the good people and
her dad lets her go right now the thing
about this is this is all being watched
by Spider-Man UK and his response is yes
you'll do quite nicely they're gonna
bring her into their ranks now here's a
funny thing this story it was nuts right
like when this came out everybody wanted
to know everything about spider Gwen
they were like no no no you can't give
us some story in edge of spider-verse
like this and give us nothing else again
right because she showed back up in the
main spider-verse event but she was so
huge that Marvel Marvel like had to
create a story about it right I mean
it's sold like gangbusters and so ever
since then spider-gwen's been like a
Mainstay in Marvel Comics she's just
that popular and she probably always
will be to be honest I mean she's always
written just incredibly well but yeah
that's the origin of spider-gwen in
Marvel Comics if I'm being honest with
you guys I would not be surprised this
video does terrible
what's going on guys this is Robin in
this video we're going to cover a story
where Spider-Man kills everyone
and this story is amazing
story so much it is dark it's like the
darkest Spider-Man story ever although I
imagine Craven's last hunt might really
take the cake for those of you guys who
are experienced with Spider-Man Reading
when we're done with this let me know
which one of the two you think is darker
now for those of you guys who are
unfamiliar with our spider-verse
coverage up to this point because I
imagine we might gain a little bit of
traction based on the popularity of the
trailer which is releasing tonight at 8
30 p.m at the time that I'm recording
this video the edge of spider-verse
event was part of the larger
spider-verse story right where you had a
whole bunch of different Spider-Man from
across the Multiverse you were teaming
up against a group called The inheritors
Edge of spider-verse basically gave us
these little stories dealing with
different Spider-Man from across the
Multiverse some of whom actually
survived into the main spider-verse
event and some of whom did not for
various reasons this one actually picks
up with a kid named Patton Parnell
instead of Peter Parker the traditional
name and right off the bat right like
right off the bat Clayton McLeod the guy
who wrote this story basically shows us
that this kid is dark right like he
finds an ant used as a magnifying glass
and basically kills the but one of the
things about this is he's not like some
you know six-year-old kid who does it
out of curiosity or something like that
he actually is showing signs of
psychopathy if not sociopathy right like
anti-social personality disorder a
sociopath or a psychopath right the idea
of harming things that are basically
defenseless that that's really the kind
of air that he puts off more so than
that though it doesn't really seem to be
done out of malice or cruelty it really
seems to be done more out of curiosity
and that's one of the big differences
between Peter and like a traditional
psychopath or a traditional sociopath is
that he doesn't really have a desire to
harm people for the sake of doing it
it's really more of like a science
experiment than anything else and so
what he actually ends up doing or at
least in this time when he's in his room
he's got a uh got a pair of binoculars
and he's basically spying on a girl
named Sarah Jane who is in effect Mary
Jane Watson right just by a different
name and it's one of these things where
he actually refers to her as like as an
experiment of sorts so right there
you've got a kind of Detachment right
Reed doesn't necessarily see himself as
being a human despite living among
humans right like being a human himself
that he sees himself as kind of
different now this has become hugely
important once you get to like the
traditional Mythos as far as Spider-Man
goes and all that kind of stuff but the
way that he speaks here is like
commencing surveillance experiments
Stakeout number 16 right subject remains
unaware of being under observation
perfect so he's basically spying on her
as she's getting undressed right he's
like I must collect samples from
subject's living area for analysis right
and then at that point his uncle
basically starts shouting at him and
telling him you know he's got to drive
him to school and all that kind of stuff
but once he gets there of course again
his interactions with Mary Jane Watson
and we're just going to go ahead and
call her that right you know we're going
to call him Peter Parker we're going to
call her Mary Jane Watson we're going to
keep it simple here right I mean they
are alternate reality characters they do
have their alternate reality names but
thereby all standards of measurement
Peter Parker and Mary Jane Watson right
so we'll just go ahead and call him that
so basically Mary Jane kind of asked
Peter Parker to sit down next to him
right now on the surface this is not a
very big thing but for those of you guys
who come from a background of being like
socially awkward or lacking the kind of
social skills necessary to talk to girls
this is something that's kind of huge
right I mean I used to be a socially
awkward guy back in the day if you can
believe it or not when I say back in the
day I mean like when I first started
Middle School right like I'd say within
like a year or two of middle school I
was awesome but up until that point
I was kind of socially awkward right but
the thing about this is that if you come
from that kind of background you
understand the struggle of like just
striking up a conversation with a person
in general let alone a girl you like
right the idea behind this is they're
basically going to a place called Alcor
right which is basically this kind of uh
what you would normally expect with
Peter Parker receiving is his
radioactive spider bite right in that
particular location and that's exactly
what happens now of course as you also
expect if you're familiar with the
existing Spider-Man Mythos Mary Jane
Watson's basically in with Flash
Thompson now it didn't historically work
this way but it's one of the things
where it's basically the love interest
of Peter Parker is dating the school
bully right and so because of that one
of the things to know this is something
that I think a lot of young people
struggle with why do girls like bullies
or why do girls like guys who are jerks
because they exude confidence man like
they they are just they're some of the
most confident people you're ever going
to find and one of the things that you
will learn over the course of your life
is confidence is key right like you
don't even have to be confident you just
need to look confident right but like
confidence will get you where you want
to be in this world right believing in
yourself and so one of the things that's
kind of given here and even one of the
things that Mary Jane Watson discusses
is this idea that this this institution
right Alcor is basically a place where
they like experiment on animals they
conduct a lot of heinous research here
right a lot of terrible terrible things
all in the pursuit of Science and so one
of the crazy things about this is that
unlike days past when Peter was more of
the the Curious one right the one who
would stray off the beaten path in order
to find his own way or to kind of go
into that room and feel you know to kind
of see what's going on what you actually
get here is Mary Jane Watson that leads
him into a Restricted Section it's one
of these things where like her goal is
to save animals right to save as many
animals as they possibly can and so
Peter actually ends up reaching into a
into a container that holds an
irradiated arachnid female and of course
it bites awesome when that happens Mary
Jane Watson of course has a rabbit
because of the fact that they enter the
room and basically started messing with
stuff it activated the entire alarm
system and security shows up and so
while they're kind of being interred
there Mary Jane Watson's parents of
course come and pick her up Peter
Parker's parents are dead right that's
one of the things he says is like his
parents are dead and he basically lives
with Uncle Ted who's basically a
stand-in for Uncle Ben because seemingly
Aunt May is not really part of the
picture and we're not really given an
explanation as to why his aunt's not
there but we can largely assume that
they are basically separated right that
they basically split up and we'll get
more of an explanation as to why that's
the case here in a second but Mary Jane
Watson having lived next to Peter Parker
it's kind of like look you know he can
come home with us right I mean they have
to release him to like an adult Guardian
but it's like he can come home with us
it's fine you know everything is going
to be cool and so when he gets back home
that's when his uncle Ted shows up and
what you end up finding out is that
Peter Parker is the the way that he is
because of the abuse he sustains at the
hands of his uncle so for those of you
guys who aren't really familiar with
this kind of stuff the old adage is that
sociopaths are made and psychopaths are
born and for the most part that's kind
of old hat that stuff doesn't really
apply anymore and even the term
sociopath and psychopath are considered
Antiquated terms that by and large the
notion of a psychopath versus a
sociopath just kind of fall under the
umbrella of anti-social personality
disorder and a lot of that's because the
various attributes of the two cross over
in a lot of ways right like a psychopath
lacks the ability to feel remorse a
psychopath lacks the ability to feel
empathy a sociopath can feel empathy and
where a psychopath may be a lot more
controlled a lot more manipulative far
more planning and their approach to
different situations sociopaths will be
far more hot-headed right they'll be
impulsive different things like that at
the end of the day both of them can be
made right there are genetic components
to a psychopath but it's not necessarily
that way that Peter here looks to be a
classic case of what we would call a
sociopath right that he was made this
way and the reason why is because his
uncle's head is highly abusive right
that he considers Peter to basically be
this kind of goofball this kind of kid
who's always problematic and even goes
as far as to say that he never should
have let Social Services talk him into
taking Peter in and so we actually beats
Peter and while that's happening because
Mary Jane Watson lives across the street
she hears it happening right it brings
tears to her eyes but she hears Peter
begging as is his uncle just beats him
right on a daily basis now when that
happens or at least following that at
least the next day anyway the kind of
impulses that Peter begins to experience
as a result of the spider bite begin to
manifest now this is where things
totally change because in the main
Marvel Universe and really most
alternate reality stories that involve
Peter Parker or some variation of Peter
Parker whether it's a you know
spider-gwen or somebody like that the
the whole process of him becoming
Spider-Man usually manifests in the fact
that one he feels more confident he
feels more energetic right like as if
he's just been working out his entire
life and is just now feeling the effects
of it as well as the traditional things
that you're used to seeing him crawling
on walls his Spider Sense different
things along those lines in this
instance whether it's because of his
upbringing or something along those
lines the powers that begin to manifest
actually fall in the range of more
violent and dark abilities right in the
sense that like he experiences a kind of
hunger and so as a result of this he
actually ends up grabbing a mouse that
was caught in a mousetrap and
essentially consumes it following that
he goes after a cat and then in turn
when the cat scratches him and begins to
get away he ends up shooting his webbing
by accident realizing that he has it and
snares the cat and then realizes he can
make a kind of home for himself right in
the same way that a spider will fashion
a web Peter Begins the same thing here
and so what ends up happening is later
on that night of course uncle Ted comes
home and things happen exactly as you
would expect them to right and some of
you might have been watching this like
yeah man it's about time uncle Ted got
his due right so ultimately uh when
Uncle Ted comes in of course the lights
are out the whole thing's done he's
pissed off that Peter doesn't have
dinner ready when he gets into his room
he basically finds all these different
just kind of cocoon type things right
basically all these animals from around
the neighborhood that have basically
been ensnared by Peter that he's
essentially saving as meals and that's
what spiders do right spiders will catch
an object or catch a thing that shows up
in their web or at least activates their
web they'll ensnare it and then
sometimes they'll eat it immediately
other times they'll store it for later
use but regardless Peter's just laying
in weight basically attached to his
ceiling and then immediately goes after
his uncle Ted right now following that
you basically end up picking up with him
as he's making his way to school and of
course you've got all these posters for
missing cats and different things along
those lines right animals that have
vanished and then Flash Thompson shows
up right Flash Thompson starts giving
him a hard time having no idea that
Peter is basically eating a bird that he
had kept away in his locker which is
really kind of weird but with Flash
Thompson giving him a hard time kind of
making fun of him that sort of a thing
you know ultimately Peter kind of does
exactly what you've seen over the course
of the traditional Spider-Man Mythos
where he stands up to Flash Thompson
with this new vow of confidence the
difference here is that unlike Peter who
usually gets in some kind of a fight
with flash overpowers him and then
basically demonstrates I'm not someone
to be trifled with in this instance he
kills Flash Thompson and he eats it
right now you don't actually see it
happen instead it's alluded to right
flash says like you won't be laughing
when I wipe that grin off your face with
my fist and then in turn Peter's like
you know well name a time and a place
and Flash says okay well then how about
during lunch right out in like the in
the the locker room and so it's like
lunch that sounds perfect right and so
given what we've seen so far Peter's
basically going to eat Flash Thompson
now following that of course again after
school making his way back to his home
he ends up coming across a kid who's
putting up a poster looking for his pet
Peter leads him back to his house and
then ultimately seems to consume that
kid as well and so all this comes to a
head with Mary Jane showing up at his
house last night and the reason why is
because Flash Thompson hasn't shown up
right she doesn't know where he is he
usually always calls that kind of a
thing and Peter kind of dismisses it and
so far as just being like I mean what do
you ever see in that guy anyway right
you know it's kind of like you know the
guy was always a jerk like why would you
date somebody like him you know and so
there is almost kind of a romantic
moment right with this sort of new
confidence that Peter has again much
like you would normally see in the main
Spider-Man Mythos he makes a move on
Mary Jane Watson the difference here is
that after kissing her he immediately
bites her and of course with that in
mind when she smacks him and just
basically knocks Away part of the skin
on his face you actually see what he's
ended up becoming under his skin that he
is is basically a giant human spider I
mean he's got like eight eyes and just
like these mandibles coming out of his
mouth and all kinds of crazy stuff right
of course Mary Jane watts is terrified
for her life ends up stumbling into his
room to find his uncle strapped to the
bed Peter's basically just been feeding
on him all this time and then the kid
that he had kidnapped earlier is
basically strung upside down with Peter
having the intention to feed on him at a
later date right I mean I told you guys
man this story gets dark dude it's it is
dark
now the funny thing about this is that
in this whole process as Mary Jane is
trying to like get away from Peter right
he's kind of stalking her a little bit
and she's begging for her life and he's
like look I'm not I wouldn't hurt you
like why would I why would I kill you
you know that's that's never gonna
happen you know like you know he's like
today like I'm a carrier right you're
gonna be the mother of my children and
that's when you end up finding out that
what he had done with Uncle Ted is he
had actually deposited spider eggs in
him and all those spider eggs just come
pouring out of him right his mouth his
ears his eyes the whole nine yards just
come dumping out of the sky they
immediately go and try to try to
basically swarm to Mary Jane and then of
course that basically leads to the
arrival of more lung now here's the
thing about this this again Tana ties
into the nature of spider-verse that
Morlan is one of the inheritors and what
these guys are doing is just traveling
around the Multiverse killing everybody
who is basically some variation of
Spider-Man doesn't matter who they are
or what they are and that's kind of the
irony behind this is because under
normal circumstances when you look at
the edge of spite of her stories or even
the lead up to spider-verse that Moulin
was basically a bad guy right killing
the Spiderman who Heroes who are just
trying to do the right thing and this
instance he's kind of more of a good guy
right now he's a good guy by
circumstance it's not as though he
somehow changed his tune decided to
become a hero killing off all the
different evil Spider-Man across the
Multiverse it just happens to be this is
a universe where Peter Parker ended up
becoming some giant Twisted version of a
human spider and was about to kill Mary
Jane and he showed up and just happened
to rescue her right the funny thing
about this is that when you're talking
about somebody like Milan and this is
something that we've seen consistently
this dude's on a whole different level
this this kid right I mean he's only
been Spider-Man or at least been a
Spider-Man s character for like a couple
days or something like that so quite
literally Morlan tears this kid apart I
mean he rips his arm off he tears the
mandibles out of his face I mean he he
just wrecks this kid right and then in
turn just absorbs all the life force
from him and basically kills him in the
process and so following that what you
end up doing is picking up with Mary
Jane Watson the next day and so as she's
kind of getting ready for school and all
that kind of stuff you basically end up
having her looking at this bite that she
has from Peter Parker and then some
suddenly there's movement only for a
baby spider to crawl out and suddenly
for like all these spiders to come
dumping out of this opening presumably
to consume Mary Jane Watson alive
all right what's going on guys this is
Rob we are back with spider-verse now
this is the week of Thanksgiving so just
so you guys know videos are gonna be
pretty scant this week we're kind of
hammering them out on Monday and Tuesday
and then my guys get the rest of the
week off normally I would just give them
the whole week but I wanted to kind of
upload some of these or at least record
some of these and we were running a
little short on time last week and over
the course of the weekend so um you'll
have three videos you'll have this one
you'll have a second one on Wednesday
we'll have beyond omega level on Friday
and then that'll be it um and then next
week we'll pick back up with our regular
scheduled programming so what this does
here is this picks up with Earth 98 120
yet another alternate reality here in
Marvel Comics and this one specifically
focuses on Miguel O'Hara now one of the
things about this is that this version
of Miguel is actually part of the
Avengers of this universe and we'll
explain Miguel here in a little bit or
at least give him a little more detail
but this version of Miguel here again is
part of the Avengers is basically
experiencing this kind of feeling where
somebody's stalking him right where
somebody's hunting him now here's one of
the big differences between Miguel
O'Hara and the other Spider-Man and this
is something that we'll address as
things go on with spider-verse is that
each time a version of Miguel is killed
he feels it right he actually
experiences a kind of dizziness or kind
of haziness that impacts him physically
whenever that happens now this
particular Miguel doesn't really seem to
experience that instead you basically
have more Lun who shows up on the scene
and basically overpowers the Avengers
and what actually overpowers these guys
it's no small thing right like these are
some Heavy Hitters in Marvel Comics well
heavy might be a a little over
exaggeration here I mean you got Captain
America and you got Wolverine that's
cool you do have genus valve this guy is
nuts okay assuming this guy has the same
power that his main Marvel Universe
version does he's actually a genetically
created version of Marvel of the creek
but this guy got so powerful he actually
recreated the universe right this guy's
Powers is just it's stupid right he was
so powerful Marvel had to kill him off
and then basically replace him with
philavel of course philavel was really
really really cool she ended up becoming
the new Quasar in Marvel Comics during
the whole Dan abnick Cosmic era but
nonetheless this guy's a universal force
is basically what we're getting at here
right more Lund overpowers every single
one of these guys like he literally
drains genus Vel of his cosmic energy he
attacks Wolverine and Captain America
takes both those guys out and then in
turn kills Miguel O'Hara siphons his
energy off and then basically bails now
in that version of Miguel O'Hara dies
Miguel O'Hara from the main Marvel
universe that's the one who experiences
this whole thing every single time that
happens it almost kind of seems like
he's losing a piece of himself right
it's kind of a a mental backlash to a
degree now while this is happening of
course he's currently in the present in
the main Marvel Universe it's a whole
story arc involving like Tyler Stone and
everything from his timeline not overly
important here the fact is that he is
currently here in the present day
there's some villains that are trying to
get away he of course ends up
incapacitating them but the first thing
he comes to the realization of is with
all this going on I need to get a hold
of Peter Parker right I need to find out
what's going on here and so what he ends
up realizing here is that with
everything going on once these criminals
are basically sorted out at this point
it's on the hunt that caused him to feel
this just kind of giant headache of
what's going on there and so what you
end up doing is that in this moment when
you have more Lund that kills that
alternate reality version of Miguel
O'Hara there's actually a kind of portal
which is more of a viewing screen that
opens that allows Miguel O'Hara from
Earth 6375 to view everything that's
happening and of course he's basically
realizing that Moreland and the
inheritors are killing all the different
versions of himself now for those of the
guys who are familiar with Marvel Comics
specifically in the mid-2000s with
Exiles issue number 75 you know who this
this guy Miguel O'Hara is he was part of
the Exiles for a long time now for those
of you guys who don't know who the
Exiles are they're probably one of the
most underutilized but most interesting
superhero teams in all of Marvel Comics
these guys basically travel the
Multiverse and so you got some stupidly
good stories with the Exiles back in the
day the Exile stories I actually enjoyed
the most were the ones that were
basically Post House of him the world
tour story arc so you got to see them
traveling to like the future imperfect
Universe with Maestro Hulk you got to
see all kinds of cool stuff right it was
awesome to see them travel the most
popular alternate realities in Marvel
Comics but they were basically like like
imagine an Avengers team on a
multiversal level that was basically the
Exiles I'm very very certain we're gonna
see them in the future of the MCU coming
out of the events of Doctor Strange 2.
assuming the Multiverse remains intact
but nonetheless this guy Miguel O'Hara
was part of them now one of the things
he says is that while he was there with
the Exiles he did become aware of
Moreland and the inheritors but they
never actually cross paths and a lot of
that was just because of what we saw
when it came to like spider UK right
like like the incursions dealing with
all that stuff and the fact that like
saturnin didn't really care about the
fact that more Lund and all the
inheritors were hunting the Spider-Man
from across the Multiverse that the
Multiverse itself was actually failing
while the Exiles were a big thing in the
mid-2000s and the multiversal collapse
had not actually begun yet there were a
lot of other threats out there the
Exiles had to deal with and so the
reality is these different inheritors
traveling around the Multiverse and
killing Spider-Man wasn't the most
important thing to the Exiles and
honestly they didn't realize how far
reaching it was it was really more
Whispers And murmurs right things that
people were kind of talking about and
these sort of shadowy corners of the
Multiverse but nobody really knew that
it was as big as it was but the
inheritors had been killing hundreds if
not thousands of Spider-Man up to that
point and they've just continued on
during this time right and so as a
result of that with this alternate
reality version of Miguel he realizes
that there's so few Miguel O'Hara's left
in the Multiverse that his idea is to
basically find as many alternate
versions of himself as he can and then
basically unite them that's an important
thing to grasp here this guy doesn't
know superior Spider-Man is assembling
an entire spider Army he's totally
unaware of that and it makes sense right
if I asked you right now what's going on
in Times Square like what are people
doing in Times Square you couldn't give
me an answer because you're not there
you have no idea what's happening out
there unless you have an apartment that
overlooks Times Square and you're
watching this video then sure you could
give me an answer but outside of that
give me an answer that's what we're
talking about right I mean it's one of
the things we've said before the
Multiverse is a big place and so it's
very very easy for all kinds of things
to happen out there and for you to have
no idea that any of it's actually
happening now this also seems to
indicate that each one of the Miguels
were that were killed had never seen or
never been greeted by the spider Army of
of superior Spider-Man either that or if
it did happen it was after this version
of Miguel stopped watching and so
regardless his response this alternate
reality version of Miguel is we need to
go to the Earth 616 Universe we need to
go to the main Marvel Universe and when
this reality's version of Mary Jane
Watson asks him why are we going there
his response is because it's the one
place that Moreland is scared of right
it's basically kind of like a safe haven
he's like more Lund doesn't want to go
to the main Marvel Universe he's afraid
of being there he's died there before
and every time he goes there he seems to
die so he's just terrified of it the
problem is that main universe is not a
permanent safe space because while more
Lun is afraid to go there his other
relatives are not and so it's only a
matter of time before they show up in
that universe and try to attack that
reality's version of Peter Parker but at
the end of the day we need to go find
Miguel O'Hara in the 616 Universe
wherever it is that he happens to be and
so what ends up happening here is that
following Miguel's story he begins kind
of experiencing again one of these just
giant headaches and then following his
kind of leaving a big meeting and going
onto the rooftop the portal opens up and
when it does you're basically met by the
arrival of Morlan that caught up with
Spider-Man 2099 from Earth 6375. it
killed that alternate reality version of
Miguel and when he did of course he
siphoned off his energy basically you
know taking his life force and then
Miguel again experiences that massive
headache that basically happens whenever
an alternate reality version of himself
dies and so of course more Lund drops
the body but it's one of the funny
things here is that Miguel watches all
this happen and while it seems like
Moreland is standing there for hours in
reality it's only been a couple seconds
or so but he looks terrified he's afraid
to enter the main Marvel Universe it
terrifies him because he's just been
killed by Peter Parker every time he's
come there and so he doesn't actually
enter instead he just stays and then
eventually the portal closes and he
basically walks away but because of this
because of the fact that main Marvel
Universe Miguel right 616 Miguel
Witnesses the death of his alternate
reality counterpart that he basically
realizes we've got to find Peter Parker
now having said that there are a couple
things that I do want to address here
first and foremost this version of
Miguel O'Hara the main Marvel Universe
Miguel O'Hara he is referred to as 616
Miguel that's actually not accurate
technically he comes from Earth 928
which is in the future Earth 2099 was
initially the actual future of the main
Marvel Universe until Marvel started
abandoning the ideas of guaranteed
Futures and in turn turn them into
alternate realities just possible
Futures and so that's why you see
stories like Marvel 2099 you see Days of
Future Past Old Man Logan they're all
referred to as alternate realities
because while any one of these universes
could actually become the future of
Marvel Comics we wouldn't really know
until we got to that point and creating
an absolute guaranteed future started to
become a big No-No under Joe Casada
right it was one of those things where
make it an alternate reality it's a
possible future that way we're not
locked into having to make sure that
everything that we publish leads into
that future and so the other thing about
this is the reason why Miguel has these
headaches is because the alternate
reality version of himself from 6375 had
basically used Exile technology across
the Multiverse to create a kind of
headband that psychically linked every
single Miguel O'Hara now it wasn't as
though all the Miguels knew of all the
other Miguel's instead it allowed him to
know where all the Miguels were at and
what they were doing but because of the
fact that the headband was linked to the
Multiverse it linked all the Miguels to
him using a psychic connection and
that's why the main Marvel Universe
Miguel O'Hara would experience those
headaches because he was basically
getting visions of when each version of
himself died it's also the reason why
when that version of Miguel with the
headband died the headache that Miguel
experienced was worse than any of the
others and so again I felt like that
just kind of needed to be stated it here
I know it seemed a little confusing at
first and that was one of the things
that I didn't initially catch on to when
we originally covered spider-verse but I
felt like it was something to sort of
reiterate here so
what's going on guys this is Rob and
Happy Thanksgiving a day early
ethically it's not until tomorrow but if
you're anything like me you're gonna be
filling your bellies full of food you're
gonna get the itis you're gonna get a
good night's sleep and then you're gonna
wake up bright in early on Friday and
try to make it to those Black Friday
sales I know I am I got my credit card
paid off and everything I'm ready to
match this thing out I'm gonna be
painfully irresponsible with my
financial life on Friday
but we are officially here with the
actual Main spider-verse Event only took
us like a month to get here so all the
lead up is done right basically all the
lead up is finished we're in the main
event now the throws of spider-verse so
we pick up with Peter Parker as he has
contacted at 6 a.m by Jay Jonah Jameson
who basically sends him over to
Armstrong Park and the reason why is
that in Armstrong Park there's just some
guy out there causing all kinds of
problems and ripping stuff up only for
us to find out that it's more Lun now
here's a crazy thing about this right
off the bat Peter doesn't recognize him
he doesn't know who he is instead more
Lund is kind of taunts him the same way
that he always has and saying like we've
done this on so many Earths across the
Multiverse you know and it's almost one
of these things where he's like where he
kind of explains who he is and Peter's
like I mean I have no idea what you're
talking about we're not even on Earth
and then response more or less like I
don't even know why I bother explaining
this when all you guys do is die and
then he in turn just kills Spider-Man
only for us to find out that this is
actually Earth 449 this is an alternate
reality where Humanity had basically
colonized the moon and they live on the
blue area of the Moon those of you guys
who don't know what that is the blue
area of the moon is the oxygen-rich area
of the moon right where you can really
have entire bases of operations the
Watchers stayed there the Inhumans lived
there apocalypse the X-Men villain had a
base of operations there for a while
it's been used by a lot of people it was
created by the cree when they were
working on creating the Inhumans on
Earth and it just stayed there ever
since but we end up switching back to
what's basically Loom world right this
is Earth one this is the base of
operations for the inheritors this is
where these guys operate out of and
again they work directly with or really
control the master Weaver now remember
the master Weaver is the guy who
basically controls the gateway to
alternate Dimensions the way this is
depicted and the way that it's done you
have what's essentially called the web
of life and Destiny it's a really overly
convoluted and complicated method of
explaining the idea that the master
Weaver can basically allow people or at
least open a portal using the web of
life and Destiny to transport anybody to
any universe that's connected to the Web
of Life and Destiny right so it's
literally these strands like it looks
like a giant web but each one of these
universes is basically represented as a
strand as part of this web so if you
were to cut away a universe from this
web and remove it then it would be
isolated from the rest of the Multiverse
now one of the things that you guys are
also going to notice over the course of
the spider-verse event is that the web
of life and Destiny will actually begin
to shrink in size and the reason why is
because remember while the whole of
spider versus taking place the events of
Jonathan Hickman's Avengers and New
Avengers are going on so universes are
smashing into each other they're being
destroyed too at a time it's just the
collapse of everything the end of
everything and that's it's a really
really cool depiction by Dan slot in
them to actually shrink the web of life
and Destiny as the entire events of the
incursions go on showing us that the
Multiverse is getting smaller universes
are being destroyed and of course this
leads to more lunge showing up here
after basically consuming Spider-Man
from Earth 449 and he's actually kind of
teased by his brothers and sisters now
that's one of the things to know here is
the inheritor family is pretty prideful
and they're also just dicks but it's
also one of these things where they're
exceedingly arrogant and so far as
they're like we're at the top of the
food chain and in a lot of ways they are
they really really are right they're
arrogant but they can also back it up
right technically they feed or they can
feed on anything that is part of the
animal totem right so any superhero that
represents some aspect of the animal
kingdom like Panther Spider-Man anybody
out there like that they can feed on
those individuals but they prefer to
feed on spiders and in fact they were
directed by their father to feed on
spiders and seemingly nothing else so
we'll actually get a motivation for that
when we're introduced to the father of
the inheritors because I'm gonna tell
you right now man that dude is broken
God he is so op it's nuts how cool he
was but the thing about this is his
family basically knows he avoids Earth
616 right he avoids the main Marvel
Universe and they kind of tease him
about it a little bit and so at the same
time of course you end up having Verna
who's basically one of the inheritors
who assembles her Hounds in reality this
is Dan slot borrowing heavily from the
events of Days of Future Past and I
would even go as far as to say that
because of the fact that the inheritors
have existed across the Multiverse they
probably came across Days of Future Past
for those of you guys who don't know how
that whole thing worked with Days of
Future Past as we talked about before it
was basically when things popped off the
mutants were considered a credible
threat and basically the Sentinel
program was activated became self-aware
and then conquered North America and
then basically set aside on trying to
conquer the world but because Sentinels
couldn't be everywhere one of the things
that they did is they created what were
called hounds basically mutants tasked
with tracking down other mutants Rachel
Summers was one of those right she now
she's in the main Marvel universe as
part of Jonathan Hickman's X-Men run but
when she originally appeared she was
initially a Hound she was used by the
Sentinels and even Some Humans before
the total Sentinel takeover to basically
hunt other mutants and bring them in and
so that's kind of where this seems to
come from as far as these hounds go what
you have is silver Sable you've got
Fireheart and you've basically got
Craven the hunter they basically helped
Verna track down spider totems across
the Multiverse and then basically help
her in her hunt for some people and even
other members of her family it looks
like it's just kind of cheating to a
degree that the nature of like hunting
the spider totems should be done is like
a solo act but they've sort of moved
Beyond this being a sort of right of
testing or right of approval and instead
moved into the direction of like now
it's just for fun right it's just for
sport just kind of what they do and so
at that point when when Verna goes on
her mission to find her spiders you end
up switching over to Peter Parker in the
main Marvel Universe right of course
again he's met by the arrival of silk we
talked about her before the two of them
can't stop banging there's a reason for
that there's a really really cool reason
for that the hierarchy and the role the
spider totems play Philadelphia Gods who
are a little curious were a little
confused about the nature of spider
totems that will all become clear as we
progress through the story so don't
worry I'm not going to leave you hanging
just kind of hang with me for a minute
but it's one of these things where Cindy
Moon actually pitches the idea that
because she's becoming more capable in
terms of her role as a spider that Peter
Parker should like leave New York or
even just leave Earth and like go to the
moon or go somewhere else right it
doesn't really matter I mean she's half
joking here here but she's also half
serious because as long as the two of
them operate in the same vicinity they
will be attracted to each other there
are hormones and really their role
within the nature of the spider totem
hierarchy will bring them together and
they will ultimately end up just
ignoring everything and just procreating
like rabbits again right but what you
end up finding out here is that
following the events of spider Island
flows you got to remember that when you
had like the you know everybody on on
the island of New York literally turning
into a spider that one of the things
that Doctor Octopus had done when he was
superior Spider-Man as he had largely
formed his own kind of spider Army what
you ended up getting was actually a
whole bunch of these criminals who just
stole these suits in Tech they pretended
to work for Spider-Man and then robbed a
bank which is actually not the most
unintelligent thing to do it's a pretty
good plan now of course Peter Parker and
Cindy Moon catch up to them but while
Peter Parker is trying to apprehend
these guys suddenly he's met by Jessica
Drew Spider-Woman as well as Anya
Corazon and then Miguel O'Hara now
Jessica Drew most of you guys know from
from Marvel Comics you guys have heard
of her right she's Spider Woman She's an
Avenger that kind of The Thing Miguel
O'Hara we just talked about in the
previous video Anya Corazon is somebody
who's actually worth discussing here so
Anya corazon's not really an actual
spider person meaning she wasn't really
bitten by a radioactive spider per se
she's actually part of a group called
The Spider society which has existed for
a long long time so if the inheritors
hunt down spider totems and then kill
them and consume their energy then the
spider Society is the antithesis of that
they actually worship spider totems and
so while they wouldn't necessarily
attack anybody out there who is a
quote-unquote villain they will fight
anybody who is considered to be a threat
to anybody who's an actual spider person
now the other thing about this is that
for the spider Society to be effective
they had what are called Hunters which
were basically their soldiers and they
were individuals who were imbued with
what was essentially mysticism that gave
them the powers of a spider and that's
where Anya Corazon comes from initially
it was believed that she was supposed to
be a hunter that ended up changing later
on in Marvel Comics they actually
switched it to a new person instead of
Earth but for a time she was pretty cool
and pretty popular the overall gist here
is that there's all kinds of members of
the spider Community here more so than
that you get Billy Braddock right so
spider UK which we've talked about him
we've covered him Mayday Parker we
covered her spider ham is here like it's
just this enormous coming together of
all these different spider characters
now here's the thing to understand Peter
Parker doesn't know what's going on with
all the different Spider-Man being
hunted across the Multiverse he has no
idea that's happening he doesn't even
know that like the entire spider Army is
being assembled remember Peter Parker's
just got his body back from when Dr
Octopus had an a superior Spider-Man and
so where Dr Octopus superior Spider-Man
was assembling this great big huge
spider Army this all happened without
Peter Parker being aware of what was
going on he initially thinks it's
Mysterio that Mysterio is messing with
his head he's using some kind of trick
or something like that to dupe
Spider-Man Spider Sense and to basically
send all this stuff into disarray and
make it look like this kind of thing is
going on which really speaks volumes
about the character of Mysterio because
he could do it right that's just how
good he is now of course this leads to
MayDay Parker revealing her identity and
basically telling Peter no right like we
are actually here it's not some kind of
an illusion you know me you've met me
before everything's cool essentially we
really do have a big thing going on we
need you here right and that's when
spider UK is like you faced the threat
before like it's more Lun like more Lon
is who we have to deal with now where
Peter thinks that mourlan is coming back
the response to spider UK is no it's not
Marlon who's coming here it's his
brother Deimos and that's when Peter
begins to learn more Lunds got relatives
remember up until this point this moment
right here Peter only thought it was
more Lund he thought that was it right
more Lund was like just the inheritor
that like Ezekiel Sims the person who
warned Peter Parker about Moreland in
the early days of Jane Michael
susinski's run when all of this really
began if we're being honest with
ourselves uh that that there wasn't
really a whole lot of discussion about
the extended family of Moreland it was
really just maulana's hunting you Peter
make sure you stay safe because you'll
take your energy and kill you right
that's basically what he'll do and so it
was just kind of Peter fleeing for his
life against Milan than eventually
really fighting him and then killing him
a handful of times and so this is the
first time Peter learns that is actually
a huge inheritor family and there's more
than just more Lund that there's
actually other people there and so the
response is yes Peter like more Lund's
brother is coming here there is a big
inheritor family we have to go like you
have to get to this portal we need to
take off as fast as we possibly can now
at that point you switch over to one
degree mountain in Eastern Europe right
the home of the high evolutionary and
you pick up with Kane now here's the
thing about Kane right Kane Ben Riley
all these guys so here's the thing about
this so back in the 1990s and we've
actually got these videos covered here
on the channel and they're part of the
Spider-Man playlist if you want to check
them out after this video but what you
had was a story called the clone saga
probably one of the most reviled stories
among Spider-Man fans right it's one of
those where it was just it was only
supposed to be like maybe a 12 or 13
issue series and they ended up expanding
it and it spanned like three years right
it was just it ballooned up to being
unnecessarily large but the overall gist
here is that Kane and Ben Reilly were
clones of Peter Parker that were created
by the jackal and the idea was to
basically screw at the head of Peter to
even convince him that he himself was a
clone and so the whole just behind the
story was it was Marvel asking us as the
reader which one of these guys is the
actual real Peter Parker because you
didn't know which one it was you didn't
know if it was Ben Wiley you didn't know
if it was Kane and he didn't know if it
was Peter Parker uh again that's one of
the reasons why it wasn't very well
received but Kane has just kind of here
as part of Mount wundergore basically
keeping all the people here protected
and then he's met by demos who basically
begins the process of trying to kill him
and consume his energy now as he goes in
for the kill against Kane that's when
you end up getting Bruce Banner from
Earth 7105 who's not a Hulk but he is a
Spider-Man the old man spider of Earth 4
whose identity is never given to us and
then a few others he of course got Gwen
Stacy's spider-gwen who's here as well
and that as they're basically trying to
trying to protect Kane and then fight
off damos you've got Ben Reilly who
steps in right now this is the
Spider-Man of Earth 94 so it's not the
main Marvel Universe version of Peter
Parker he's been recruited here by by
the other members of the Spider-Man Army
so that's why you have a Ben Reilly here
it's not the Ben Reilly just a Ben
Reilly from an alternate reality but for
the most part during this whole conflict
Bruce Banner from this alternate reality
is killed right or at least his back is
broken so they basically leave him for
dead there's nothing they can do and in
reality it's not really a kind of
coldness that leads them to do that it's
because it's just practicality right
that if they were to stay there and they
were to fight damos they would lose more
than just one guy and so ultimately it's
one of those things where it's like we
can't sacrifice the entire team for just
one individual right like it sucks we
gotta leave him behind but we do and so
what you end up getting is all these
guys going through this portal and then
showing up in Central Park in Earth 13.
now Earth 13 is probably one of the
coolest universes that you don't really
get a whole lot of exposition about
Instead This is the story where Peter
Parker never lost the Enigma Force so
back in 1989 well really December of
1989 running into 1990 Marvel had a
story called acts of Vengeance and this
is basically a story where Loki brought
together all the different villains this
or at least the most popular villains of
Marvel Comics and then switched around
who they were going to fight and had
them fight against different Heroes and
so during this time what you had was a
manifestation of the Enigma Force now
the Enigma Force is exactly what you
think it is right it's a super powerful
force of energy but we don't really know
much about it outside of the fact that
it basically comes from the microverse
right like literally a microscopic
Universe inside the main Marvel Universe
but the overall gist here is that
whenever the Enigma Force appears it's
like The Watcher showing up right like
it's a significant thing during the acts
of engine storyline the Enigma Force
possessed Spider-Man because it was on
the hunt for a person that it needed to
possess and it's one of those things
where the Enigma Force does that it'll
appear and then it'll bond to a person
and then a successive series of people
until it finally settles on a compatible
host Peter Parker happened to be one of
those and it was actually a really cool
thing there was one point where he
punched the incredible Hulk like into
space it was amazing but basically Earth
13 is a universe where Peter never lost
the Enigma Force where he basically held
on to it seemingly even all the way up
to this point right he's just super
powerful now one of the things to know
is the Enigma Force has been shown to be
capable in different capacities over the
years so it's really inconsistent in
terms of its power level but a lot of
what's going on here is just hitting
Peter Parker exceedingly hard because
it's a lot to happen at one time
basically in a matter of what we could
probably attribute to being 20 minutes
or so he's met all these alternate
reality versions of himself including an
animated version of himself who's a pig
right it's cool to see Ben Wiley again
an alternate reality version of himself
that basically never became or never got
rid of the Enigma Force and then while
all that's going on when he's asked the
question like like why you know what why
am I here right like why is this whole
big thing being a symbol he's told
because the inheritors are here right
like one of the things he's told by
Spider-Man from Earth 13 is that because
the Enigma Force is part and parcel to a
universe if he were to leave his
Universe then he would basically lose
the power of the Enigma Force he would
just become a regular Spider-Man and
that's why Earth 13 is a safe haven
because this guy is a cosmic care
character and his argument is if the
inheritors were to show up here to this
reality I would obliterate them it would
be it'd be a Fool's errand right it'd be
a suicide mission and that's why they
use this as a safe place but he says
this battle that's happening Peter this
war with like all this stuff the
inheritors we have you here because
you're our secret weapon you're the
greatest of us all right you're the only
one who's ever faced against Moreland
and survived not only that actually
killed him a couple times and then
beyond that there's actually a much
bigger role that Peter's going to play
as part of this great big huge
spider-verse event that's when I say
this fighter totems will be explained
but what we end up doing here is
switching over to an alternate reality
it's labeled as Earth 610 for those of
you guys who read the original
spider-verse event you guys know is
actually 16 10. why does 1610 matter
because ladies and gentlemen this
universe is home to what I consider to
be the greatest spider character ever
made in the history of Marvel Comics
none other than Miles Morales yes it is
and Miles Morales is about to have a
very very terrible experience because as
he is mourning the loss of his mother
Rio Morales because this takes place
right when his mom dies you've
immediately got the arrival of Verna and
all of her hounds that just come pouring
in with the intention of killing miles
killing this reality's version of
Jessica Drew who's basically a clone of
Peter Parker consuming their energies
and walking away
she's my cherry pie cool drink of water
such a sweet surprise tastes so good
make a grown man cry sweet cherry pie
hello everyone
how are you guys doing today as you guys
could tell I'm in much better spirits
I'm still a little nasally but I'm in
much much better Spirit also for a
couple reasons one because I get to see
an early screening of Spider-Man no way
home this weekend for the Press junket
which is gonna be cool so I get to
interview the cast no idea who I'm gonna
interview yet and two I have a theory
about Spider-Man no way then I'm going
to talk about over a geek culture
explained probably on Wednesday so
here's the thing let us continue with
our discussion on spider-verse
specifically where we picked off with
last time when I left you guys on a
massive Cliffhanger which was Verna of
the inheritors basically going after
Miles Morales the Ultimate Spider-Man
now as soon as this happens you
immediately are met by the arrival of
assassin Spider-Man and Spider Punk
right punk rock Spider-Man but these
guys basically show up and they're able
to fight off Verna in her forces pretty
quickly and then of course they
immediately recruit miles as well as
Jessica Drew from the Ultimate Universe
and we'll talk about her here in a
second but one of the funny things about
this is that Miles recognizes superior
Spider-Man and he recognizes them from
the events of cataclysm well technically
it was cataclysm The ultimate's Last
Stand and Miles Morales only saw
superior Spider-Man for like two seconds
while he was trying to escape the Baxter
building in the main Marvel Universe
when they were time displaced to an
alternate reality after Wolverine broke
time in Age of Ultron there was a lot
that happened in cataclysm the important
thing is Miles Morales didn't know that
was superior Spider-Man he thought it
was just regular Peter Parker wearing a
different costume albeit a better
costume but the important thing here is
that because they're basically on the
verge of death this leads to Miles and
Jessica Drew basically going alongside
superior Spider-Man and everybody else
now at that point you switch over to
Earth 13. this is something I want to
clarify for everybody because of
something that seemed to throw people
off in the last few videos that we did
and this is largely my fault for not
making this a little clear what you have
here are basically two teams of
Spider-Man that by and large don't seem
to be aware of the other that you've got
superior Spider-Man and his team and
then you've got this team that grabbed
Peter Parker and have him in the safe
zone for Earth 13. so that's something
that I wanted to sort of explain here
now the other thing that goes on is
again we'll kind of explain this as we
go forward into the future of the
spider-verse event but one of the things
that's going on here is that again they
refer to Peter Parker as basically their
chosen one and this is for a couple
different reasons but the most
significant reason is because he's the
only Spider-Man across the entirety of
the Multiverse seemingly that's faced
off against an inheritor and not only
lived but actually killed them remember
more Lunds died a couple times at the
hands of Spider-Man and so because of
that he's kind of like the guy that
they're really picking to sort of lead
them into the whole thing because he
seems to be the one to actually know how
to win now while all that's going on you
of course have Cindy Moon and again
because of the fact that she's the bride
as part of the spider totems again we'll
explain that uh in future videos that
what happens is she actually kind of
pokes around at these different versions
of Peter Parker now the reason why is
because as we discuss again in a
previous video Peter Parker from The
main Marvel Universe gives off a kind of
scent a sort of pheromone that draws
Cindy moon to him and so the two of them
just can't stop knocking boots and so
Cindy Moon's question is if she's in
close proximity to other Spider-Man will
it have the exact same effect in the end
it doesn't really seem to be the case
that she does pick up on pheromones and
there is some general level of
attraction but damn slot doesn't really
differentiate between her just kind of
being like I mean that version of Peter
Parker is hot and her just kind of being
like I need to get with them right
because of like the pheromones and all
that kind of stuff the other part of
this is that with the team becoming
aware of the fact that there is a second
team of Spider-Man out there their goal
is to bring them to this universe
because remember Earth 13 is home to
Cosmic Spider-Man basically a version of
Peter Parker with the power Cosmic the
Enigma Force right he never lost it in
this universe like he did in the main
Marvel Universe and one of the things
that's been established here is that
because this version of Peter Parker has
so much power the inheritors would be
foolish to come here and to basically
start a conflict and so in a lot of ways
they're literally in just like this
giant Steel Vault right where they're
basically safe from the inheritors the
other spider team is like they're hiding
out in a hut made of straw right I mean
it's only a matter of time before the
inheritors find them and when they do
they'll overpower all of them especially
if the inheritors show up in a large
number and so you basically end up
seeing the group splitting off into
teams now there's a couple things that
happen here one Cindy moon is told to
stay put just because of the concern
being that with her having her
pheromones and all that kind of stuff
that it could lead the inheritors to
them and again that ties into the nature
of the totems but the other part is
Peter Parker doesn't want Spider Gwen to
go because as you guys know Gwen Stacy
died in his universe and so in a lot of
ways this kind of Peter Parker just not
wanting to relive the death of Gwen
Stacy one of those things where he
almost kind of believes in like
predestination that like Gwen Stacy
across the Multiverse is destined to die
he doesn't really say it but that's the
case you know we're not really even told
that's the case in all honesty the
continued existence of Gwen Stacy seems
to fly in the face of that but because
of the fact that it was a huge ordeal
for him he doesn't want to have to
experience that again let alone put her
in Jeopardy if he doesn't need to and so
what ends up happening is you basically
switch over to the team of superior
Spider-Man when all the other Spider-Man
emerged now here's an important thing to
understand as soon as Peter Parker from
The main Marvel Universe shows up here
he immediately recognized The Superior
Spider-Man but he doesn't say anything
right so superior Spider-Man does not
know this is Peter Parker who gets his
body back at a future point in time at
this point superior Spider-Man is just
kind of operating under the idea that he
will basically be Spider-Man forever
right or until his body gives out and he
dies whatever it is but he doesn't
really have to worry about losing his
body again to Peter Parker more so than
that what ends up happening is that
superior Spider-Man had actually
developed a device that basically masked
their scent from the inheritors so the
inheritors could show up on this world
and unless they're able to physically
locate the individual Spider-Man under
the protection of superior Spider-Man
they would never be found the problem
here is that this device is designed to
protect a particular number of people it
only has so much power to it with all
these other Spider-Man showing up here
it overrides the whole thing that
combined with the fact that Cindy Moon
ignores her orders and shows up in this
universe is basically ringing The Dinner
Bell right it's like giant purple
letters across the Multiverse telling
the inheritors hey we're all here and
the inheritors just come pouring in
right I mean really it's only Deimos who
shows up here but Damo shows up and
starts attacking everybody now here's a
big difference when it comes to Superior
Spider-Man one of the things that we
covered when we initially covered his
run one of the things that was made
apparent To Us by Dan slot is he does
not mess around that he is meticulous
when it comes to battle strategy and the
reason why is because Dr Octopus is so
incredibly intelligent and we'd have to
believe that when he began to realize
that Spider-Man from across the
Multiverse were being tracked down and
killed by the inheritors it wasn't
enough to assemble a team he also had to
have some kind of battle strategy for
what they could do when they faced off
against the inheritors because we saw
them fight against some of the
inheritors and they were overwhelmed
pretty quickly but as always Dr Octopus
learned from his mistakes and then went
forward from there and so that's why you
see him basically barking orders at
these different spiders women to attack
in different ways and by and large while
they don't necessarily get the upper
hand on Deimos they do exactly what they
were supposed to do which was create an
opening whereby superior Spider-Man
could deliver the killing blow and he
succeeds he kills demos right he kills
one of the inheritors and that's kind of
a funny thing because right off the bat
the response of that is something's
wrong that this body should have
basically broken down it's Peter Parker
who recognizes it right in the various
conflicts that he's had and the times
when more Lunas died his body has
dissolved and so that's one of the big
questions is why hasn't the body of
Deimos broken down here now of course
the response and really this is actually
something that's noticed by Miguel
O'Hara that there's what's basically a
stasis charge that what had happened is
Dr Octopus had augmented his Weaponry in
The Superior Spider-Man suit with 2099
technology and so what this is basically
done is it's put the body of Deimos in a
kind of stasis and so what this means is
they can take the body and then
literally analyze it study it they can
learn how the physio Theology of the
inheritor's work which is probably one
of the best possible things they could
have at their disposal right they can
find a weakness they can reverse
engineer how their powers work and find
a way to prevent the inheritors from
siphoning off the life force of the
Spider-Man themselves there's any number
of ways they can approach this now the
other thing about that is that Peter
Parker is not a fan of superior
Spider-Man killing demos now again this
to a degree is kind of the naive nature
of Peter Parker that if this was just
some random criminal out there sure I
guess an argument could be made but
you're literally talking about a force
of beings that are tracking them down
and that unless they're killed or
stopped incapacitated in some way they
will never stop they will always come
after them and so this is one of those
circumstances where the only way to stop
them is to kill them but the other big
problem is they realize that the scent
of of Cindy Moon of silk is basically
more potent than any of the other
Spider-Man here or at least that seems
to be the case and so for the most part
they are all kind of grasping at straws
and it's one the things that old man
spider says right we don't really know
the identity of this guy we suddenly
know they refer to him as old man we'll
find out who he is here in a minute but
he basically says like it doesn't matter
what any of you believe you're fumbling
around in the dark you have no idea
what's actually happening but I need to
explain it to you but in typical comic
book
fashion
killed not only is he killed he's killed
by damos and so what we end up finding
out here is that the inheritors have
found a way to Cone themselves that in
order to ensure that they won't be
killed in any one particular Universe
basically learning the lessons of what
happened to more Lund they send what are
essentially clone bodies of themselves
out into the Multiverse in order to
track down and kill these various
Spider-Man so that if one of these
inheritors are killed a clone takes
their place so they never have to worry
about actually dying off as a race it's
a genius maneuver it's an incredibly
intelligent thing to do and so with the
other inheritors showing up as well
basically totaling in three the only
thing these Spider-Man can do is run and
so they actually start breaking off into
groups the first group that breaks off
is Ben Reilly one of the Clones of Peter
Parker from an alternate reality and
Kane the clone of Peter Parker from The
main Marvel Universe along with Jessica
Drew who's a clone of Peter Parker from
The Ultimate Universe they break off to
go try to find the Clone Factory where
it is these inheritors are being created
other members of the Spider-Man team
start breaking off as well right you've
got Jessica Drew you've got Cindy Moon
they break off and do their thing they
kind of start splitting into factions
right Spider-Man Noir actually ends up
going with them this was basically
Marvel just kind of splitting the team
off in order to launch tie-in Comics
which we will cover and in fact we'll
transition to one of those here in a
second but what you actually end up
learning here as as Peter Parker begins
to make his escape and Miles Morales of
course goes through and all that kind of
stuff that he stopped by old man spider
who actually turns out to be Ezekiel
from an alternate reality now again
Ezekiel was the one who first introduced
Peter Parker in the main Marvel Universe
to everything involving the inheritors
in the first place that the inheritors
existed they were tracking down
Spider-Man all that kind of stuff right
all that work that J Michael strzinski
did that led into the Run of Dan slot
and this spider-verse event it all
hearkens back to the original Ezekiel
this version of Ezekiel is from a
reality where more Lund successfully
killed that universe's version of Peter
Parker and so he basically dawned the
Spider-Man costume or at least some
variation of it in order to carry on the
legacy of Peter Parker but what he says
and what he does is kind of give him not
really a list of names so much as a list
of titles he says the Scion the other
the bride they're all that matter these
individuals have to be kept safe that's
something that I want you guys to keep
in the back of your head but of course
again what this does is it leads to us
basically following the Clones
themselves right following Jessica Drew
following uh Ben Reilly and Kane now
again Jessica Drew is basically a clone
of Peter Parker from an alternate
universe from the Ultimate Universe and
in all honesty she's basically Black
Widow by all standards of measurement
right like the Ultimate Universe version
of that character and now that I think
about it I feel like that does deserve a
little bit of explanation so the way
this worked in the Ultimate Universe is
you did have a Natasha Romanov you did
have a black widow it turned out that in
Ultimate 2 issues 10 through 13 that she
was actually a traitor and she ended up
basically assisting the liberators kind
of like this invading group to topple
the United States which for the most
part they were successful in doing as
payback for the United States basically
toppling the Soviet Union ultimately she
was injured by Iron Man and then she was
killed in ultimates 2 issue number 13 by
Hawkeye and so really it was more young
ultimates than anything else but
technically it first happened in all new
ultimates volume 1. she donned the
moniker of Black Widow and then went
forward from there it was a way for
Marvel to kind of move her away from
being like the clone of Peter Parker in
the Ultimate Universe to basically
having like her own identity and her own
character it was cool for what it was I
didn't really care what moniker she had
I just loved the character in general
but uh all these guys or at least the
three of them basically show up in this
this alternate universe here and once
they get in there what they're expecting
because it seems to be the home world of
the inheritors at least from where
they're coming from what they're
expecting is basically this this kind of
Earth where like it's fire and brimstone
and they've conquered everything and all
that kind of stuff but when they get out
there what they find is that it actually
looks kind of like a Utopia like a
technological Utopia uh and it's kind of
a crazy thing because of course with
Kane the Scarlet Spider he doesn't
really need to hide himself per se
because he's got a suit that basically
makes him invisible but for Jessica Drew
and Ben Reilly if they go swinging
through what is supposed to be the
Homeworld of the inheritors the race of
beings that are trying to kill them
they'll do nothing but draw attention to
themselves right and so right off the
bat they're like okay we need to
basically hide and so of course they end
up donning some smocks from hospitals
right so basically Hospital Garb with
their their back ends hanging out which
is always the most embarrassing thing
ever but as they get in there you end up
finding out that this world is basically
ruled by genics now genix is a member of
the inherited race but it's more of like
the scientific member of the inherited
race right like their main Science Guy
the other thing that's also discovered
here is that while they're making their
way through this building they end up
seeing all these individuals who are
essentially clones and they're really in
like a very docile state with Gen X on a
screen talking about how you are elegant
you're a part of a big complex system
different things along those lines we're
not really given a lot of information in
so far as how this world functions at
least at the moment instead they end up
drawing the attention of one of the
science guys who's actually this
reality's version of Max Modell the guy
who leads Horizon labs in the main
Marvel Universe and is actually a kind
of well I wouldn't say father figure but
very much a mentor for Peter Parker they
end up getting his attention and then in
turn everything starts to pop off right
they basically web this guy up their
cover's blown and they take off now at
that point because of the fact that they
were basically encountering like you
know security and all that kind of stuff
they have to redone their suits and The
Jig Is up right like everybody knows
that like Spider-Man are here now then
that of course leads to the arrival of
Iron Man which is a crazy thing to see
that in this universe Iron Man exists
and it's one of the things that's very
easy to forget when it comes to the
inheritors They Don't Really they have
no desire to kill like Iron Man or like
Captain America or any of those guys
they track spider characters now if in
some alternate reality The Avengers get
in the way of the inheritors trying to
kill that version of Spider-Man Spider
Woman spider girl whoever they'll Kill
The Avengers right they'll kill whoever
they need to in order to get to their
target and again that ties into the
benefit of hone bodies that if that
inheritor were killed their clone would
come back with the knowledge of how it
was they died and some means to overcome
those forces and try again the response
of Iron Man is basically one of
immediately attacking them now of course
they get the upper hand on him they're
able to subdue him and then in turn it
becomes a big interrogation of what Iron
Man knows how this world works but he's
not really dumping a whole lot of
information all he really says is that
in this reality genix basically runs the
world and that genix operates out of the
Baxter building which as most of you
guys know is traditionally the home of
the Fantastic Four the other thing about
this and what's kind of crazy is the
question is to ask like Tony Stark how
did you get like this and while we're
not really given a definitive answer the
explanation that's offered here is that
most likely what happened is Tony Stark
in this universe was probably killed and
this is a clone of that version of Tony
Stark that in fact most every citizen on
this planet is likely a clone designed
to be docile designed to never resist
the the control of genix himself that
genix isn't really viewed as like a God
among these people but is certainly
viewed as a person whose authority is
beyond contestation and so this again
basically leads to the clones heading
towards the Baxter building now this
actually leads to a pretty genius
maneuver where you actually have them
strip Tony Stark of his armor and then
Ben Reilly donned the armor himself and
then pretends to lead them in as what
are basically prisoners it's a pretty
smart maneuver right it's a very
intelligent thing to do because when
that happens basically Jessica Drew
breaks free and it's like oh my God
she's free somebody stop her right and
then like while Security's dealing with
her you have Ben Reilly in the Iron Man
suit basically taking Kane and then
leading him to quote unquote the prison
cells which allows Jessica Drew to
basically do her thing and buy them as
much time as they possibly can the
problem here is that while you would
expect Ben Riley in his Iron Man suit
and Kane to be able to sort of move
through the building almost at their
Leisure so long as it's being treated
like a uh like Iron Man escorting a
prisoner and investigate the place learn
more about the planet where they're at
where the Clone Factory is that's
creating these inheritor clones so they
can destroy it all that kind of stuff
they're suddenly met by the arrival of
Johnny Storm the Human Torch who is
quite lightly in this universe one of
the most powerful beings on the planet I
would even argue Johnny's storm is
probably one of the most powerful beings
across the Marvel Multiverse right that
guy he's just super powerful like Johnny
Storm and any universe is ridiculously
op
what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are back with Amazing Spider-Man yes we
are and this one's cool because we
basically get to see superior Spider-Man
versus like Spider-Man it's like
Spider-Man versus Spider-Man it's cool
man right so in the last video we
basically had this instance where
superior Spider-Man Doctor Octopus had
basically stepped up and said he was the
one that was gonna run the show because
at the end of the day when it came down
to it the inheritors being killed was
the only way to really stop them and
that he really viewed Peter Parker in a
lot of ways as a half measure that he's
not really willing to go to the Limit
and do what it takes to stop a force
that will do everything they can to kill
him and that's the the real
philosophical difference between the two
and it's one of the cool things right
we've talked about that before that when
you have Heroes like Spider-Man vs
superior Spider-Man the big dichotomy
between the two is that superior
Spider-Man will not kill on a whim right
it's not as though superior Spider-Man
is going to kill a bank robber that's
not really what we're talking about
we're not going with that level of an
extreme the response of superior
Spider-Man here is that the inheritors
will do everything thing they can to
kill us that's literally what they do
they don't want to take us prisoner and
use us as like a source of slave labor
no they want to like consume our life
force which will leave us dead the only
way to stop them is to find a way to
kill them and the response of Peter
Parker is no we have to be better than
that now if we were talking about Dr
Octopus saying that he wanted to kill
like Electro whose schemes and
mechanations to a degree may result in a
loss of life but more than anything
there is usually just a kind of General
menace to Spider-Man you can make a
credible argument there that I probably
wouldn't follow but you can make an
incredible argument that like those guys
shouldn't be killed but against a force
that will continually do everything it
can to destroy you the only way to
defeat it is to kill it and that's the
big difference between those individuals
that have what it takes to actually
succeed and those who don't right those
who are half measures and Peter Parker
is a half measure here now of course
this leads to a fight breaking out
between the two and it's kind of a funny
thing because what happens over the
course of this conflict is that Dr
Octopus keeps making references to Peter
Parker as his past self and that's when
Peter comes to the realization Dr
Octopus doesn't know that Peter gets his
body back he doesn't know that Dr
Octopus loses possession of the body of
Peter Parker he doesn't know that Peter
that this version of Peter Parker is
actually from his future as opposed to
his past and to a degree Peter actually
starts to use that to his advantage that
if superior Spider-Man knew that this is
Peter from his future he would probably
kill him to be honest with you guys like
he would probably have destroyed him at
this point in his story it's kind of
hard to tell because in the progression
of superior Spider-Man up to this point
he had moved away from being your
stereotypical Dr Octopus villain and
basically became a hero that happened in
a lot of different ways from a lot of
different things right Anna Maria
Marconi is a really good example of that
the character that kind of provided a
softer Edge to Dr Octopus although I
would argue it took away his
ruthlessness as well as basically
learning that Peter Parker was pulling
his punches right if you guys recall
when superior Spider-Man got into a
fight with a scorpion and literally
punched his jaw off of his face and then
realized that Peter Parker could have
beat them all to death at any point in
time and just simply chose not to like
that kind of a thing right so kind of
learning really the tried and true
lesson that was being taught to Peter by
Uncle Ben that with great power must
come great responsibility and basically
becoming a good guy but in this instance
Peter Parker represents an existential
threat to the continued existence of
superior Spider-Man and even if for no
other reason than like self-preservation
I could see him killing Peter or at
least interrogating him and trying to
find out how it is that Peter got his
body back and then trying to prevent
that from happening and then probably
killing Peter at the same time so
regardless it's a pretty interesting
circumstance it's a pretty cool thing
now ultimately of course as you would
expect because you know Peter Parker is
the star of the show Peter Parker
overcomes Dr Octopus he's able to able
to overpower him now Dan slot doesn't
make this some kind of throwaway thing
where he was where he's like you know
I'm Peter Parker and I'm I'm powered by
hope and goodness and so I win the way
Peter Parker overcome superior
Spider-Man is he actually just stops and
gives up and the reason why is because
if Dr Octopus genuinely believes that
Peter is his past self and if Peter
Parker were to die then how would Dr
Octopus come into existence he would
literally destroy himself right he would
end his reign as superior Spider-Man by
basically killing his younger self now
Dan slots being a little fast and loose
with this because one of the things that
Marvel has routinely established over
the years is that if you make a change
to the timeline all it's really gonna do
is just create a branch timeline and so
all that would really happen here at
least if we give our go with our general
knowledge of Marvel Comics if superior
Spider-Man killed Peter Parker then it
would just lead to an alternate reality
where he never became superior
Spider-Man and Peter Parker had died in
an earlier date most likely they would
just never manifest they would just
never be there right you would never see
them because both of them would Cease to
Exist by nature of the circumstance and
so literally you would just have
superior Spider-Man standing over the
body of Peter Parker and that would
basically be it but for the sake of the
story it's basically crafted in such a
way where dance slots like okay uh yeah
superior Spider-Man is not going to kill
his younger self Because he believes in
paradoxes and so because of that it
gives Peter the upper hand where he
basically takes out Dr Octopus now
following that we switch over to Earth
13989 this reality is not overly
significant but it does deal with Khan
now remember for those of you guys who
are unfamiliar with our discussion about
Moreland about the inheritors different
things like that the nature of Karn and
the reason why he wears this helmet is
that prior to the master Weaver that
currently exists to basically allow the
inheritors to travel throughout the
Multiverse there was a previous version
of this guy and that Karn and the
inheritors had basically tracked this
guy down and intended to kill him and
then basically replace him with an
inheritor of their own that would
essentially give them free reign across
the Multiverse to track down Spider-Man
wherever they could find them and so
during that initial scrum with the
original Master Weaver it was revealed
that unlike the other inheritors that
enjoy the idea of like killing spider
totems and virtually any animal totem
but spider totems in particular Khan
didn't that he was actually a break away
from his family he didn't like what it
was that they did and he actually
condemned it but he kept that to himself
because he knew if he came out publicly
his family would probably kill him or
they would shut him or something along
those lines and so once this became
general knowledge once the original
Master Weaver revealed this to the rest
of the inheritors basically a helmet was
thrown on the head of Karn and he's
almost playing the role of Sisyphus
right like constantly pushing the
boulder up and then once it gets near
the top it comes back down again that
his job is to literally travel the
Multiverse and just attack as many
Spider-Man as he possibly can and kill
as many spider totems as he possibly can
but the reality here is that because
he's considered such a shameful being
among the inheritors that his father
will probably never bring him back that
this will be a fate that he will just be
left to endure forever to try to gain
his father's respect and just constantly
keep along that path of course that will
change but the results of this is that
with everything happening of course more
lung coming back and so on that the
father of the inheritors who we haven't
really seen much of before actually
addresses the idea of Moreland refusing
to go to Earth 616 because he's been
killed there twice by Peter Parker and
that's where the father of the
inheritors is like okay like you know
it's time to stop being nice right it's
time to stop like playing with these
guys and kind of doing this cat and
mouse game and all that kind of stuff we
know where they are we know they're in
their safe Universe let's just go and
get them right let's just go and attack
them which really kind of begs the
question what circumstance would it be
that it would just that he would
literally break into a universe or show
up in a universe where one of those
Spider-Man has the power of like the
Enigma Force right where he's basically
a cosmic God how powerful could this guy
really be or how foolish could they
really be right it's only every one of
the other but the result of this is that
Peter actually extends an olive branch
to Superior Spider-Man kind of jumping
back to those two again and the result
is just seemingly out of respect or what
have you superior Spider-Man and Peter
actually start working together and
despite the fact that they recognize
that they're in a universe where this
version of Spider-Man never lost the
Enigma Force and is absurdly powerful
the most powerful of them all at the end
of the day it's still a foolish idea to
keep them all confined to a singular
location because if something were to
happen and this guy were to be destroyed
by just some crazy circumstance who
really knows then suddenly they would
basically be left defenseless more so
than that if the inheritors decided to
just launch an attack which they would
most likely do and we know they are
doing especially because of the fact
that they have clones meaning they can
always find a way to come back it's only
a matter of time before they Whittle
their forces down because where the
inheritors can come back by way of
clones once any one of these Spider-Man
are dead they're dead there's no coming
back and there's no way to replenish
your number so the smart move here by
Peter Parker is to say we need to
basically go to different locations we
need to ensure we can maintain
communication across the Multiverse but
we need to be in different places we
can't all operate out of One Singular
safe house and basically cross our
fingers hoping it works for the best the
other thing about this is that where he
had basically used the cloaking
technology of a superior Spider-Man the
question he has for Doc Oculus is there
a way to reverse engineer this so it can
actually detect inheritors so we can
basically see them coming before they
get here right so if a universe is a
house they don't have to wait for the
inheritors to like Smash down the door
before they know they're there they can
actually see the inheritors coming as
they get onto the street right like once
they turn onto the block then it's like
oh my God the inheritors are coming and
so again it's one of those things where
doc Ox like I'm way ahead of you like I
already did that and in fact I know
where their home world is the problem is
we can't go there because if we did they
would probably eradicate us they would
destroy us and so the result of this is
Peter actually concocts a plan he's like
okay so one we don't have every single
Spider-Man from across the Multiverse
and two the inheritors because they're
still tracking them they know where
these guys are so we basically have to
race them there right we have to to grab
more Spider-Man so what he actually does
here is he tasks Miles Morales in
Spider-Man from the Ultimate Spider-Man
cartoon show yes
Ultimate Spider-Man cartoon show like
he's in this comic which is amazing uh
he actually tasked them with going out
into the Multiverse and finding as many
Spider-Man as they possibly can now that
story continues on in spider verse team
up and it's an amazing story uh
technically it kind of begins here and
we can kind of go into this a little bit
basically they end up on Earth 67 uh
which is cool you guys will you guys
will recognize this one here in a second
but they basically show up on Earth 67
they're kind of making making their way
around they realize they're in the 60s
there's like one building that says
Daily Bugle there's like only one
building with a sign on it and so
they're like okay well I mean I wonder
where Peter Parker's gonna be you know
and we basically find out they're in
like the 1960s Spider-Man cartoon
Universe which is awesome because that
version of Spider-Man is amazing I loved
him in spider-verse he was so awesome
but then you kind of switch back to
Earth 13. right now showing up here this
is basically the inheritors making their
move now the ones who show up are
basically Solace Morlan and genix of
course more Lund we've talked about
extensively Gen X we've covered already
is basically like the scientific AI of
the inheritors Solace we have not
covered he's simply just the father of
the inheritors now this is one of the
more disappointing things I'm going to
nip this in the bud right off the bat we
never get a true definitive origin of
the inheritors in this story and that
was that's what was kind of
disappointing about it it's like they're
just there and I remember reading
through the entirety of like
spider-verse and I was like like as it
was coming out and I was like when do we
get like a One-Shot origin of the
inheritors right like dance slot writing
Once Upon a Time on Earth one there was
a guy who was a dick and he was really
hungry and he ate Spider-Man and then he
realized he tasted good and then started
doing it across the Multiverse you know
something along those lines you know
just some kind of like One-Shot origin
for his character but we never really
get a One-Shot origin for the inheritors
themselves the closest we get is when
they killed the original Master Weaver
but Saul is showing up here is one of
those things where seemingly if it was
like Jinx who just stumbled into this
universe not realizing that it was
guarded by like Cosmic Spider-Man or if
it was like more Lun who had done it or
something like that they probably would
have retreated they there is a chance
they would have attacked this Cosmic
Spider-Man and their their body probably
would have been destroyed but in the end
like Solace is fearless he basically
sends in more lawn and genics and is
like kill as many as you possibly can if
you die it's fine we'll resurrect you
not a great bq's deal right we'll
literally bring you back with a clone as
far as is like Cosmic Spider-Man goes he
basically ends up like showing up like
he literally just like establishes this
power right just kind of like goes
against Solace tries to attack him and
saw us withstands the full brunt of his
attack like literally withstands the
power of the Enigma Force now this was
Dan slot again kind of playing it fast
and loose if we're being honest with
ourselves the purpose of the Enigma
Force while its power has waxed and
waned over the years it allows an
individual to wield enough power to
where they can affect the fundamental
probabilities and forces of the universe
itself it makes a person absurdly
powerful if you were to use the peak
capabilities of the Enigma Force you'd
be one of the most powerful beings in
the universe we're not told if that
that's really what this version of
Spider-Man is capable of again this
version of Spider-Man is based off of
the acts of Vengeance storyline where
Peter Parker gained the Enigma Force and
this is basically a continuation of that
story in an alternate reality where
Peter never lost the Enigma Force the
only thing we saw Peter do with that
level of power he parked The Incredible
Hulk out of the earth and that's it we
didn't see him fight Galactus or
anything along those lines different
people have wielded the Enigma Force in
different ways but this version of Peter
seems to be a continuation of the one
from acts of Vengeance and so while he
does have the Enigma Force and while he
is very powerful it's not really scale
here right I mean it's literally like
taking a fish and just dropping it in
the ocean and then taking a picture I
mean how big is that fish if there's
nothing there for scale that fish could
be 50 feet long that fish could be five
inches long there's no way to know
because the ocean has no scale and so
because of that it's kind of difficult
to basically you know ask this question
how powerful is solace really when it
comes to what it is that he's capable of
doing because we don't really have a way
to kind of compare these guys the
important thing though is that whatever
power cosmic Spider-Man has is
irrelevant Solace overpowers the sky
almost in an instant like literally he
goes to attack him and the response to
Solace is sure man you have the Enigma
Force it's the Primal force of creation
that's cool in everything man but like
we literally Feast on Life Force so you
are just like a giant buffet and so he
just absorbs the entirety of the Enigma
Force into himself basically absorbs the
uh the life essence of this version of
Spider-Man in any hope these guys had
for safety is basically gone like at
that point it's panic mode like people
are just like what do we do man it's
just like I don't know man just run Flee
for your lives you know it's just it's
crazy right now at that point you end up
of course picking up with Mayday Parker
who of course had her younger brother
essentially Moreland finally gets his
hands on it and again we find out that
Benji is the Scion that they've been
looking for now again we'll cover that
later you know as we as we get further
into this what I actually want to do
here is switch over to Spider-Woman now
before you guys are kind of like you
know a spider woman sucks no no here's
the thing Jessica Drew has had some
pretty bad stories over the years right
she's had some garbage stories over the
years this story in spider-verse is
really cool not only that if you ever
doubt how interesting Jessica Drew was
go read Brian Michael bendis's New
Avengers she was amazing in that story I
loved her in New Avengers especially
everything with like the hand and like
Hydra and all that kind of stuff that
was cool but the important thing here is
that again in the aftermath of
everything that had popped off on in in
the earth 2099 Universe if you guys
recall when Deimos had shown up and
attacked everybody and basically people
started splitting off that uh silk and
Jessica Drew and Spider-Man War were one
of the three that had taken off now at
that point in time Spider-Man Noir
seemed to basically be knocked out he
wasn't really like dead per se but he's
since recovered and they're essentially
on a mission to basically try to Stave
off as best they can to keep away from
the inheritors and then eventually
regroup at a future point in time what
ends up happening here along the way is
Jessica Drew gets exceedingly fed up
with silk now the reason behind this is
because Cindy moon is very Reckless it's
one of the things to know about her
character she's interesting but she's
Reckless Jessica Drew on the other hand
has a lot of experience with like
stealth Espionage she was very black
widow-esque in terms of how she how you
know what her Form and Function was in
Marvel Comics especially during the days
of Brian Michael bendis's New Avengers
so she's highly capable the problem is
that basically looking after Cindy moon
is like trying to look after drunk
college girls it's babysitting and
incredibly annoying and so because of
that she's like okay this girl is wildly
irresponsible she's literally doing
everything she can to keep their profile
low they end up breaking out into a
fight right like Cindy Moon basically
attacks these guys who were like trying
to shake down some old woman trying to
rob him so like now you got Jessica Drew
he's got to go in there and try to Stave
that off but their continued action the
fact that they've been making moves
Making Waves the fact that Cindy moon is
just an easily trackable person leads to
the inheritors tracking them down now of
course this is the brother and sister
they literally show up here like Team
Rocket right like blast off at the speed
of light because we're Team Rocket and
we're kind of dicks so like it's it's a
little funny
appear like that now of course this
leads to Spider-Man Noir trying to
intervene and that's one of the funny
things is because in the the last I
guess the first half of this video there
was a point where Peter Parker had hit
up like Jessica Drew and and Cindy moon
to see how things were going and they
were like Spider-Man noir's down right
this is that moment and this is one of
the things that I do want to explain
about the nature of spider-verse is that
because they did have like a bunch of
tie-in comics that like this comic is
technically after at least in terms of
reading orders after the one that we
just covered but it actually takes place
at the same time with Cindy Moon again
that's why her and Jessica Drew and uh
in in Spider-Man Noir are basically
constantly moving because as one of the
more significant members of the spider
totem she's easily trackable right it's
basically her just kind of leaving a
scent behind it's like you walking
around with a a bottle of cologne or
perfume and just kind of spraying it as
you walk and leaving a trail for someone
to follow that's essentially what's
happening here like Cindy Moon's got
body odor but the the important thing
here is they basically end up
teleporting away and they actually jump
back to the universe of Earth 9214
that's the home Universe of Spider-Man
Noir which is a huge gamble to take and
the reason why is because while the
inheritors have already been to this
universe and of course Spider-Man Wars
not there anymore the risk comes in the
form of the fact that because the
inheritors have been there they probably
wouldn't come back but because they have
been here they understand and they know
about this universe so it may be one of
those things where they're like I mean
they took off what if they went back to
their own universes let's just double
check right and then they end up
arriving in this universe only to turn
around and find uh you know Spider-Man y
now of course again because of the
nature of Cindy Moon their location is
pretty much tracked it's almost
guaranteed but in the middle of that
there's a great big huge kind of
explosion that takes place which leads
them to take off and find out what's
going on only for them to realize that
it's Spider-Man it's Anya and it's
spider-gwen now the reason why they're
here and this was part of the secondary
plan that Peter Parker had when he was
talking to Superior Spider-Man about
reverse engineering the cloaking devices
to find the locations of the inheritors
is that yes they were we're not in a
position to travel to the inheritor
Homeworld but they could possibly get
someone in there who could basically
operate Behind Enemy Lines that could
essentially sneak around and in Peter
Parker's mindset the best person for
that is Jessica Drew because of her
history as a spy and so due to that he
basically teleports here with spider
Gwen and Anya essentially pulling out
Jessica Drew and then replacing her with
Anya and spider-gwen who are basically
going to keep an eye on Cindy Moon the
problem with this is that if one of the
world's best spies and a new Avenger had
a hard time keeping Cindy moon in check
what chance do you like Anya and
spider-gwen have I mean they're cool and
everything but they're nowhere near on
the same level as Jessica Drew but at
the end of the day literally Peter
Parker's is doing the best he can with
what he has hence the reason why they
want to grab more Spider-Man from across
the Multiverse because there are other
more capable Spider-Man out there and so
during this whole thing you basically
have this instance where Jessica Drew
actually pulls spider Gwen and Anya
aside and says look Cindy Moon's cool
her heart's in the right Place she's a
really really nice girl and if we
weren't being chased around the
Multiverse by some guys that wanted to
kill us and siphon off our life energies
I would say we could all go get our
nails done and talk about our feelings
but the thing here is that she'll get
you killed if you let her because she's
Reckless she doesn't really understand
the gravity of what's going on here and
even if she did she doesn't seem to care
she's too headstrong and so Cindy Moon
actually overhears all of this and so
quite literally where Anya and spider
Gwen are supposed to be keeping an eye
on Cindy Moon as Spider-Man and Jessica
Drew leave Cindy Moon's vanished she
literally took off right it's like a
toddler right you know once you once you
get into like the walking phase you got
to keep your eye on them all the time
either that or like baby proof your
house so you just kind of block off a
section of your house as you move around
so they just can't leave that general
area you know it's one of those things
where it's like that's just the nature
of Cindy moon now of course we end up
finding out Cindy moon has teleported or
moved to earth 981. now any of you guys
who are familiar with 981 one I know
you're probably even just looking
forward to this because like this fight
diverse event you're like when are we
going to get to earth 981 like what are
we gonna get to that whole story we're
getting there please for the love of God
do not spoil anything
it's an amazing segment but you
essentially have like this giant monster
that appears out of nowhere and attacks
Cindy moon or at least goes after Cindy
Moon following that you actually have
the brother and sister inheritors who
show up here with the intention of
tracking Cindy Moon down but what comes
after this is one of the greatest
moments in the entirety of spider-verse
it's awesome but we will cover that in
the next video
what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are here with what's probably the most
entertaining story from spider-verse
which is Miles Morales and Spider-Man
from the Ultimate Spider-Man cartoon
show meets Spider-Man from the 1960s
cartoon show and it's amazing I love
this story it's just so much fun right
it's just a fun story to read so as we
as we kind of mentioned the last video
right they're miles and and we're just
gonna call them Ultimate Spider-Man it's
just easier that way but miles an
Ultimate Spider-Man basically ended up
in this universe because they're
basically trying to find more Spider-Man
and this year I mean it's basically what
it was you know what you saw in the
cartoon show right where it's pretty
straightforward there's like only one
building with a sign on it and that sign
is Daily Bugle so they know like exactly
where to go to find Spider-Man but like
Jay Jonah Jameson he's hilarious in this
right so he's like pay attention Parker
he's like we've had reports of two
Spider-Mans swinging around making
spectacles themselves and Peter's like
two Spider-Man he's like do you know
what that means Parker he's like well I
don't know I mean criminals have been
personally Spider-Man before he's like
Balderdash the Webhead admit has finally
showed his true colors he's put together
a gang of crooks to terrorize the city
get me proof
Jay Jonah Jameson became Americans in
the 21st century I have a conclusion now
I need evidence to support it
and it's just like okay all right Jay
Jonah Jameson so anyway you end up
picking up with Ultimate Spider-Man and
miles of course as they're on the hunt
for for 60 Spider-Man and ultimately
they find him but as you guys if any of
you guys ever saw the 1960 Spider-Man
cartoon and if you didn't it was amazing
dude old school Spider-Man was hilarious
but this episode was actually based off
a story called to catch a spider right
which was basically Dr noabati who
essentially unleashes like Electro and
like Green Goblin in these guys to take
out Spider-Man but unlike the the
original show the original cartoon this
basically takes place in instead or at
least uh partly takes place in instead
so what goes on here and it's kind of a
funny thing is uh miles an Ultimate
Spider-Man are talking to like 60s
Spider-Man right in 60 Spiderman's like
okay you imposters can unmask and
surrender right now or I can whip you up
and we'll do it at the police station
your choice Chums now Ultimate
Spider-Man is hilarious here right
because he's like okay stay back miles I
got this man like I'm well versed in in
this kind of talk so he's like get hit
to this Daddy-o there's a heavy scene
going down and we ain't got time for a
lot of rama lama ding dong you dig and
60 Spider-Mans like the hard way it is
I'm like
he whips them up
now at that point miles comes in and
miles is like no you got the wrong idea
man he's like we're Spider-Man from a
different dimension and then like uh and
then like like literous what he says
right he's like we're Spiderman from
like other dimensions there's like like
a giant Menace that we have to deal with
and we need help and like 60
Spider-Man's like oh well why didn't you
just say so that explains everything
it was it was hilarious because at that
point in time like the the way
Spider-Man was depicted is he was just
so I don't know maybe naive or something
like that but it was it was almost kind
of adorable right it was kind of funny
plus he would complain a lot in the
1960s show he would complain all the
time I mean I guess technically it was a
1967 show but like he would complain a
lot he'd be like I'm hot in my
Spider-Man suit and swinging around is
making me even hotter and these stupid
villains are escaping now I'm gonna have
to beat him to death like he would
complain all the time but again the
whole thing ends up kind of playing out
where he's like okay cool like I'll go
with you guys to go on this gravity huge
Adventure but I needed to take up this
thing first right this guy Dr Noah body
has basically released the vulture and
Electro and Green Goblin and Scorpion
and I gotta deal with them first right
now here's a funny thing as soon as
these guys show up I mean it's designed
to look like the 60s show so like they
look Goofy and they look kind of silly
and whenever Green Goblin was riding
around on his Goblin glider in like the
60s cartoon it looked like he was
powering it by farts not even gonna lie
but the whole thing about that is of
course they're they're able to overpower
them momentarily but Mr noabati who's
basically invisible has like this ray
gun that basically incapacitates them
and then the villains do what they
always did in the show which was bigger
amongst themselves and then ultimately
get themselves caught now in that whole
thing where this this whole kind of
situation is going on like 60
Spider-Mans like the last time I beat
him I used ventriloquism but I don't
know if that'll work this time and of
course it ends up coming by way of
Ultimate Spider-Man who basically webs
up their legs and then essentially takes
out Mr Noah body which you know allows
Miles Morales to you know kind of step
up and then you know use his Venom
blasts to electrocute Mr Noah body and
take him out and all those guys are
defeated and basically the day's saved
and then you get to one what's quite
possibly one of the more questionable
moments of the comic
in which direction you're coming from
but basically once they're all together
it's almost like the old throwback to
like the 19 or to the the old Justice
League right like when they all masked
and they all learn their identities but
basically like Ultimate Spider-Man
Reveals His identity as Peter Parker and
then Miles Morales Reveals His identity
and they're like 1960 Spider-Mans like
Wallop and web Snappers I mean he
doesn't say like like he's not
it's not like he's like you're black
like it's not anything like that he's
just like surprised he's a high school
kid but like Christos Gage was kind of
going with that right kind of like you
know building up to that little bit of
comedy and ultimate Spider-Man's like oh
snap man tell me that like the 1960s
Spider-Man is an old-fashioned in all
the bad ways too you know but ultimate
and it's one of those things where Miles
was kind of expecting it right miles is
kind of like all right I'm gonna take
off this mask in front of this 1960s
white dude we're gonna see what happens
right and you know he's like Wallop and
web Snappers and I was like man don't
you say it he's like you're a high
school kid miles like awesome dude I'm
not gonna have to beat the hell out of
you
because I'll be honest man I feel like
miles would have dude miles would have
beat the tar out of this guy like say
what you would have just lost it on him
it would have been hilarious well he
would have totally lost it on him but
nonetheless the two of them basically
end up going forward and bringing in
like 1960 Spider-Man as a way to
basically combat the inheritors but yeah
okay now this is something else that I
also want to point out here um so the
way these quite team up stories were
done is they were basically a side
stories and B-side stories you
essentially get part one then you get
part two so if you guys want in the
future stories that we do or the future
videos that we do we can cover both
parts let me know if you guys want to
see both parts in a single video or if
you want to focus on like just each
individual part as its own video and let
me know what you guys are interested in
seeing but
what's going on guys this is Rob and if
any of you guys are part of the Discord
server you guys know that actually as of
about 10 minutes ago I finished
interviewing Tom Holland Zendaya and
Jacob battle on for Spider-Man no way
home and I asked them two of the
questions that you all had in the
Discord server so the video will
hopefully go up tomorrow and uh yeah
then hopefully you guys will be able to
find out which one of you got your
question answered having said that we
are picking back up again with
spider-verse now one of the things we're
doing here this actually kind of opens
up initially with Spider-Man 2099 and
again one of the things you remember is
the 2099 universe is where that great
big huge battle between demos and the
various Spiderman unfolded and so while
you did have like Peter Parker and all a
lot of those guys who all just kind of
took off to different realities and so
on Miguel O'Hara from Spider-Man 2099 he
never left right he's basically been
here the whole time along with Lady
spider and with six armed Spider-Man
who's actually from a universe and which
we'll talk about here in a second which
is a really really cool story because it
ties into a video that we've already
done and it actually kind of ties into a
character that's going to be in the MCU
so the idea behind this is that we
initially pick up with Tyler Stone now
Tyler's stone is basically one of the
high-ranking members of alchemax as
those of you guys may recall if you've
read Spider-Man 2099 if you didn't uh
the nature of alchemax is they're
basically like a mega Corporation so
think of them as like Amazon in the
future is basically what they are right
they're just a really crony company
that's just done some really shady stuff
uh but Tyler Stone his relationship with
Miguel O'Hara is a little bit
complicated and the reason why is
because really in the early days of
Spider-Man 2099 back in the mid-1990s it
was really more that that Tyler Stone
was kind of a dick and that Miguel
O'Hara wasn't really a big fan of
alcamax engaging in like human testing
with experiments and things like that
that initially kind of led him to
becoming Spider-Man in the first place
or at least having a vendetta against it
the other part of that and really the
more personal motivation here is that
Tyler's Stone seemed to basically be
responsible for getting Miguel O'Hara
addicted to a drug called Rapture and
then use the ability of alchemax Supply
that drug as a means to basically keep
Miguel on a short leash now in
Spider-Man 2099 issue number 25 you
actually learn a few things the first is
that Tyler stone is the biological
father of Miguel O'Hara and two Miguel
was never actually addicted to to
Rapture so basically he was manipulated
by Tyler Stone and that's why over the
course of Marvel's publication history
in addition to just the nefarious things
that Alco Max does while Miguel O'Hara
has always had a vendetta against
alcamax he's always had more of a
personal Vendetta against Tyler Stone
and in fact there's actually been
instances specifically with what was
going on right up until this story was
being written where Miguel O'Hara had to
actually go back in time or at least was
trapped in the past but had to
essentially ensure that Tyler Stone
lived because he was his biological
father if Tyler Stone died before he
could Father Miguel O'Hara Miguel O'Hara
would cease to exist so literally he had
to save the life of the man he hated in
order to preserve his own existence and
so one of the things that goes on here
is that with uh Tyler Stone being head
of what is a in effect the secret police
of alcamax now they're basically told
like hey like Miguel O'Hara just came
back from the past and he's here with a
few other guys now the funny thing about
this is that despite his business savvy
Tyler Stone doesn't seem to be too
intelligent when it comes to like
technology and things like that the
reason why is because when he asked the
question like he was barely gone for an
hour how did he get back so fast the
question that's given to him is time
doesn't work that way for us he's been
gone for an hour but it could very well
be that he's been stranded wherever he
was at for like months or years right
where he just took him that long to find
a way to get back here and one of the
things that's pointed out here which is
kind of interesting is we're like I'm
kind of surprised that we didn't end up
with a paradox where like he came back
before we sent him into the past and
then warned himself to to basically
ensure that we can't trick him into
going into the past and so we basically
have this kind of wonky wild situation
probably like this total breakdown of
reality and things along those lines but
you know leaving out all the crazy
zaniness of it you basically end up just
kind of picking up with the situation
where finally Miguel O'Hara makes his
presence presence known to his brother
Gabe as well as introducing six-armed
Spider-Man and Lady spider now something
that I do want to point out here is that
at first glance you may think this is
doppelganger for those of you guys who
don't know who doppelganger is and if
you recall our coverage on Infinity War
one of the things of magus the future
evil version of Adam Warlock did is he
basically created doppelgangers of
various characters out there
doppelganger or Thanos doppelganger of
the Avengers and a doppelganger of
Spider-Man due to his popularity he
basically lingered on following the
events of infinity War but it was
basically like this kind of Twisted evil
six-armed version of Peter Parker the
idea here with this version of Peter
Parker is that if you guys recall our
discussion on really the character
explanation of Michael morbius is we
actually solidified this idea that with
his initial introduction or at least
kind of going into his introduction his
first encounter with Spider-Man came by
way of Peter's attempt to cure himself
of basically being Spider-Man the result
is that it actually led to him
developing six Arms This is an alternate
reality where that was never solved
right he basically kept six arms so
again kind of an interesting little
thing there but the whole idea behind
this is that you end up having of course
Miguel basically warning Gabe and it's
like things are kind of popping off and
that we've got inheritors chasing after
us and all that kind of crazy stuff and
or they're trying to buy their time as
best they can and basically stay hidden
that again because they're spiders and
because the inheritors track spiders
Deimos is able to track them down
incredibly fast now remember the
motivation of Deimos here is twofold the
first is that of course they're spiders
so damless wants to basically kill them
consume their life energy and and leave
them the second thing is he's trying to
recover his body remember the inheritors
have cloning technology they have the
ability to basically take their
Consciousness and download it into a new
clone body every single time they're
basically killed no matter what the
circumstance is and so the the various
spiders being in possession of a body of
the inheritors means they can reverse
engineer it and they can find a way to
destroy the inheritors and actually keep
them from being able to download their
Consciousness inside of a body demos
basically goes after all of them now the
fun thing here is that lady spider is
not an actual spider character meaning
she didn't really get her powers from
like a radioactive spider bite so she's
not really tied directly into the spider
totems per se she doesn't have that
mystical connection and so where damos
can't really siphon her life energy I
mean I guess he could right but it would
be like eating a carrot when he what he
wants is a steak you know what I mean
like he just wouldn't really quite
satiate him in the way that he needs
that he actually kind of entertains this
idea of quote unquote using her for his
own ends now we'll actually find out
what that means when we pick up with
Spider Woman and the story of Jessica
Drew because not everything is what it
seems when it comes to the inheritors
that they have as much contradiction and
hypocrisy going on as they do their
belief and their righteous cause but
regardless Gabe buys him a little bit of
time when he basically blasts demos
through like a wall you know using like
this just massive gun and then the fight
basically takes out into the city now
while all that's going on Tyler wants to
grab Miguel right I mean he basically
wants to like incapacitate Spider-Man
remove him from the landscape so we
didn't have to worry about man like
stopping alchemax like your your
standard traditional like villains
fighting Heroes kind of Arc right and so
that's why you see like the the secret
police who are out here like these you
know Soldier guys and of course demos
rolls right through these I mean at this
point the existence of these guys being
here is really more of a nuisance than
anything else but it does provide a
helpful scenario for Miguel O'Hara and
the reason why is because for each one
of these guys right like the public eye
as they refer to for each one of these
guys they've got an up link directly to
Tyler Stone who runs them all and so
whatever they see and hear Tyler Stone
season hears as well and so that's why
where I wouldn't say Tyler Stone adopts
the philosophy that like the enemy of my
enemy is my friend it is one of these
things where he's like Okay so this guy
demos or whoever this guy is is a far
more credible threat in the moment here
and now and that Miguel O'Hara and I at
the very least have some kind of like
loose goal which is to see this guy
destroy now Tyler Stone doesn't really
know enough to know about anything
that's going on here and in fact his
desire to appeal Miguel O'Hara is really
rooted more in the fact that Miguel's
pissed right he's like you tricked me or
you sent me back to 2014 like ordinarily
I would beat the absolute crap out of
you and you know just as well as I do I
could right like this little cat and
mouse game we have like it really is
just a game we play but at the end of
the day like I could kill you where you
are so if you don't want me to do that
out of just sheer anger and irritation
understand that you are correct when you
surmise the situation and say I'm not
worried about you right now because I've
got more important things to worry about
but what I do need from you is to
literally activate something for me
right like he basically tells him
outcomeax floor 82 lab C you know
exactly what I mean have it ready for me
and so where Miguel O'Hara basically
leads you know uh Deimos to this
particular location once everything pops
off and in fact you know lady spider
kind of does what she can uh in the the
fight between the two that is really
more of of Miguel playing possum to a
degree right I mean not in so far that
like he fakes his own injury or death
but basically luring demos to this spot
in alchemax and then as soon Deimos gets
there he immediately goes to attack
Miguel O'Hara and then just gets
electrocuted and the reason why is
because Miguel has him trapped in what's
basically a stasis cell now here's an
important thing to grasp here and this
is one of the reasons why I always kind
of felt like Miguel O'Hara in a lot of
ways was a more capable version of
Spider-Man of Peter Parker it's not
necessarily that he's better but the
technology of the time of course is more
advanced than it is in the main Marvel
Universe but Peter Parker was always
more of like a comedic character and so
it would usually break down to him just
kind of pissing off the villain and then
letting the villain basically like
defeat themselves by way of their
carelessness because they let their
anger get the better of them Miguel was
a lot more methodical and I would say
even to a degree he was a lot darker
than Peter Parker was but I think there
was more methodology that went into
Miguel O'Hara being Spider-Man than it
did with Peter Parker being Spider-Man
and that's one of the reasons why Miguel
O'Hara when he first popped up really
did develop his own fan base like people
loved Miguel O'Hara back in the day
because he was just so starkly different
from what you normally saw but
regardless
what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are back with spider-verse now we
basically pick up here with uh with Kane
of course the really you could call him
like the evil or darker clone of Peter
Parker as well as Ben Reilly who's
dressed up as Iron Man after Tony Stark
Was Defeated and then Johnny Storm of
the Fantastic Four who basically serves
as the head of security for Genex right
of course Gen X basically being the
inheritor that occupies this world where
all the various clones are created and
so what you get here is this initial
realization by Johnny stormware
initially it seemed as though like he
realized they were Intruders but instead
he doesn't know Iron Man's not Iron Man
now a lot of this seems to kind of go
directly into the nature of Iron Man
himself in terms of how he speaks and
it's one of those things that's been
interpreted differently over the years
by Marvel Comics right like you go and
you read the Old Roy Thomas stuff and
the way that Iron Man spoke was very
robotic well you couldn't really
differentiate between anybody's voice
whether it was Tony Stark or James Rose
or anyone because it was almost a kind
of distortion in terms of how the suit
communicated or how the voice
communicated through the suit you go
into more recent years and it's a pretty
purified version of Tony Stark's voice
so you could obviously tell if it was
somebody else and not him and this one
kind of seems to indicate that this suit
as it communicates is very much similar
to the old school you know Iron Man
suits uh where basically it was kind of
like a distorted robotic voice but
regardless Johnny Storm does not pick up
on the fact that this is not uh Tony
Stark instead it's kind of like okay
like I don't understand like like why
why would Jinx have somebody brought
here when he wasn't supposed to be here
and so over time the response of of Ben
Reilly is if genix wanted you out of the
loop you'll have to take it up with him
right I don't know what's what what his
decisions are I don't know why he does
the kind of things he does but at the
end of the day like my job is to bring
this Spider-Man you know to to the cells
you know to take him in and that's
basically it but one of the things that
seems to seems to happen here is there's
very close communication between the
various members of the security team if
we can call it that and so Johnny Storm
picks up right off the bat okay
something like this never would have
happened under or any normal
circumstance this doesn't add up
something's going on here and so
ultimately Kane a little hot-headed as
he is you know Ben Reilly not really
able to talk them out of it just
immediately attacks Johnny Storm and of
course this also leads to Iron Man or
Ben Reilly punching uh Johnny Storm as
hard as he possibly can which
temporarily knocks him out right it kind
of allows them to go forward and do
their thing but the problem is their
cover's blown right The Jig Is up guards
are coming in from every direction and
it's like okay like this is it right
there's there's no way for us to do this
oh we just gotta go do our own thing so
the plans basically shot which is kind
of what you would expect from the Clones
to be honest with you guys there's never
really been an instance when like Ben
Riley or Kane and have like engaged in a
plan and it's gone the way that it's
supposed to
always end up going sideways with the
various schemes they have and so all you
know the only real assistance the only
real Aid they have comes from Jessica
Drew who's basically using one of the
security monitors of the various guards
right so she's like I don't know where
you guys are because they don't know
where they are so they I don't know
where you are like if if they don't know
where you are I don't know because I'm
basically listening in on their various
broadcasts and so on she's like but what
you're looking for is basically the
colony facility right the main lab
facility and she says the central shaft
of the building is tiered lab space and
draws the majority of the power that'd
be my first guess that's where you
should start now of course tiered lab
space basically means that like there's
level one level two level three and it
seems as though the security clearance
to get from one level to the to the next
just kind of increases depending on you
know what all is going on in these these
various things and so of course they end
up basically coming across Max Modell
now again one of the things that we
talked about in the previous videos is
that Max Modell in the main Marvel
Universe was very much a mentor for
Peter Parker and was the head of horizon
labs in this universe where basically
Gen X seems to have conquered everything
that he's really nothing more than just
kind of a science guy right that genix's
intelligence when it comes to Science
and Technology and so on seems so far
beyond everybody here that they could
only ever really hope to keep up now a
lot of this also seems to be subjugation
that they're just not as capable as
genix's and that the fact that Gen X was
able to basically conquer this whole
world and maintain control over this
world even if him conquering it came by
way of help from the other inheritors
seems to indicate he's Far and Away
Beyond virtually anybody who could
actually stop him and it makes sense
right in the various times where we've
seen the inheritors face off against
like The Avengers or something like that
they Crush those guys pretty well which
was cool but also kind of disappointing
at the same time because Marvel never
really bothered to explain these guys in
relation to anybody else right so like
how strong is an inheritor in relation
to like the Incredible Hulk or something
like that the only thing you really get
is like when Peter Parker's punched by
Moreland for the first time and he's
like it's like getting hit harder by the
Hulk but like I would love to have seen
Marvel do more with the inheritors by
having them face off against more
individuals in the Marvel Comics
Community because they seemed incredibly
powerful but Michigan wants aside with
everything popping off here you end up
having miles worn who basically
approaches genix to kind of give him the
news of what's happening now this is a
very very telling exchange between the
two and while it's not really something
that we get like directly on the nose
like we're not really walked through it
like here's everything that happened we
can largely infer what took place on
this world so Miles Warren as most of
you guys know or at least some of you
guys may know from the main Marvel
universe is the one responsible for
basically creating Spider-Man clones
right so he's the one that created Ben
Riley he's the one that created uh Kane
he's the one that really kind of jump
started that initial clone saga event
back in the 1990s I mean technically
there was a clone saga before that but
the one in the 90s is the one everybody
thinks of when they think of that
storyline but in effect in Marvel Comics
when it comes to the expertise of
cloning that's the Jackal right that's
usually Miles Warren who you think of
there and so it stand to reason in this
universe he played very much the same
role and in fact Genex really seems to
hit at that that he kind of asked him do
you know why it is that I keep you
around and the answer he gives is I keep
you around because you were once the
most brilliant mind on the planet and so
what this seems to indicate is that if
that really is the case then read
Richards of the Fantastic Four maybe
Tony Stark in terms of his traditional
intelligence just wasn't really there
but regardless this world was very
similar to the main Marvel Universe most
likely in a lot of different ways
whether the clone saga took place or not
we don't really know but Miles Warren
seems to have been every bit as capable
in creating clones in this universe as
he was in the main Marvel Universe and
so what most likely have happened here
is that as the inheritors who are
expanding throughout the Multiverse and
as there were very little instances
where they could be overcome by members
of the superhero Community especially
given how powerful they became over time
as they essentially absorbed the life
energies of different Spider-Man and
different spider women then of course
they would likely create their own
Empires their own little worlds kind of
universes they could rule to a degree
and so the result of this is that genix
probably showed up on this world
encountered Miles Warren realized that
Miles Warren was that intelligent when
it came to cloning technology and he
probably killed the original Miles
Warren and then cloned him and so that's
really kind of how this works that Miles
Warren doesn't really seem to be that
different from the various clones that
exist out there where he's basically
just a brainwashed clone he doesn't
really know his own history and this
really seems to be confirmed by this
exchange when miles answers a really
response to the statement of of Gen X
saying you were once one of the most
Brilliant Minds of the planet when he
says I don't think so sir I I think I'd
remember some of that and the response
to Genex is well there's some times that
you do and those days are the best days
right so occasionally it looks like
Miles Warren recalls his own history
most likely what happens when that takes
place is Gen X kills and replaces him
with a with a new brainwashed clone and
that clone is totally unaware of what
his role is or any of his history or
anything like that and when he begins to
basically realize what his own history
is Genex kills and replaces and so on
and so forth and just kind of keeps that
pattern going the other part of this is
that genix kind of adopts this mentality
of like if you want something done you
got to do it yourself and even kind of
makes a statement like let them go do
their own thing like let them run
through there I'm not too concerned
about it because they'll end up getting
to the special project swing and when
that happens then I'll talk to them
personally and so that's where you end
up picking up with like Black Widow and
Kane and all these people who were
actually in the main cloning facility
itself and the initial response is let's
blow it up right let's just destroy the
whole thing right just just obliterate
the entire cloning facility the problem
with this is that there's a lot of
innocent people in there and so again
the various spider teams adopting the
philosophy the needs of the few outweigh
the needs of the mini they basically
decide to spare the lives of innocent
people and try to find some other way to
destroy this whole facility now of
course it doesn't really seem to go off
or it doesn't seem to work as well as it
seemed because in the middle of all this
Max Modell basically starts making this
kind of of you know these references to
the fact that he's not the one who's
actually running the facility instead
he's just a technician that his job is
to basically identify any possible
mutations in the code of basically these
clones and that's when it's kind of like
wait a minute there's something more
going on here right and that's when he
leads them to the special project and
what we end up finding out here is that
one of the things that genix had been
working on is that while the inheritors
travel throughout the Multiverse killing
various Spiderman and spider women what
if they didn't have to right what if
their ability to absorb the sustenance
they need was something like Star Trek
right where they literally just kind of
summon these things seemingly out of
like a computer generated system right
that essentially trying to clone
Spider-Man and Spider women so they can
just feed on them now the funny thing
about this is it would actually be a
great thing if they did I mean sure it
would suck that like they would create
these clones that would just turn around
and feed on them but assuming they
weren't really sentient like they didn't
really have any memories or anything
like that they didn't know what they
were that they were basically these
things that were just unconscious had
they weren't really alive per se then I
guess maybe it wouldn't necessarily be a
be a terrible thing I mean I don't know
at that point you start getting into all
kinds of different philosophical and
moral arguments but the important thing
here is that this would prevent the
inheritors keep the inheritors from
actually having to travel around the
Multiverse and kill all kinds of
different Spider-Man and Spider-Woman
the question that I would post to you is
do you consider these things to be
morally equal if genics were to
successfully create clones of Spider-Man
and spider-women they were able to tap
into the essence of what it meant to be
a spider totem and then feed on those
clones while they were unconscious or
they didn't really have any sentient so
like they didn't have an identity they
didn't have like a family or a life or
anything like that is that morally the
same or different as the inheritors
showing up in some alternate reality
where some version of Peter's been
Spider-Man for you know five years of
his life and he's got a girlfriend and
he goes to school and he's got life and
all that kind of stuff and they kill him
and consume his life energy is it
morally the same thing but the thing
about this is that genix has not been
able to successfully duplicate what it
is that allows the Spider-Man and
Spider-Woman to tap into the totemic
essence of being a Spider-Man and
Spider-Woman in effect he can create the
bodies he can't create the energy he
needs for the inheritors to siphon to
maintain their own existence and so
basically they're just empty husks and
they've just kind of been left here and
that's really what he tells everybody
right when Kane starts freaking out and
he starts getting angry that's exactly
what genix says that the entire process
of traveling around the Multiverse and
consuming clones is kind of exhausting
more so than that like they have to deal
with the psychological effects of dying
and coming back we know that for more
luck right more lunch showed up in the
main Marvel Universe he was killed by
Peter Parker twice it has a
psychological effect on the inheritors
and what I wouldn't say that's enough
for me to like feel bad for them it can
certainly screw with their and possibly
even make them more dangerous than they
are right now if they're just you know
psychotic right if they're mentally
unstable and so because of that he was
just trying to create clones and it all
basically failed and so because of that
one he kills Max Modell because he's
just like done right I mean like another
disappointment right like this is not
something we need to deal with and then
finally he confronts the two of them and
says the two of you are here you guys
are basically clones you are the end
result of what it is that I've been
trying to achieve whether the Jackal in
your Universe knew it or not he had
cloned Peter Parker and at the same time
found a way to duplicate the essence of
what it means to be a spider totem I
could Feast on you right now and take
your life energy and sustain myself but
what I want is more of you so the
intention is to defeat them and then
start breaking them down right just
going through and experimenting on them
dissecting them to find a way to create
more of Kane and Ben Reilly
what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are picking back up again with
Spider-Man uh well really with spider
verse more than Spider-Man but we're
picking back up here with Spider Woman
and then uh well things get a little
crazy here in a little while but as you
guys know if you guys recall the last
video that we did that basically Jessica
Drew kind of went on this Mission at the
request of Peter Parker to basically
travel to loom world right the Homeworld
of the inheritors to figure out some way
to defeat them specifically to try to
find a way to either end or discover how
their coding process works or to just
straight up find a way to defeat them
and so the result of this is that when
she gets here one of the things she
realizes is that with this basically
being their home World their base of
operations that is very much a
hodgepodge right that they've basically
kind of filled this Earth with things
that they've conquered and that's why
you see a combination of what looks like
old technology so old ships with sales
combined with flying cars things like
that because they really seem to have
built it as kind of a monument to their
ability to conquer different realities
now a lot of this also may just be based
on passing interest right thing things
we're just kind of curious about that
they hadn't really experienced before
right so like you bringing home some
kind of a trinket from a trip to Japan
or to China or something along those
lines kind of a Keepsake something to
remind yourself of the time that you had
the fact that you were there and so on
and so forth and so what ends up
happening is that Jessica Drew as soon
as she's here where she expects to
function in a capacity akin to a spy
where she basically keeps herself
disguised she operates under the radar
as soon as she's discovered people start
celebrating her right they start running
up on her like hey look at this look at
what I got you look at this thing that I
did for you you know I found your your
perfect color right look at these furs
and so on and so forth she's very much
viewed as kind of a celebrity among the
people who are here now this can work
for and against her it can work for her
because of the fact that she doesn't
really have to like skulk in the shadows
or anything like that it can work
against her because we'll kind of find
out a problem with this here in a little
bit but in the midst of all that she's
basically set upon by this guy with like
tentacles for hands or something like
that and it's basically whisked away
only for us to find out that she was
basically brought here by this weird
tentacle monster looking thing which is
actually a kind of a mutated Atlantean
but she was brought here at the behest
of Neymar the Submariner now here's a
funny thing Neymar was never actually
named in this part of the story he's
we're not explicitly told he was Namor
and in all honesty it wasn't until Dan
slot was answering fan questions on
Twitter that he was like yeah that's the
name of the sub-hander so we didn't
really know when this story initially
came out that that was the case but the
thing about this is that Jessica has
been brought here because it's part of
her role seemingly in this world that
she lives in to basically pick over the
various discoveries and findings of name
of the Submariner and his crew but her
job is to basically pick over all that
stuff kind of get her own choice and
then everything else goes to them right
so they basically get whatever's left
over when it's all said and done now
while that's happening and she's on this
ship we pick up with the real Jessica
Drew and the real Jessica Drew is a
prick this this woman is absolutely
horrible right like there's this little
kid and like his mom was working on this
little thing for him and he was really
excited about it and he almost missed
seeing Jessica Drew he takes a tour in
like shows it to her and as she looks
over this thing like this kid goes to
grab her and because she feels disgusted
by the fact that this kid touched her
she basically slaps him and the thing
away and even goes as far as saying like
when this kid says like you know I know
I shouldn't have touched you but my mom
has spent all this time working on this
for you and I was afraid that you
wouldn't get it when he gets slapped
away she was like I don't even know why
I bothered bringing guards if everybody
on the Street's just gonna be able to
cop a feel on me right so I was like do
not let these lower people down here
touch me do not let that happen it's
pretty crushing like it's a pretty
terrible thing right and so switching
back over to I guess good Jessica Drew
wouldn't call her good Jess and evil
Jess right so switching over to good
Jess of course she's using the ability
to pump her pheromones right now one of
the things about Spider-Man about
Jessica Drew is that initially when she
was introduced Marvel didn't want to
create what was in effect a carbon copy
of Peter Parker where they wanted her to
be different unique something that
wasn't necessarily the exact same as
Peter in the same way that like She-Hulk
was like the Incredible Hulk except she
could change it will things along those
lines and eventually keep her
personality in check when it comes to
Jessica Drew she can admit pheromones
that are by all standards of measurement
the chemical version of love potions is
really all it is she can basically get
people to do pretty much anything she
wants she doesn't like doing it very
often and she only likes doing it under
certain circumstances like like the the
character of Jessica Drew as she's been
written she doesn't like doing it in
order to like get stuff out of guys
right so it's not like she's like yeah I
use my pheromones I got like a free date
right she's not really that kind of a
chick she normally only uses her
pheromones whenever she's on like a spy
mission or something like that to like
overcome guards or something along those
lines but regardless but what ends up
happening here is that while good Jess
is on this ship with Namor suddenly evil
just shows up and that's when good Jess
is like okay I gotta get out of here and
she tells Neymar she's like look okay
here's what's gonna happen this this
evil Jess here is gonna show up and
you're gonna act like it's the first
time that you've ever seen me or her or
whatever the first time you've ever seen
Jessica Drew you're gonna treat it that
way and so following that we switch over
to Silk now as you guys recall silk of
course ever the pain in the ass for
anybody ever that she's ever met and
just kind of really causes more problems
for people than she does anything else
it's basically just fleeing from
Universe to Universe because you know
she felt like people weren't going to be
her friend that's literally what it came
down to right like the fact that Jessica
Drew was like Silk will get you killed
if you let her when she was talking to
spider-gwen and those folks who are
supposed to be babysitting her and so on
but basically Silk's like irresponsible
and Reckless right she's the last person
you want on your side under any
circumstance but along her basically
taking off and and hiding she was
basically being chased down by the
brother and sister inheritors right so
literally they've just been chasing her
non-stop the problem with this is that
as she continued on she basically broke
her teleporter and so she did the only
thing she could do which was jump
through the portal of the inheritors
that had been made which landed her in
Loom world now along the way while she's
there we actually pick up with Jessica
Drew who oversees her evil self
basically like toying with this guy and
saying that like hey like you know thank
you for the wine and all that kind of
stuff and there's a little bit of a joke
there right in the sense that like
Locust is gonna get like 30 lashes is
for basically stealing wine from the
kitchen of the inheritors and bringing
it to that Jessica Drew and she's like I
mean yeah but that's fine I mean you
know he gets a lifetime of lashes so
it's not like he's gonna make that much
of a difference and at least I get some
wine out of it right so very much using
people for her own ends right she
doesn't really care about the wants and
desires of individual people that
they're by and large just play things
for her own enjoyment now good Jess is
watching all this happen and she hates
it right she's just like this is
ridiculous right this is like a terrible
version of myself and so that's when you
end up having the brother and sister
inheritors who show up after they
basically lost track of Cindy moon when
she showed up here in Loom world now of
course one of the other cool things
about this is that despite how Jessica
Drew treats people and despite the fact
that even though she is this reality's
version of a Spider Woman or at least
seems to be she seems to have the
ability to just come and go as she
pleases she gets a lot more freedom than
seemingly anybody else more so than that
when she's talking to the brother of
course she basically bows down she pays
her respects all that kind of stuff so
she's not on the same level as the
inheritors in terms of social
acceptability right she is still very
much subservient and she's basically
instructed one we're not going to attack
you because we know how [ __ ] hates it
whenever we go after his own little toys
and so on and so forth so obviously her
and Marlon have a thing going on but
she's also told if you see a spider
totem here say something and so when
Cindy Moon basically comes racing
through and then sees evil Jess thinking
she's good Jessica Drew and stops to
talk to her evil Jess is like spider
totem right that's when good Jess jumps
out and knocks out evil Jess and evil
Jess is basically out of the picture at
this point like Jessica Drew gives silk
her her teleporter device and then takes
the body to name of the Submariner puts
it in like a chest and is like take off
of this for a couple days and then come
back right I need her out of the picture
for right now now as far as silk goes
because she had teleported that Drew the
attention of the inheritors the funny
thing about this is silk teleported to
Earth 3145 when the inheritors get there
they can't enter and the reason why is
because this universe or this Earth is
home to what's basically a global
thermonuclear war and so in effect it's
still highly irradiated and this
radiation is a weakness of the
inheritors and so when the brother and
the sister pass through here they
immediately start succumbing to the
effects of radiation and they have to
pull out and so what this has done is
given silk kind of a temporary safe
space so leaving soaking kind of jumping
back to Jessica Drew you're basically
met by the arrival of Moreland now one
of the funny things about this is that
more London appearing here is actually a
bit of a inconsistency in terms of
writing regarding how it was handled
we'll talk about that here in a second
because the inconsistency is really up
more for interpretation than anything
else but when Moreland arrives here and
basically Jessica Drew pretending to be
your evil self bows down pays respects
all that kind of stuff in Orlando's like
what are you doing this you don't need
to bow down to me right like you and I
are a thing right we're a couple and
then he goes in and kisses her basically
more Lunas banging a spider totem which
is kind of weird but at that point we
end up basically switching over to Earth
13 right now if you guys recall in the
video that we did before the Earth 13 is
actually or at least was the safe zone
for all the different Spider-Man that
were there until Solace the father of
the inheritors showed up here and killed
this this reality's version of cosmic
Spider-Man without his protection these
guys are all just just sitting ducks
right I mean it's just Easy Pickins now
again this kind of takes place before
Moreland comes to visit Jessica Drew and
so that's why you see moral on here
right because he hasn't really
teleported back but the the thing about
this is that he's basically got what's
referred to as the Scion now the Scion
again that's a fairly important thing
but ultimately you end up seeing like
all these different Spider-Man that are
basically attacked by by Solace and so
on when Solace tells more Lund go back
to to limbworld take the Scion with you
right so with the baby being taken right
Benji being taken basically Mayday
Parker right the the sister of Benji
starts to freak out because her
brother's basically been kidnapped and
with her mom and her dad already dead
literally Benji's all that she has left
and then ultimately you end up having
the arrival of Spider-Man UK who's like
we brought reinforcements right like we
have reinforcements here and so what you
end up getting is actually anime
Spider-Man which is amazing and then you
get Gundam Spider-Man now depending on
who you talk to some people will be like
Gundam Spider-Man's like the best
version of Spider-Man ever right but the
important thing here is that anime or
really like next Spider-Man is ripped
apart pretty quickly by solace
literally this guy shows up in a giant
giant suit of armor and it just starts
getting torn apart and they're like okay
so we were kind of hoping that guy would
be able to help us but uh yeah we're
kind of screwed so like we need to bail
out of here as fast as we possibly can
right like we literally need to run so
what they end up doing is basically
punching in just random numbers and just
teleporting arbitrarily only to
essentially arrive in what looks like an
area where dinosaurs have essentially
conquered the world now here's the funny
thing about this while we're not
explicitly given like the gritty details
of this in this particular story I would
argue this is where seemingly The Savage
land had basically taken over now for
those of you guys who don't know the
Savage land is actually a place in
Antarctica which houses like dinosaurs
and all kinds of creatures and life and
so on that was thought to be extinct
there's also people who live there right
like khazar lives there even though
nobody cares about Kazar he lives there
uh trying to find some measure of
relevance in a world of like superheroes
literally no one cares about Kazar the
reason why I say it looks like this is
where the Savage land had taken over is
because if you look in there you
basically see what looks like a
skyscraper it seems to kind of make
sense that like Humanity probably lived
in this world or existed in this world
and like the Savage land took over it
doesn't really matter honestly you see
it for like a few seconds right there
isn't a whole lot doing there instead
Peter Parker basically chimes in with
Jessica Drew now of course this takes
place after Jessica Drew finds out that
this reality's version of herself is
essentially banging more along uh but
she ends up stumbling across what is
basically the master Weaver right now uh
Spider-Man does check in on a few things
right he checks in on like Miles Morales
and Ultimate Spider-Man the cartoon
version and like they they're like it's
exactly what you would expect right
where things are basically going awry it
is awesome to see that the Spidey mobile
is back
I'm not even gonna lie to you guys I
really wish they would bring back this
Mighty mobile or bring in the Spidey
Mobile in like the Marvel Cinematic
Universe because there's just something
that sounds amazing about Tom Holland
riding around town in a dune buggy
painted as a spider it just sounds cool
something else to point out here and I
don't know if you guys are aware of this
the Spidey mobile does talk it's the
Spider-Man version of cars like it it
does talk right it can talk to you like
it can look at you and all kinds of
stuff so it's one of those cool little
things like these are all basically
Spider-Man right like cowboy Spider-Man
like these are all basically Spider-Man
of course you know they end up basically
teleporting away and one of the funny
things that I do want to point out here
is that a joking reference is made to
this group being called the web warriors
this is actually where this started from
when that comment was made in the comic
oh it exploded on the forums I don't
know how many of you guys remember that
but Spider-Man fans everywhere were like
web warriors like web warriors are
amazing like it just kind of blew up in
popularity and just kind of been that
way for a while and of course over in
the year 2099 you basically got you know
uh lady spider and you got Miguel O'Hara
basically dissecting uh one of the or at
least the body of Deimos as they had
captured the Clone body anyway and of
course what kind of circle back around
with that when we get back into uh
Spider-Man 2099 but the big thing about
this is jumping back to loom world right
to Earth one where you basically have uh
Jessica Drew conversing with the master
Weaver one of the things we learn here
is that yes the master Weaver is
imprisoned by the inheritors right the
master Weaver is serving the inheritors
despite the fact that Master Weaver
doesn't necessarily want to the other
thing about this and this is what made
the notion of the master Weaver so so
wonky is the ability to see the future
that what this did is that while it
wasn't necessarily like a foolproof
thing right like make sure you turn left
on that road on Tuesday right you'll get
to where you need to be while it's not
necessarily like that so the the
inheritors weren't able to basically
meet Spider-Man in every single reality
as soon as they teleported there it was
more of kind of like a broad Direction
in terms of where time was going even
then it still kind of flies in the face
of of Marvel Comics as a whole and the
reason why is because if you go and you
look at things like Days of Future Past
or or any one of those stories that take
place in the future one thing to bear in
mind is that while that quote-unquote
future had been averted at any point in
time it can become the guaranteed future
of Marvel Comics it's why sometimes
they'll go back and reference those
stories right so Days of Future Past
that reality wasn't necessarily
destroyed per se it is technically an
alternate universe out out there but
Marvel kind of keeps it on the back
burner under this idea that hey guys at
some future point in time Senator Robert
Kelly and Maury mctaggard and Professor
Xavier can all be assassinated and that
can basically lead to Days of Future
Past although I believe Robert Kelly's
dead he's been gone for a long time
basically what the master Weaver tells
Jessica Drew here is that while it is
basically forced to work with the
inheritors or work for the inheritors by
opening up portals to different
dimensions and different things like
that giving them a kind of General
viewpoint on what direction the future
is going in and so on and so forth that
it can also work against them he cannot
do it overtly otherwise they'll kill the
master Weaver and replace him with
somebody else but what it does is it
basically pulls little strands so
basically kind of orchestrating and
ensuring things play out a different way
right so like instead of Jessica Drew
basically being assigned to loom World
by Peter Parker that she could have
ended up in some alternate reality
somewhere that it basically could have
been her and Ben Riley and Kane that
were dealing with uh the the whole clone
area such as it was was the master
Weaver basically pulled little strings
and kind of had things maneuvered in
little ways even if it's only kind of
subconsciously manipulating Peter Parker
and those guys so that it would all lead
to Jessica Drew being here presumably
because this is the only circumstance
where it works and so what ends up
happening is the master Weaver says like
all this is done right all these strings
have been pulled all this manipulation
through the timeline has been done for
the purpose of getting you here so I can
give you these Scrolls right these
prophecies about the Scion and the other
and the bride and something else and
that's kind of the funny thing here is
because this is where you basically end
up learning about all these little these
little roles and moments and so on and
so forth and so what Jessica Drew
actually ends up doing is basically
taking these Scrolls and teleporting
them away to Peter Parker now she does
this because one she's not supposed to
be in the presence of the master Weaver
right that area is off limits to her and
two she certainly couldn't be in
possession of Scrolls that basically
illustrate what these particular roles
play as well as what the master plan of
the inheritors is because their job or
their goal is not just simply just kills
Spider-Man they actually have a goal
they have a particular task that they're
trying to achieve here kind of a
ceremony that they're looking to attain
and so of course they need these
individual spider Turtles the bride the
Scion the other like they need those
individual characters to achieve this
particular goal in the end when they go
to Peter Peter of course is contacted by
Cindy moon right where they're looking
for safe space in City moons like I
found a place where the inheritors can't
come to it's Earth 3145 right this is
alternate reality where they can't come
here get here as fast as you possibly
can so of course they all end up
teleporting away now once they get there
they realize the whole area is
irradiated right Mayday Parker's pissed
off at all of them right because she's
just like because of you guys my
brother's basically been kidnapped she's
working with them but like her role here
will basically stop as soon as her
brother is effectively saved but like at
the end of the day they're like okay
look like we're here yes everything's
gone to pot we've literally ended up in
one bad situation after another because
Peter Parker is clearly more inept than
Dr Octopus was as Spider-Man he's
nowhere near as intelligent or capable
or able to plan in the same way but
they're all kind of taking his lead
anyway because they hope that he's right
even though he has kind of proven
himself to be a bit of an idiot when it
comes to being a leader and so
ultimately when they get here
arrows out of webbing which leads them
to their destination right exactly where
she had gone to which was the bunker
where all the different spider totems
were hidden and that's where we kind of
end up getting this realization if we
hadn't achieved it already that while
Ezekiel sends the person who initially
told Peter Parker about the inheritors
about like more Lund and all those guys
where he had built a bunker in the main
Marvel Universe for Peter Parker
seemingly that had been done across
every single Universe in the Multiverse
to keep the Spider-Man safe because the
threat of the inheritors was so
significant and so this reality's
version of Spider-Man had basically been
hiding out in this bunker and Cindy Moon
stumbled across this reality's version
of Spider-Man when she went to that
bunker and so when Peter gets there he's
like okay look this place is going to be
a little cramped it's going to be a
little bit crazy but uh at the end of
the day like you know while it's a
little crowded everything is going to be
cool and then that's when Cindy moon is
like okay well here's the thing though I
discover the the spider person of this
universe and you might want to embrace
yourself for a shock Peter Parker the
reason why is because when all the
lights and everything get turned on we
we end up finding out this reality
version of Spider-Man is Uncle Ben
all right what's going on guys this is
Rob and we are back with spider-verse
and in this instance we are picking up
with the Scarlet spider's story now
something that I also told you guys is
that we would explain the whole idea
behind like the other and all that kind
of stuff in this video which we will do
but what this initially does is it
basically picks up with like Ben Riley
and Kane and Jessica Drew from the
Ultimate Universe these guys facing off
against genics in all honesty this story
is pretty straightforward and there's
not a whole lot doing here right like
Gen X is there to stop them from
destroying the cloning facility their
idea is to destroy the cloning facility
and then things just kind of go from
there right like you basically got Kane
and and that's that's kind of the funny
thing I always thought of Kane as like
an answer to the question what if the
Punisher became Spider-Man because while
Kane is not necessarily as brutal as
like Frank Castle is he's certainly a
lot more brutal than Spider-Man
traditionally is and so as a result of
that one of the things that he really
kind of takes on here is this idea that
the inheritors will always hunt them and
where Ben Riley is kind of like no no we
can't kill them that's not what we do
the response of Kane is like we're past
the point of like the moral High Ground
right we're past the point of saying
like we don't kill inheritors because
it's the wrong thing to do instead he's
just like this guy has to die and so
what ends up happening here is that he
actually start s to lose control of
himself and when he does he starts
basically developing like these
appendages and spikes and things like
that they come out of his body and he
successfully kills genix now there's a
reason why this happens and this
basically leads us into our discussion
about the nature of the spider totems
and so on and so forth so here's the
thing to understand when it comes to
these totems the reality in terms of why
Marvel created them in the first place
it was initially just designed to
explain why Peter Parker could do things
that were Beyond his normal Power set so
originally Peter Parker was an avatar of
the other then what you also have is the
bride and you have the Scion in terms of
the ones that matter here there are
others but the way this all works is
that if we use Juggernaut as an example
right Kane Marco is an avatar of sidorak
insofar as sidorak the demon entity had
a crimson gym and K Marco got his hands
on the Crimson gym and by possessing it
he is given a portion of the power that
belongs to sitarak the great spider
totems are basically the exact same
thing that you have the Multiverse so
then you have the web of life and
Destiny which is kind of the Spider-Man
version of the Multiverse so think of it
like the Spider-Man equivalent of like a
speed force essentially for like the
flash but the spider totems exist on a
multiversal scale and there's only ever
one of them so there's only ever one
other there's only ever one bride
there's only ever one Scion right that's
it and the way this works is that you
basically have like the the great Weaver
the master Weaver if you want to call it
that and their job is to one ensure that
the Multiverse is maintained by
basically having individual Spider-Man
or spider-women become hosts for the
great totems or the great avatars and so
in the case of Peter Parker and the idea
of the other that was initially Marvel's
way of explaining how it is he was able
to do things that he couldn't normally
do and it went on that way for a little
while but one of the things that we've
talked about in the past is that when
jokasana became editor-in-chief he
wanted to get rid of what he considered
to be all the unnecessary fluff and
return the characters back to their
basic roots and the basic root of Peter
Parker is he was a kid bitten by live
spider that basically gave him powers
and then he went forward to Spider-Man
all the other stuff that like
strzezinski and some of those guys did
where they created the spider totems and
so on uh Casada thought was unnecessary
and so that's why Peter Parker who was
originally a host of the other all that
went away in the aftermath of one more
day that when his whole history was
Rewritten by Mephisto one of those
things is that instead of him embracing
the other as he had previously done he
cast it aside and so that entity that
spiritual Essence if we want to call it
that was taken away from Peter by the
great Weaver and given to Cain and
that's why it is that Kane is now the
other in Marvel Comics and the case of
Cindy Moon she's the bride and in the
case of Benji he's the Scion now the
question that has to be asked here is
what's the purpose of these guys what do
they do with these particular roles so
if we start with the Scion as most of
you guys know whenever a person becomes
like a Spider-Man or a Spider Woman more
often than not is because they're bitten
by a radioactive spider right this is
kind of the Mythos surrounding
Spider-Man and has been since the
character's introduction however there
are occasionally instances where a
person is born with spider powers and
that's what the Scion represents
specifically it's bingy he's the
youngest person in the Multiverse to
have been born with the abilities of
Spider-Man and so he represents every
instance where a person is born with
spider powers now the nature of silk
also called The Bride is she is the one
that's basically the spider wife of
Peter Parker if we can call it that not
literally she's not married to Peter
Parker but when you look at the various
instances where people have been bitten
by a radioactive spider and then went on
to become Spider-Man or Spider Woman it
only ever usually happens once right in
the case of Miles Morales it's a little
bit different Miles Morales was bitten
by a spider that came from the same
experimental stock but miles himself was
not actually bitten by the same spider
that bit Peter Parker Cindy moon was
bitten by the same spider that bit Peter
Parker in the main Marvel universe so
she represents random chance right
happenstance the random probability that
somebody will be in a certain place at a
certain time and then be bitten by a
radioactive spider that will turn them
into Spider-Man and then in turn you
have the other which is basically just
like the warrior quote unquote of the
various spider totems right the one
built for conflict and so that's why
over the course of this whole
spider-verse event yes you have all
kinds of different people who have been
bitten by radioactive spiders things
like that but then you have select few
because the circumstances surrounding
them becoming Spider-Man and
Spider-Woman are very unique among the
web of life and Destiny
99.99999 of every single Spider-Man and
Spider-Woman that you're ever going to
see in the Multiverse were just a
version of Peter Parker man or woman who
was bitten by a radioactive spider and
that's it but Benji was born with his
powers silk was bitten by a spider the
same spider that bit Peter Parker and
the other is the totem that defends all
the others and so in the end in facing
the fact or facing this Revelation that
so long as this cloning facility remains
that it'll just keep going on and on and
on and on with Kane currently knocked
out right he's out of commission and
then you've got Jessica Drew who is
captured by Ben Reilly does the only
thing he can do right he actually ends
up just activating an explosive device
really just like a giant bullet right I
mean this thing's much much larger than
like a 50 count but basically just like
throws it into a stack of all these
other bullets and just blows up the
entirety of the cloning facility right
he basically ends up killing himself in
the process while Jessica Drew gets Kane
out of there and as Kane begins to come
too he realizes that Ben Riley's now
dead right then Reilly sacrificed his
life in order to destroy genics and he
in turn blames the inheritors for it and
so because of the fact that he won
recognizes that he's the other two he
can kill the inheritors and three the
cloning facility is destroyed that
basically there's no real way for the
inheritors to come back and so once they
die they stay dead and so basically
leaning into the totality of his power
as the other he heads directly to loom
World in order to find a way to destroy
the inheritors now at that point we
switch over to loom World itself right
back to Earth one and you have of course
these other members of the inheritors
who were here right you've got Borah and
bricks and you've got Jinx at least
what's left of him him right the the
last Gen X that there will ever be you
have like all these people who are here
demos and so on and they all of course
are just begging for forgiveness because
of the fact that they essentially failed
Solace or at least in their mind they
failed Solace because the different
members of the uh of the totems that are
they were supposed to capture the bride
and the other and so on have all
basically managed to escape so the
response to Solace is we're not worried
about that and the reason why is because
remember what the web of life and
Destiny while it's not unnecessarily
guaranteed future which is do a b and c
and d will happen it's more of if you do
a b and c than like D or e or F will
happen or something along those lines
that Solace seems to have this
understanding of the fact that in time
because of what they've done so far
specifically the fact that they've
captured Benji they've captured the
Scion that in turn everybody else will
follow suit right the nature of
Spider-Man is no man Left Behind they
won't sacrifice people if they don't
have to and so in turn he knows they
will come to them they'll basically go
to the ends of the Earth to try to find
a way to save Benji and ultimately the
other and the bride will inevitably end
up on loom world even if the others stay
behind and so what we end up doing is
transitioning back to Earth 3145 right
now remember this is where we discovered
that in this reality Uncle Ben ended up
becoming Spider-Man and has just been
kind of laying in weight here ever since
and what we end up finding out is the
origin is not that dissimilar again kind
of tying into this discussion about like
the Scion and so on and so forth that
when Peter had basically gone to the
science exhibit that nobody would go
with it and so Uncle Ben basically took
the day off ended up going with Peter
Uncle Ben was bitten by a radioactive
spider and Peter actually leaned into it
right he helped him develop all kinds of
like Technologies and things like that
that could help him play this role and
that he basically went forward as a hero
the problem with this is that as you
guys know just by nature of reading
comic books when you are a hero you will
draw the attention of villains and that
where in the main Marvel Universe the
Green Goblin had killed Gwen Stacy in
this universe the Green Goblin killed
Peter Parker and Aunt May which
basically left Uncle Ben alone and so he
ultimately abandoned his role as being
Spider-Man now this is really important
because
actually a time like this little panel
you see where like Uncle Ben is walking
away and like the Spider-Man costumes in
a trash can that was an actual plot
moment that happened in the Spider-Man
Mythos when Peter Parker was going to
quit he ultimately ended up going back
to be Spider-Man but Uncle Ben didn't do
that instead Uncle Ben was met by
Ezekiel Sims who basically told him hey
like there are inheritors running around
the Multiverse and they are killing
Spider-Man and they will find you and
kill you unless you come with me and you
stay in this bunker but unlike what you
would expect from like Peter Parker of
the main Marvel Universe who would do
exactly what he did do which is turn
down the offer and instead go forward as
being Spider-Man confronting whatever
threat May face him because the lives he
can save in the interim and the good he
can do outweighs the value of his own
life that Uncle Ben leaned into it and
so he decided to stay in the bunker and
where some of you guys may interpret
that as me kind of saying that Uncle Ben
was a coward the reality is you would be
right and in fact that's how he's
depicted here by Dan slot now one thing
that I want to point out when this
happened people were pissed when it
comes to spider man fans they never want
to see Uncle Ben shined in any light
other than Uncle Ben was just this great
guy who always did Noble things and his
death was one of the most significant
moments in Peter's life but that's kind
of the great thing about this is that
having an Uncle Ben that makes morally
questionable decisions I think is a cool
thing because it takes him off of this
pedestal that Spider-Man fans put him on
and kind of brings him down to being
like yeah man he's a person like he's a
human being he's not some Godly guy
who's incapable of making bad decisions
and everything he does is great but like
morally questionable decisions that's an
awesome concept and so what you also end
up finding out here is that the world
itself being totally destroyed actually
happened at the hands of Otto Octavius
now remember superior Spider-Man is
listening to this whole thing and as you
guys know superior Spider-Man was when
Dr Octopus took over the body of Peter
and so what superior Spider-Man is
basically listening to is this story
where an alternate reality version of
himself held the world hostage using
nuclear weapons and that when all his
demands were being met something went
wrong and basically the world of evolved
or at least was destroyed by nuclear
weapons superior Spider-Man is so taken
aback by this because in his mind he
could never make such a miscalculation
and it's one of those funny things
because he's kind of like you know in
every Universe no matter what Universe
it is I am always this intelligent when
in reality he was kind of an idiot in
this universe and basically led to it
all being destroyed the other part of
this is that Peter Parker kind of Yanks
everybody back and says okay look this
is a cool tale and everything but it's
taken us off track right our Focus needs
to be on what's going on with these
spider totems right what's going on with
what the inheritors want to do Jessica
Drew sacrificed her teleporter to give
us these Scrolls and nobody's ever
really able to read them now when it
comes to Silk ever the girl whose emo
and just feels misunderstood by the
world when like somebody makes some
off-handed remark and they're like so
basically Jessica Drew sacrificed our
teleporter to give us these useless
Scrolls that we can't use then silk
Little Miss the world revolves around me
and you know anytime anybody says
anything bad about something that I
happen to be involved in they're
directly talking about me she's like oh
oh God I feel so bad you know and that
kind of thing I'm sure she basically
leaves one of the things to understand
this story killed people's interest in
silk because all she was was the girl
who just moped around and every single
circumstance that ever went bad was a
reflection of her and the fact that she
had somehow failed as a person right
like people remember reading the forums
and people were like dude I hate silk
like so much and so what actually ends
up happening is her working alongside uh
spider-gwen they actually teleport away
to loom World directly in order to find
a way to get Jessica Drew out of loom
world and back to basically this reality
which is where none of the inheritors
can arrive to you but something that I
hope you guys are noticing is that now
with Cindy moon going there on top of
Kane going there all the uh all the
these fighter totems are all in the same
place now one of the other things to
know here is that when it came to uh
Anya Corazon that remember she's not
truly a Spider Woman per se she is but
she's not she got her powers by mystical
means and the spider society that
worships the nature of spider totems are
the ones who basically gave for her
powers but they also worship the totems
which meant they can read these Scrolls
and so Anya Corazon knows how to read
them because she was taught to and so
where she goes through and reads all
this we're not really given like the ins
and outs and the specific details of how
all the spider totems work but what we
are told is that if the blood of the
bride and the other and the Scion is
spilled on the web of life and Destiny
that it'll basically destroy any of the
spider totems from coming into existence
that basically there will be no other
there will be no bride no Scion or
anything like that and that in doing so
the inheritors will never have to
concern themselves with the other part
of the prophecy which is that the
various Spider-Man and Spider-Woman that
exist out there specifically the totems
are destined to end the reign of the
inheritors themselves they're destined
to destroy the inheritors and so that's
why the inheritors are doing this is
because while yes killing various spider
totems does grant them like some
increased level of power and they do
find satisfaction in absorbing the life
energies of various Spider-Man and
spider-women out there their goal is to
actually find find the bride and the
other in the Scion and then take them
spill their blood on the web of life and
Destiny and then destroy the future
appearances of any other Spider-Man as
well as actually ending the Multiverse
now this would be doubly worse because
the Multiverse is already collapsing
right like the the incursions were
happening at the time this story was
taking place so if anything the
inheritors would actually speed up the
destruction of all existence which
really is one of the things that a lot
of people asked when it came to
spider-verse I found myself asking that
that while you did have like the black
priests and the ivory Kings and all that
kind of stuff how come the inheritors
never came across the map makers or
anything like that right if they were
being sent to universes where Spider-Man
were there it seemed to maybe kind of
make sense because it just meant that
like the incursions had not taken place
on those worlds yet or like the black
priests had not arrived so I guess it
kind of made sense but still you would
have thought somewhere along the line
they would have like met a black priest
or a group of black priests or something
like that and just like fled for their
lives after almost being destroyed but
whatever the case is when we switch over
to loom World we're canarized and in
fact Spider-Man tells him look man and
like do not go to loom world and Kane's
like too late bro I'm already here right
and he's just like no no like you're
literally destroying the plan that we
need to create like you're doing the
worst possible thing the question that
Spider-Man has is or at least a
statement he makes is okay look we
basically got Cindy Moon who took off
the loom World we've got Kane who took
off to loom world the Scions already on
loom world they're in the worst place
because they're going to be easy to
capture so he's like everybody doing
everything you're doing Drop it right
like no matter what you're doing what it
is that's happening right now drop what
you're doing we all need to go to loom
world and either we have to destroy the
inheritors or we have to save the three
spider totems and get them out of there
and bring them back here now Miguel
O'Hara's initial response is no like
we're in the middle of something give me
like five minutes and then we'll head
back out there and then of course you
end up having like Miles Morales and all
those Spiderman that they've gathered
who are of course answering the call and
so they're responding and so what you
end up getting or at least doing is
switching back over to loom world and
you basically end up having the having
the other right like Kane who
successfully manages to kill Solace now
this was another controversial moment in
the story and and when I controversy in
the story I mean it's I use it as a
loose term right I mean there's nothing
controversial about comic books right
like it's it's comic books but like the
thing about this is that uh that the
other actually kills Solace which was
kind of nuts right because again the
other is like the warrior right designed
or destined to face off and seemingly
destroy any threats that may befall the
various spider totems that exist out
there but were Solace who's seemingly
the most powerful of all the inheritors
is killed by Kane that in turn Kane is
killed by more Lund what made this
controversial to fans is that it
happened so incredibly fast right it
just happened so quickly now a lot of
this was because it was just part and
parcel to telling the story so I would
argue anybody who was mad about this was
probably looking for a reason to be mad
to me like I wasn't you know it was like
I mean I guess it makes sense right I
mean something had to happen right I
mean this you know Kane couldn't stay
around as Spider-Man forever in all
honesty this as much as any other story
was designed to kind of wrap up his plot
threads and basically call it a day but
at the end of the day uh because of the
fact that Solace is now dead that puts
more line in charge of all the other
inheritors and so what you end up
getting of course is that while Jessica
Drew and Cindy Moon and spider-gwen are
now gathered together after Jessica Drew
was rescued by Cindy Moon and spider
Gwen that in turn leaves all the Green
Goblins being sent are being descended
onto them by the inheritor so of course
now they have to flee for their lies and
this leads into to another one of the
controversial moments from the story
which was the depiction of Uncle Ben
that when you switch back to this
reality and you've got Peter Parker
talking Uncle Ben and saying look like
we've got to go the response of May
Parker ride the spider girl from an
ultra Universe Benji's older sister is
like one person is not going to make a
difference and the response of Uncle Ben
is yeah you're right like I'm not gonna
make any any real difference here right
like I mean I possibly could have done
something to stop you know uh Dr Octopus
from destroying you know my my world or
whatever it is but he's like at the end
of the day like I'm just one simple guy
right there's nothing I can do here
there's not much that can be offered to
like save this day but this is where
things were really cool with Peter
because suddenly the shoe was on the
other foot in years past it was always
Uncle Ben making these speeches just to
Peter Parker and saying with great power
must come great responsibility that you
have a duty to to things greater than
yourself that you can't simply just kind
of fall to the Wayside collapse in on
yourself when times get hard because
it's when times get hard that you really
find out what you are and the way that
Uncle Ben is depicting himself is that
when times get hard he gives up he
doesn't really like stand up and kind of
keep on going the way that he's supposed
to a massive difference between this
reality is Uncle Ben and the Uncle Ben
that Peter Parker knows and Peter Parker
goes as far as to tell him that right
like in my universe my Uncle Ben never
would have done this he never would have
been the guy to just kind of sit down
and collapse and give up roll over and
play dead because things just got really
really hard and because he made a few
bad choices right he's like I have lost
seemingly everything that was important
to me all the things that were that were
that were significant to me and where
Peter Parker doesn't necessarily seem to
be able to to rile him up and doesn't
seem to be able to kind of get him back
it comes down to Superior Spider-Man and
he's like you're pathetic old man
and just start screaming on right like
where Peter Parker goes to chime in the
response to Superior Spider-Man is shut
up right he's like he's like so you're
saying that's it you're afraid to fail
again right that's what you have to
offer no he's like I've lost more times
than I've won and every time I got back
up that's all that matters and he's like
when Victory is easy it's cheap every
fight that's ever been worth fighting
has been against adversity against
so-called quote unquote unbeatable
forces some kind of unbeatable foe but
there is no such thing every enemy has a
weakness you just have to find it once
right he's the one that actually rallies
Uncle Ben that gets Uncle Ben off his
backside and willing to fight again he's
like look the ones who go forward and
Achieve great things who do something
meaningful are the ones who stand in the
face of everything they've lost and are
willing to give just a little bit more
in order to get what it is that they
really want and that's what he asked
what is it that you really want here do
you want to give up just roll over and
play dead or do you want to get off your
ass and do something right do you want
to redeem all these past mistakes and
all these past failures that you've made
and that's exactly what happens Uncle
Ben gets up and it's like one more time
and Dawns the costume and the whole
group goes forward into Loom world with
the intention of killing the inheritors
what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are back with spiderverse and here's a
funny thing this is going to be a pretty
short video relative to the other ones
that we've done because this is
basically part of Spider-Man team up uh
so these stories are not super lengthy
in fact they're like 10 pages each right
so they're they're pretty short here
what's funny about this one though is
this is probably one of the most
important moments from all of
spider-verse and so I don't really
understand why they shuffled it off to a
team up comic and basically called it a
day right it's a little weird that they
did that but one of the things that had
come out of the Scrolls that have been
given to the uh to the spider Army by
the master Weaver was the nature of Karn
now we've talked about Karn before that
he's one of the inheritors the Khan
himself very much cherished love and
beauty and that unlike the other
inheritors he didn't feed on spiders out
of a desire to and so when his family
learned that they basically put this
helmet on his head and then vanished him
from the inheritor Homeworld destined to
essentially spend forever consuming
spiders in an effort to earn his place
back home the reality is that was never
going to happen but because of the fact
that the spiders have learned this they
see him as a potential ally because of
the fact that the enemy of my enemy is
my friend that Karn hates his family and
his father most of all and so the
spiders can use that to their advantage
as a means to basically rally and bring
him on board so what we do is we switch
over to Earth 3123 this alternate
reality where it actually turns out that
Peter Parker and Uncle Ben neither one
of them had become Spider-Man instead it
was Aunt May which is cool you know
there's a few stories those of you guys
who don't know there's a few stories
where awesome stuff happens with Aunt
May like you guys remember the golden
oldies story right where like Aunt May
becomes like golden oldies she's a
Herald of Galactus it's amazing it's
really cool she's like babysitting
Franklin Richards and got like Galactus
shows up out of nowhere and then she
like races off and like chastises him
and then like he turns her into a Herald
and then like she goes and finds world's
form it's really cool like it's a really
really fun little story but regardless
this this conversation between the two
is actually interesting because Aunt May
does exactly what you would expect her
to do right I mean she's a kindly old
woman she's like a nice old woman that
would like fix your cookies and stuff
like that I mean she'll Wallop you
upside the head with her purse if you're
like you know if you're mouthing off or
acting up right I mean Aunt May's never
afraid to throw hands but the
conversation between the two is such
that she's a very gentle person and it
almost kind of begins to turn Karn for
like a brief second but then he snaps
back and says no right Destiny cannot be
denied I have to earn my place back at
my family just one more spider that dies
and then I'll in turn be able to earn my
place again right I'll be able to be
back with the family kind of earn my
right as I desired it so much now of
course as you would expect you basically
end up having the arrival of all these
fighters who show up right so you've got
Ashley Barton you've got spider Punk
you've got Spider-Man UK Billy Braddock
you've got Spider-Man India you have
like all these spiders who show up out
of nowhere and a fight breaks out
between them and Khan now here's a funny
thing about this that Karn initially
goes to attack all of them right and we
all know for the most part Karn could
probably overpower them right and
probably even kill them but right off
the bat they take him by surprise and
the reason why is because he says like I
don't know how you guys you know how you
came here I don't know how you got this
knowledge that you know you that I was
banished from my family and all that
kind of stuff and it doesn't matter he's
like but but like all of you are going
to die and the response of Spiderman UK
is like you have it wrong like we're not
here to fight you man we're here to ask
you to join us right and initially the
response of Karen is like man you guys
must be desperate if you're showing up
here asking me to join your ranks but
the funny thing here is that Spider-Man
India chimes in and says I understand
obligation to family better than most
but your family betrayed those
obligations long ago they claim to
punish you for your mother's death but
the truth is they sent you away because
they feared you because you questioned
them and then Ashley chimes in and says
the same Kinfolk who said that you could
come back and live with them like one
big happy family if you killed just
enough spiders and that was how many
hundreds of years ago the walls are
closing in like their argument is
there's nothing you can do here that
will make your family proud there's
nothing you can do to earn your place at
their side God that's never going to
happen that's never ever ever going to
happen like there's nothing you can do
here your family will always have you as
a as a carrot on a stick right just keep
going a little bit longer and you'll get
it right they're literally just leading
you on and so either you can stand aside
from that you can stop that or you can
keep it going and one of the funny
things is they kind of tease this way of
saying like you you know they have like
another way for him to continue to
survive and where the answer that that
any crazy gives us no we don't but your
family if you help us beat them we could
use their technology to find
alternatives to you traveling around the
Multiverse and consuming spiders then
right off the bat Carn snaps back right
this little glimmer of hope that he
thought he had he snaps back and says no
no that's never gonna happen I've got to
keep doing my thing right in a lot of
ways it's like a video game right where
you have to go through like those trust
challenges where you have to like
convince them into believing you and if
you answer any of the questions wrong
then like they're like no I can't trust
you you know you guys know what I'm
talking about like Star Wars knight to
the Old Republic is a really good
example of that where Karen says it's
useless to defy fate the natural order
Spider-Man UK says who says there's only
one natural order how many worlds have
you been to I've seen multitudes they're
all beautiful and they're all different
according to the scroll you wanted to
explore their Beauty record it celebrate
it not bring death and destruction and
then Anya chimes in and says and asks
for fate who knows more about it than
the master Weaver and who do you think
gave us this and so when the statements
made like the master Weaver is the
reason why we have these Scrolls in the
first place it kind of begins to lock
things in stone because while Karn has
been banished from his family for quite
some time the basic functions of the
family and the nature of the master
Weaver that's still known to him and
again one of the things that we've
stated is that while the master Weaver
doesn't tell them Walk This Way and turn
left you know or follow this exact path
and you will end up where you want to go
he doesn't lead them to their future the
master Weaver does have knowledge of the
future and so what their response is the
master Weaver gave us these Scrolls and
in giving us these Scrolls gave us this
knowledge of you so we could tell you
that we have this knowledge so we could
ask you to work with us that is all
basically fate that Karn was destined to
turn away from his family and to join
the spider Army against the inheritors
this is a big Ally for a variety of
reasons the first is because despite the
fact that Karen has been gone for a
lengthy amount of time there's still
some very important information he can
give the spider Army to help him defeat
his family their inner workings how they
function all that kind of stuff any
information that they don't have no
matter how small is exceedingly
important in this war that they're
engaged in the other part of this is
that Khan says my Hunger can be intense
it can be uncontrollable there are times
when I'm going to need to feed and the
response of these guys is okay then if
that's the case and this is a big risk
that we're taking here we'll let you
feed on us not enough to like kill them
right but enough to basically sustain
himself and that's what happens right
Khan comes in this realization he says
all this time it was a lie the centuries
I suffered the pain I inflicted none of
it had to happen my family told one
truth there is no greater wretch than me
and so the response to spider Punk is no
one is beyond Redemption it will be a
long journey but that is nothing new to
you is it let us help you take the first
step this is an important thing because
it feeds into the nature of the spider
Army the various Spiderman themselves
right one of the things we didn't
necessarily cover in the previous video
I didn't seem overly important is that
there is a point where Spider-Man India
has this bit of a kind of an emotional
breakdown where he seems to come to this
realization that when he looks at Peter
Parker that all their differing names
and even their costumes seem to be
alternate variations of Peter Parker
himself that they're all basically
copies of Peter Parker and in a lot of
ways that's true but that's the common
theme that Spider-Man more often than
not share it's one of the things that
made Ashley Barton and Superior
Spider-Man so unique is that they were
kind of an answer to the question what
happens when somebody becomes a
spider-esque character but then it's
kind of a villain and then maybe kind of
a hero but is usually a jerk more often
than not but they aren't straight true
villains I mean I guess maybe Ashley
Barton is she kind of became the new
Kingpin and Man Logan but outside of her
you know superior Spider-Man isn't
necessarily a straight villain he kind
of was in the beginning but he changes
ways as time went on and that's kind of
the nature of what it means when it
comes to the Spider-Man Mythos is
they're not necessarily naive I mean in
some ways they are right the belief that
like everybody can be saved if you just
show them happiness and help them
understand their hearts are three sizes
too small you know like if you if you
approach it from that perspective sure
right that's just that's just good old
plain being naive you know and so with
these different Spider-Man sure like in
this instance If This Were anybody else
they probably would have pummeled it but
the fact that Karen is someone they need
on their side that they're able to bring
in this sort of gentler touch that can
kind of rally him in and say look we
need your help in defeating the family
that you hate so much and so as a result
of this they actually all end up
basically grabbing Khan and sharing a
bit of their power with him which kind
of allows him to feed and sustain
himself to a degree not enough that it
like kills anybody but enough that like
he's able to kind of keep himself going
and then following that they exit
through the portal and take Karn back to
their base of operation so again an
exceedingly important story in the
spider-verse event which was just kind
of shuffled off to a Side Story and I
never completely understood why but
okay so we are finally here at the
conclusion of spider-verse and for some
of you guys the response might kind of
be God this ending kind of came out of
nowhere it did and that was really one
of the biggest gripes that people had
about spider-verse when the event
originally happened is the ending felt
rushed right like at the time the story
The the ending came out a lot of people
were on forums and they were like god it
feels like Marvel just wrapped it up
with a quickness and they kind of had to
right that's one of the things about it
is when we when we covered this event
originally and we were talking about
everything that was going on at the time
remember Marvel had the incursions going
on right the collapse of the Multiverse
and all that kind of stuff and the
reality is that everything that Marvel
was writing was largely contingent on
what was going on with secret wars in
the sense that it was all basically
supposed to end at around the same time
in the sense that what you basically got
was you had the last days of various
Heroes right the last days of Loki the
last days of Black Widow last days of
Punisher different things like that
Spider-Man didn't necessarily get that
he kind of did but spider-verse was
really more of the last days of
Spider-Man because for his character it
really went directly into Secret Wars
issue number zero and basically the
collapse of the Multiverse and so with
all this happening it was basically this
idea that Marvel had to wrap it up fast
and that's exactly what they did and so
in the last video we basically kind of
ended it with the various Spider-Man
from across the Multiverse descending
onto Loom world right the Homeworld of
the inheritors due to a couple different
factors one they didn't necessarily want
to do this they wanted to kind of keep
playing Shadow games to a degree sort of
biting their time and trying to organize
their strategy a little bit more but
because of the fact that Silk is one of
the important spider totems because
she's the bride because Kane is the
other and because Benji the Scion had
basically been taken already that with
silk and Kane arriving on loom world the
hand of the Spider-Man was basically
Force they had to come here to rescue
these guys in order to keep the prophecy
from coming to fruition which would
basically see the destruction of all the
different Spider-Man across the
Multiverse and so one of the things that
happens with this is that with the death
of Solace as the father of the
inheritors and remember he's not really
the biological father so much as he's
like the leader of the group and so they
really base leadership roles on like
familial lines right so that's why you
have like mother you have father not
really their biological parents so much
as this is ceremonial role they hold but
with the death of Solace this is really
throwing the inheritors into disarray
Deimos more than others and the reason
why is because the prophecy as it had
been foretold by the master Weaver is
that Solace would outlive demos but the
problem with this is that Deimos
outlives Solace and so what this does is
it actually throws into into kind of
disarray this idea that the prophecies
don't really matter because the
prophecies were wrong the prophecies
only have as much value as whether or
not they unfold the instant of Prophecy
does not come to fruition it's usually
discarded as having been a false
prophecy or that conclusion was
basically averted right that's usually
kind of How It's treated here and so
with with Deimos that's the way he
responds the funny thing about this is
that with Genex again being the
scientific arm of the inheritors and the
one that was responsible for creating
clone bodies for the inheritors to
occupy what he does was is he actually
produces this Crystal which basically
has all the knowledge and essentially
the essence of Solace it's basically his
Consciousness locked away in crystalline
form and what that would do that
intelligence that it was kind of backed
up in real time seemingly would be put
into a new host body and that's how the
inheritors would come back by virtue of
being cloned but because the cloning
facility was destroyed this Crystal is
all that's left of Solace now one thing
that I want you guys to notice here it's
the 11th hour right I mean it's
basically over with and so the
inheritors are kind of Clinging On to
this idea that they can somehow come out
on top and so that's where the prophecy
kind of comes back when genix says no no
the prophecy is true we can believe the
master Weaver because technically Solace
has outlived you because his Essence is
in this Crystal the master Weaver did
not specify how Solace would outlive you
right what condition he would be in the
master Weaver simply just said that you
would now one thing to keep in mind
though is that the master Weaver has
basically been working against the
inheritors in small ways and so while
we're not doing given a definitive
answer here this may be one of these
instances where the master Weaver didn't
really give them a false prophecy so
much as a prophecy that was kind of
skirting the lines between true and
false right but regardless you end up
having uh more Lun who Begins the
prophecy itself right the process of
basically killing these different spider
totems and again this is where you
really got like the actual explanation
but again it was very very cryptic it
wasn't really given to us in a clear-cut
way so for example when he goes and
kills the other basically Kane the giant
spider form that Kane took on he says as
it was foretold with this first cut the
blood of the other stains the great web
across all time and space its Legacy is
no more it shall find no new host the
problem with this is that while I mean
this portion is straightforward right
there will never be a person who will
imbue the power of the other and the
Multiverse ever again it still didn't
really give us a definitive role that
the other played it's one of those
things where it was only in hindsight
between questions that were answered by
Dan slot and future stories that were
done that we got an explanation of what
the other was actually about that and
the old J Michael strzynski stuff but
the point is that there will be no more
combative Spider-Man right in the sense
that like the other is kind of a host
for like the fighter of the various
spider totems right to protect the other
spider totems nobody will ever imbue
this again and so the master Weaver in
turn completes the other half of the
statement and saying the great totem
will inhabit no living thing its age is
over the spiders can feel it in their
blood the strands of the web pull at
them they are coming for you Morlan all
of them and that's exactly what happens
all these Spider-Man all start coming
for them from conceivably every
direction they've already arrived on on
loom world at this point they haven't
quite gotten to the location of where
Morlan is at the other part of this is
all they knew is that Kane had taken off
two Loom World they didn't know what
happened to him but when they arrive on
the scene and they discover the fact
that Kane is dead this is when all hell
begins to break loose because at this
point a lot of its anger and frustration
in the sense that their Tire tired of
losing various Spider-Man and so to a
degree it is all kind of bubbling to the
surface the problem with this is that
there was so much anger in Rage just
kind of lingering out there the moment's
almost kind of lost right like you get
there angry you get there upset but it's
kind of like I mean okay but like were
you not as angry or upset before right
like what was so significant about Kane
the funny thing about this is that we
can kind of interpret this in a couple
different ways if you look at the
character of Jessica Drew right this
black widow from from the Ultimate
Universe she's a clone of Peter Parker
in the Ultimate Universe so for her it's
a very personal Vendetta to see a clone
killed because the death of Kane hits
very close to home for her now for the
other Spider-Man they're just pissed off
that another Spider-Man died like so
many others have but switching back to
mordlan what he does is he transitions
to the bride right to Silk and says the
spinner at the center of the web second
bitten the Unseen silken thread pulling
at the hand of fate and where silk tries
to besiege him and say like you know
what you're saying doesn't make any
sense it's all just a whole bunch of
nonsense and so on and so forth like
you're never going to win and that kind
of a thing a base basically leads to
more lung cutting the hand of silk
spilling her blood on the great web and
saying as your blood flows through these
schemes no spider totem shall ever
appear by chance that one was really the
more direct of the three but again to
kind of reiterate here silk represents
just random circumstance that leads to a
person being bitten by a radioactive
spider and becoming a Spider-Man or
Spider-Woman and this is one of the
elements of the Spider-Man Mythos as it
was changed by strazinski and continued
by Dan slot that that some fans I
wouldn't say a lot I wouldn't assign a
value to it but that some fans in
general didn't really seem to enjoy that
in years past leading up to the events
of strzinski's run and going into Dan
slots run Peter Parker was just a kid
who was bitten by a radioactive spider
so depending on how you look at it he
was in the right place at the right time
or the wrong place at the wrong time but
he was basically flying by the seat of
his pants trying to figure out how to be
a hero and that was basically it the
introduction of the other the spider
totems right the bride the Scion all
that kind of stuff kind of move Peter
Parker into this realm of being unquote
the chosen one and not everyone was on
board with that but what this did by
virtue of introducing that concept was
really kind of bring together all these
different alternate reality versions of
Peter and essentially saying that they
are all kind of destined to become
Spider-Man right whether it is a female
version of Peter Parker or a male
version of Peter Parker that in every
single Universe there is destined to be
a person who is bitten by a radioactive
spider and goes on to become that
reality's version of Spider-Man the
funny thing about this is silk in terms
of how she was explained regarding the
the concept of the bride and random
chance is that sometimes that doesn't
always happen that yes it plays out that
way but not necessarily that in addition
to that reality getting its own version
of Peter Parker sometimes you get a
different version of Spider-Man Beyond
Peter Parker now Marvel doesn't really
say it as much but the notion of like
spider-gwen for example right she's not
an alternate reality version of Peter
Parker she's an alternate reality
version of Gwen Stacy but she was bitten
by a radioactive spider nonetheless how
exactly that ties in is not fully made
clear the essence of silk seems to be
more in line with the idea of a spider
turning somebody into Spider-Man and
then a secondary bite right or just the
random happenstance of someone becoming
Spider-Man when they're not supposed to
be but regardless the master Weaver
chimes in and says curses magic and
unwanted luck midwives to all new
spiders now Scurry hide and are seen no
more the web is untangled its end draws
near right and then following that you
have more Lund who makes his way towards
the Scion to Benji basically the
youngest spider in all creation and he
says with this cut the ACT is done no
new totem shall arise no more spiders
will be born no new age can begin in
effect with the death of Benji basically
solidifies this prophecy and saying
there will never ever be another
Spider-Man or Spider-Woman in the
Multiverse again that at this point as
long as the inheritors can try to find
some way to stay alive if they kill all
the Spider-Man here then they can just
travel to the Multiverse and kill the
ones they haven't killed yet and no
other Spider-Man will crop back up and
because spiders are the inherent enemy
of the inheritors they basically wipe
out their own real competition and so
the inheritors can just inherit the
Multiverse without anybody really
standing in their way now of course this
basically leads to the Spider-Man really
Peter Parker for the main Marvel
Universe arriving just in time to yank
the knife out of moreland's hand and
keep him from killing Benji now at that
point that's when Damo steps in and says
do your theme warlon like kill the baby
with your hands if you have to it
doesn't really matter I will hold these
guys off you make sure the prophecy
comes to fruition the funny thing about
this is that of course you end up having
uh you know superior Spider-Man who goes
after damos and then Peter Parker ends
up going after more lunch but one of the
things to understand here is that more
London in a lot of ways is both
terrified of Peter Parker but also
despises Peter Parker the reason being
because while the family of Moreland
didn't really hate him or despise him
there was a lack of respect for him
because of the fact that he'd been
killed twice by Peter Parker and in fact
he had avoided the main Marvel Universe
because of the fact that he'd been
killed twice by Peter Parker and so
there is a bit of a vendetta right like
Peter Parker's the only one who was ever
able to defeat me I will overcome this
Spider-Man and then solidify my place as
being the strongest person and so that's
why you have this fight that breaks out
between these various Spiderman and
spider women really uh Peter Parker and
Superior Spider-Man against damos and
while that takes place the attention of
Uncle Ben is called right whether like
Uncle Ben you have to come and help us
and the response of Uncle Ben is I wish
I could stay and help you this web it
has portals away from here I have to go
and that's one of the things where dance
like kind of plays it fast and loose
with indicating here that basically
Uncle Ben really is a coward that he had
taken off and he had ran when it came
down to crunch time right when they
really needed him he had basically
abandoned but in the midst of all that
suddenly Karn arrives now remember this
is the reason why we covered that short
little One-Shot comic yesterday is
because that was the story where Karen
had turn coded against the inheritors
and joined the spider family because in
his mind the inheritors had basically
shunned him time and time again and
that's what he says right where bricks
and Borah are like Karen awesome you're
here right our brother's Exile has been
put to an end because Solace has been
defeated and moreland's in charge right
with him on our side this day is as good
as one and that's when Karen chimes in
and says really like uh like on on your
side that's weird because for eons this
family has spurned me shunned me brought
me nothing but pain I was never good
enough for you before why am I good
enough for you now and so he says I
renounce my inheritance I abandoned my
role as part of the inheritor family
from this day forth I fight on the side
of the spider totems and having an
inheritor on their side is a massive
Advantage because with Karn comes all
the benefits of The Inheritance right
super strength speed durability all that
kind of stuff it's enough for them to
basically offer a high level of
distraction and overcome these guys now
the problem is that more Lund gets the
upper hand on Peter Parker momentarily
but that moment he gets is all he really
needs that where he's taunted to a
degree by Silk and by Peter Parker her
in saying like the web's healing itself
too much time has passed there's nothing
you can do to end this the response to
Moreland is no all I have to do is kill
this Scion and everything's gonna be
over the problem is that when he
basically pulls back the tapestry where
the Scion's supposed to be he's met with
Spider-Man and this is where the reality
of what was going on with Uncle Ben
comes into fruition that we actually
ended up learning that while more Lund
was distracted with Peter Parker that
Uncle Ben had actually grabbed Benji and
left that's why he took off it wasn't
because he was a coward and he was
abandoning anybody it was because he
simply wanted to get out of there right
to get Benji away so long as Benji was
there whether it was just by some sheer
happenstance where some kind of
projectile hit him and killed him or
because morelon went after him and did
the deed himself if Benji were to die it
would all basically come to an end and
so in this fight as it takes place you
actually end up having this kind of this
massive Calamity where finally like
Spider-Man 2099 shows up with basically
leopard on right after him and Lady
spider were able to basically restore it
and then bring it back using 2099
technology apology superior Spider-Man
steps in and kills the master Weaver
this is a massive problem and the reason
why is because the Mastery Weaver is the
one who kept the web of life and Destiny
together he's the one that that
basically held it and kept it from
falling apart why does this matter
because the web of life and Destiny was
really interesting and this is the best
analogy that I can think of it's almost
like a voodoo doll for the Multiverse
right if you were to like set the web of
life and Destiny on fire and you were to
completely and totally destroy it you
would wipe out the Multiverse with it if
you were to somehow damage or take a
singular strand of the Web of Life in
Destiny with each strand representing a
universe if you were to isolate that
Strand and remove it from the web of
life and Destiny that universe is
isolated it cannot be accessed by
anybody from the main Marvel universe
itself I mean possibly with someone like
doctor strange but basically all doors
to that Universe are close it exists out
there by itself with no conceivable
means to to reach him unless it's
reconnected to the Web of Life and
Destiny again this is not another one of
those instances of Marvel Comics where
you have basically inability to
manipulate the Multiverse it's one of
the things we've talked about before
different people can do this in
different ways the master Weaver
basically controls the Multiverse or can
manipulate the Multiverse by
manipulating the web of life and Destiny
but then you have people like the
molecule man oh and Rhys who can just
arbitrarily travel to different
universes because the reality warping
level of power that he has the ability
to alter reality on a multiversal scale
Doctor Strange can do it by magic people
like the Fantastic Four can use
technology to create portals to go to
other universes but with the master
Weaver destroyed basically killed by
superior Spider-Man this destroys the
ability of the inheritors to basically
complete their prophecy so at this point
the game's over right The Jig Is up
there's nothing that can be done this
battle is already won the inheritors
don't have the Scion the master Weaver's
dead there's no way for the prophecy to
be completed at this point for the
various Spider-Man and spider-women it's
just mop-up Duty and so what you have
here is this just kind of giant fight
where Morlan just loses it on Peter
Parker and any fear that he had of Peter
Parker any concern he had completely
goes out the win window and where he
starts drawing on the energy of Peter
literally sucking his life force out of
him the other Spider-Man and
Spider-Woman initially go to intervene
Peter Wards them off activates his
teleportation device and teleports them
to Earth 3145 right this reality this
basically immersed in radiation the one
Universe the inheritors can't go to
because the radiation is fatal to them
and so we're initially more London
starts to seemingly succumb to this
radiation poisoning Peter refuses to
kill him and instead he tells him like
there's a bunker down there follow the
webs go save your life now the response
to this might be well all they have to
do is just find a way out but the
reality is with the master Weaver killed
there's no one that would willingly open
a portal for the inheritors so they
could Escape so it's really more by
circumstance that they're stuck in that
reality now one thing to know is that
the web of life and Destiny is intact
right the issue with this is that
without a master Weaver there are
portals there once they pass through
with no master Weaver there's really no
way for them to come back and for the
most part it's one of those things where
it's kind of like the day's been saved
everything's kind of winding down and
everything's cool the problem is that in
the midst of all that suddenly all their
spider senses start going crazy and the
reason why is because someone is
screwing with the web of life and
Destiny and that's when they find out
it's superior Spider-Man now here's the
funny thing about this Dr Octopus as we
mentioned before had long since figured
out that the Peter Parker that's here in
spider-verse is not the past version of
Peter Parker before Dr Octopus took over
his body it's the future version which
basically told Otto Octavius Peter
eventually gets his body back and so out
of a desire to ensure that he stays The
Superior Spider-Man and he doesn't have
to worry about Peter returning to his
own body he's basically destroying the
web of life and Destiny now again if
this web is completely destroyed the
Multiverse will be destroyed along with
it presumably even their own Universe
right reality itself will cease to exist
this is one of those instances where it
was kind of divisive among fans but I
love the motivation here and the reason
why is because Auto Octavius is largely
a man of logic in reason he very rarely
ever gives way to emotional impulse this
is an emotional impulse his desire to
Stage Spider-Man is so overwhelming
right because he sees himself as being
The Superior Spider-Man in a lot of ways
he was he was a better Spider-Man than
Peter Parker was but he sees himself as
being better he doesn't want to go back
to who he was before now the other part
of that is remember in dying wish it was
basically established that Dr octopus's
body was essentially dying if the future
comes to fruition and Peter gets his
body back then the Assumption here or
the belief by Dr Octopus is that he'll
basically die because there'll be
nowhere for his Spirit to go right his
physical body is dead there's nowhere
for him to go or nothing that he can do
and so while the other Spider-Man and
Spider-Woman are sent back to their
realities before the web is totally
destroyed what it does is it allows
Dan's slot to kind of dwindle things
down and basically lead to a fight kind
of a sucking conflict and really more of
a final conflict between superior
Spider-Man and Peter Parker from The
main Marvel Universe now you do have
like Anya Corazon and a few people there
that are basically getting involved but
one of the things that happens and it's
kind of an important thing here is that
as Anya Corazon is reading this knife
this kind of a the ceremonial dagger
that was used for the sacrifice that it
does have the language of the totems
written on it and one of the things it
says is there shall always be a master
Weaver spinning at the center of the web
basically when one master Weaver dies
because of the fact that it's just fate
it's always destined to happen someone
will always take their place the bigger
concern here is how long before that
happens is it simply just a chain of
reactions and by virtue of impulses or
just circumstance somebody will just
become the master weaver or is it some
kind of big ceremonial thing where the
energy of the master Weaver leaves his
body and then joins into someone else
and they end up becoming the new Master
Weaver instead if anything it really is
the former right it's just kind of
circumstance that leads to it that Silk
initially believes she's the one that's
destined to become the new Master Weaver
because the inheritors kept calling her
the spinner at the center of the web and
that maybe she's the one who's supposed
to do it but again as this Fight
Continues on between these guys on your
reveals the reality of what it means to
become the master Weaver in saying it's
a lifetime sentence that once a person
becomes the master Weaver the only way
to leave that position is to be killed
that once you accept that role that's
your role for all eternity so long as
you're never killed by anybody and so
what actually ends up happening is that
Karn essentially steps up and saying
like I was cast out by my family for
centuries like there's nothing for me
here right and my goal has always been
to explore the Multiverse what better
way to do that than to be the master
Weaver and observe it right to look into
all these different things but the funny
thing is that Silk basically steps up
and says no like I've decided I'm gonna
be the one to do it right I'll put on
his gear get into the machine and when
she takes off his helmet she's kind of
like well I always kind of assume the
master Weaver will be somebody that I
knew she says I've never seen that face
before and Karen says but I have and
that's what it's basically revealed that
the master Weaver is actually the future
version of Karn in essence Karn is the
one who is destined to become the new
Master Weaver and so by putting his
staff spear whatever you want to call it
inside the machine that it basically
allows him to take the place of the
master weaver or at least he replaces
older self to Dawn the moniker of the
master Weaver and then to begin
repairing the web of life and Destiny at
this point there's nothing really
superior Spider-Man can do because of
the fact that the web is being repaired
superior Spider-Man is ultimately
teleported back to the main Marvel
Universe and basically pops up almost
the moment he left and that's why
whenever you go and you read superior
Spider-Man that you go into one issue
superior Spider-Man vanishes and then
reappears immediately after that this is
how all that happened the entirety of
spider-verse takes place between those
moments the other part of this and this
is something that was really really cool
is that it basically starts tying into
the events of the incursions that while
the master Weaver is repairing the web
of life and Destiny that in turn the
problem here is that for Billy Braddock
he can't go home to his own Universe the
reason why is because it's been wiped
out and when the question is asked no
wait a minute like what happened to this
entire universe the response to
Spider-Man UK is it's the incur that's
right Cosmic phenomena that just been
wiping out whole realities now again we
know that was like the beyonders and
really it was Dr Doom who basically
destroyed it all when he ended up
opening that box of molecule man and
detonating them all in front of the
beyonders and killing them wiping out
pretty much all that was left to the
Multiverse minus two universes this
particular instance takes place before
the story of Brian Braddock when he
comes back and says like the Captain
Britain Corps has been wiped out this
takes place before that that when Billy
Braddock looks on like his whole
universe has been totally destroyed that
the Captain Britain Corps has been
investigating it and that he felt like
he should have been there so the only
real destination left for him is to
travel to the Starlight Citadel which is
the the kind of main base of operations
for the Captain Britain Corps and as we
know from the incursions that Spider-Man
UK will basically end up being killed
alongside all the other Captain britons
when Brian Braddock is thrown from the
meeting by saturnin and left to go tell
the new Avengers everything that it that
it basically transpired and so
ultimately this is when we kind of get
this actual finality to it that the
inheritors are basically stranded in
Earth 3145 with no discernible means of
being able to escape that you do have
the body of the other right of Cain
himself this actually just kind of there
only for an arm to emerge and for us to
basically realize that Kane is
essentially being reborn and he's going
to return as the Scarlet Spider and then
of course Peter Parker returns back to
his point in the timeline and everything
basically begins to wrap up right with
him kind of going forward doing his
thing being the friendly neighborhood
Spider-Man and so on and so forth but
with that being said guys this was
spider-verse and I love this story I
absolutely loved the spider-verse event
only took us like three weeks to finish
the whole thing but with that being said
guys we're going to bring this to an end
and for all you guys who are big fans of
Spider-Man I'm sorry after this we're
taking a break
I love I I love spider versus much of
the next guy but I need a break from
Spider-Man for a little while but anyway
guys thank you for watching and I will
catch you all later
peace